ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CAPPIELLO CHIANG DALLY DODD
DORADO. GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HILL
WITH SO. TADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MONNING
MORE LOCK. MERRELL NIELSEN PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE NUMBER BY KATHY
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. THANK YOU MEMBERS IN
WALKING A LOOKING FOR TO
ANOTHER PRODUCTIVE DAY AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE ALL MEMBERS OR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REALM THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE WE WILL
OPEN WITH A MOMENT OF SILENCE
TO HONOR THOSE THAT LOST THEIR
LIVES WITH NINE ELEVEN FOLLOWED
BY OUR OUR DAILY DEVOTION BY
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
FOLLOWED BY THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE FROM A GREAT SENATOR
FROM EAST BAY. CENTER Y. CASKEY
WITH THAT IF YOU GET ALL DIRE
HEADS AND JOIN ME A MOMENT
SILENCE FOR THOSE A LOSS OF
LIFE ON NINE ELEVEN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SISTER MICHELLE. GOD
OF MYSTERY ON THIS ANNIVERSARY
OF NINE ELEVEN WE PRAY THE
PRAYER OF FATHER MYCHAL JUDGE
NEW YORK CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
CHAPLAIN AND FIRST CERTIFIED
FATALITY OF THE ATTACKS. HIS
PRAYER LORD TAKE ME WHERE YOU
WANT ME TO GO. LET ME MAYES WHO
YOU WANT ME TO MEET. TELL ME
WHAT SHE WANTS ME TO SAY. AND
KEEP ME OUT OF YOUR WAY. AS WE
REMEMBER THOSE WHO DIED IN NEW
YORK WASHINGTON DC AND
PENNSYLVANIA. AND ALL WHO RISK
THEIR LIVES TO SAVE OTHERS WE
ASK YOUR BLESSING ON THOSE WHO
STILL PUT THE LIVES OF OTHERS
BEFORE THEIR OWN. HELP US TO
DEEPEN OUR COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE. AND MAY WE WITNESS
TO OUR DETERMINATION TO BECOME
A BELOVED COMMUNITY. RECONCILE
TO ONE ANOTHER IN LOVE A MAN.
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MEMBER SO HERE'S THE
PLAN FOR TODAY WE'RE GONNA GO
TO APPROXIMATELY NOON WHERE WE
WILL TAKE A ONE HOUR BREAK AT
THAT TIME FOOD WILL BE SERVED
AS WELL AS WILL BE HAVING AS A
NUMBER OF COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN
THOSE COMMITTEE CHAIRS WILL NOW
SAT PRIOR TO THAT. BOB
FOLLOWING THAT BREAK WERE TO
COME BACK AND WORK AS LONG AS
THE MAJORITY LEADER WANTS TO
WORK S. AND LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
PRODUCTIVE DAY AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR I LIKE TO CALL ON
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT OF PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
COUPLE OF MOMENTS AND JUST
SHORT MOMENTS TO BRING OUR
ATTENTION TO THE SOLEMN THIS OF
THIS PARTICULAR DAY. OF NINE
ELEVEN. AND IT'S REALLY A
DIFFICULT THING TO COME UP WITH
TO SAY. DO YOU CELEBRATE NINE
ELEVEN DO YOU. YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WHAT'S THE PROPER TERM DO
YOU MOURN NINE ELEVEN. DO YOU
COMMEMORATE NINE ELEVEN. AND. I
WOULD LIKE TO STAND TODAY TO
REMEMBER NINE ELEVEN. AND
GROWING UP AS A CHILD. A
PARTICULAR DAY THAT MY PARENTS
SHARED WITH ME OFTEN IS A WHERE
THEY WERE IN NOVEMBER OF
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE WHEN
PRESIDENT JOHN F. KENNEDY WAS
SHOT AND KILLED IN DALLAS TEXAS.
AND I THINK FOR OUR GENERATION
TODAY. THAT DAY IS SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND ONE. AND
I REMEMBER THAT DAY VERY
CLEARLY. I WORKED ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES FROM MY HOUSE AND
ARRIVED AT MY OFFICE AT ABOUT
SEVEN THIRTY IN THE MORNING AND
HADN'T HAD THE NEWS HONOR OR
ANYTHING ELSE AND I WAS THE
FIRST ONE IN THE OFFICE THAT
DAY WE HAD A BIG SCREEN TV AND
IN ONE OF THE OFFICES AND I GOT
A PHONE CALL. AND ALL IT SAID
WAS TURN ON THE TV. THAT'S WHY
ONE OF THE OFFICE I TURN ON THE
TV. AND. RIGHT THERE ON THE
TELEVISION OR WOW THE TWIN
TOWERS ONE OF THEM A BLAZE AND
ON FIRE. AND THEN AS I WAS
WATCHING AT THE SECOND ONE WAS
STRUCK AND HIT. AS I WAS
WATCHING A LIVE ON TELEVISION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
THE DAY THAT. OF COURSE NONE OF
US WILL EVER FORGET. AND
SOMETIMES WE HAVE A HABIT OF
YOU KNOW PUTTING THOSE KIND OF
YOU KNOW ONCE WE LIVED THROUGH
THE MOMENT AND GET THROUGH IT.
WE KIND OF PUT IT ASIDE AND
DON'T PAY. VERY MUCH MORE
ATTENTION TO IT. BUT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AT THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY FAIR THEY HAD A
TRAVELING NINE ELEVEN MUSEUM.
WITH SOME OF THE ARTIFACTS FROM
THE NEW YORK MUSEUM. AND THEN I
WAS REMINDED OF IT THIS MORNING.
AND IF YOU'VE NOT DONE THIS I
WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TAKE THE TIME YOU CAN YOU SEE
IT AND HEAR MOST OF THEM.
ONLINE NOWADAYS. BUT LISTEN TO
THE PHONE CALLS. THE FINAL
PHONE CALLS. I HAVE A HUSBAND
CALLING THEIR WIVES. GOV WHY
HE'S CALLING THEIR HUSBANDS.
MONTHS THEIR KIDS. HEY BABY.
I'M ON AN AIRPLANE. AND WE'VE
BEEN. I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'RE
GOING. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT. BUT I WANT
YOU TO KNOW. THAT I LOVE YOU. I
LOVE YOU BABY. TELL THE KIDS.
TELL MY PARENTS. I HOPE I GET
TO SEE YOU AGAIN. I THINK THE
SOLOMON AS OF THE DAY. BECOMES
MORE TRUE. AND MORE REAL. AS
YOU LISTEN TO THOSE PHONE CALLS.
FROM THOSE AIRPLANES. JUST
PRIOR TO THEM CRASHING INTO THE
BUILDINGS ARE CRASHING INTO THE
FIELD IN PENNSYLVANIA. AND I
HOPE THAT WE ALL WILL BE ABLE
TO SAY. THAT WE WILL NEVER
FORGET. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU CENTER
JONES GENERAL ROCK. YOU KNOW IN.
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
ONE I WAS I WAS IN FACT TO. THE
GENERAL. LONG TIME AGO IT SEEMS
AND I WAS ASSIGNED TO THE
PENTAGON AND I HAD A TEAM OF
FOLKS WHO. SOMEWHERE RESERVISTS
PART TIMERS SOMEWHERE FULL
TIMERS. OUR OFFICE OUR LITTLE
OFFICE WAS ON THE IN THE
SEBRING IN THOSE YOU'VE BEEN TO
THE PENTAGON KNOW THAT. IN THE
RING YOU GET WINDOWS AND- THE
RINGS YOUR. RINGS AND AS YOU GO
AND MOVE IN WORD YOU DON'T HAVE
WINDOWS YOU HAVE LITTLE OFFICES
AND IN FACT OUR OFFICE. WAS IN
THE OLD. CAFETERIA AREA IN
THESE FOOD PREPARATION AREA IN
FACT I STILL REMEMBER THE THOSE
YOURS OLD AS I AM MAY REMEMBER
GREEN. TILES THOSE LINOLEUM
TYPE TILE THAT WE USED TO SEE
IN SCHOOLS AND THAT'S HOW I
KNEW WERE MY OFFICE WAS IF I
EVER GOT LOST I LOOK FOR THE
GREEN TILE. SO I HAD A CREW IN
THERE AND THE PENTAGON ON
SEPTEMBER ELEVEN. I WAS
ACTUALLY IS A PART TIMER I HAD
ENOUGH IS THERE BUT I ALSO HAD
A LAW PRACTICE IN RIVERSIDE AND
I. WE WORKED PART TIME IN THE
PENTAGON. MY BOSS AT THE TIME
WAS THE JUDGE ADVOCATE GENERAL
AND I WAS ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO
MEET UP WITH HIM. A DAY OR SO
BEFORE AND BE THERE ON DUTY TO.
GO ON ONE TRIP OR ANOTHER I
CAN'T REMEMBER. BUT FRANKLY I
HAD SOMETHING COME UP IN LAW
PRACTICE AND I HAD TO CANCEL
THAT TRIP. BUT I REMEMBER AS MY
COLLEAGUE. FROM CITY AB COUNTY%
JUST RECOUNTED I REMEMBER
GETTING DRESSED FOR THIS LAW
THING THAT I HAD TO DO IN THE
MORNING I FORGET EXACTLY WHAT
TIME WAS SO. EIGHT SOMETHING.
AND I REMEMBER WATCHING THE
PLANES GO INTO THE TOWERS. AND
THEN THE NEXT THING I REMEMBER
IS HEARING ABOUT A PLANE THAT
WENT INTO THE PENTAGON. AND THE
FOLKS THAT WORKED FOR ME WERE
IN THE PENTAGON THAT THAT DAY.
NOW. FORTUNATELY FOR THEM THE
PENTAGON WITH ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE
IS BIG IS OF CITY OF NORCO IN
MY SENATE DISTRICT. WHAT THEY
FELT WAS THE BUILDING MOVE
WHICH IMAGINE THE PENTAGON
MOVING. THE ALARMS GOING OFF
THE SMELL OF SMOKE AND THEN
SOME SMOKE THAT EVENTUALLY
MOVED THROUGH THE CORNERS. AND
PEOPLE TELLING THEM TO EVACUATE
AND LEADING THEM. LEADING THEM
FROM THEIR OFFICES DOWN TO THE
COURTYARD AND OUTSIDE OF THE
PENTAGON. SO THEY WERE VERY
VERY FORTUNATE TEN AND THEY
SPOKE TO ME ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE NOT INJURED IN ANY WAY.
THEY SPEND DAYS OUTSIDE OF THE
PENTAGON THEIR CARS LEFT IN THE
PARKING LOT. THEY WERE
TRAUMATIZED BY THAT PARTICULAR
EVENTS. THE COLONEL THE CHIEF
MASTER SERGEANT AND SOME OTHERS.
BUT THEY WERE VERY VERY LUCKY
BECAUSE OTHERS WERE NOT SO
FORTUNATE. MY IMMEDIATE
SUPERIOR WAS TRAPPED IN LONDON
AT THE TIME HE WAS OVER ON A
NAVY MISSION BECAUSE HIS
CIVILIAN JOB WAS THE DEPUTY.
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE NAVY. BUT HIS
VERY CLOSE FRIEND. WAS THE
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE MARINE
CORPS AND HIS OFFICE
UNFORTUNATELY WAS RIGHT ABOVE
WHERE THE PLANE WENT INTO THE
PENTAGON AND KILL THE ARMY
THREE STAR GENERAL WHO WAS
CHIEF OF ARMY PERSONNEL. AND IN
TALKING TO THIS GENTLEMAN A
CIVILIAN LAWYER WHO WAS THE
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE MARINE
CORPS. HE HAD QUITE AN
EXPERIENCE. IT RIPPED THE FLOOR
OUT FROM UNDER HIS OFFICE HE
COULD LOOK DOWN INTO THE FLAMES
THAT WERE CAUSED BY THE PLANE
BUT HE COULD NOT GET OUT OF HIS
OFFICE BECAUSE THE IMPACTED
JAMMED THE OFFICE DOOR AND HE
WAS TRAPPED. FORTUNATELY FOR
HIM. HE WAS ASSIGNED BECAUSE OF
HIS ELEVATED POSITION. THE MOST
BURLY OF MARINE CORPS NCOS WHO
TOOK THE DOOR AND RIPPED THE
DOOR OFF THE HINGES TO GET HIM
OUT OF THAT OFFICE. BUT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE EXPERIENCES OF
OTHER AND MANY MANY OTHERS WE
HAD THE AIRFORCE SURGEON
GENERAL A THREE STAR GENERAL.
RUN OUT HE WAS EVACUATED TO
WITH HIS OTHER MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. TAKE HIS TIE OFTEN
BEGIN TREATING PEOPLE IN THE
PARKING LOT. OF THE PENTAGON.
SO THERE WAS NOT ONE SINGLE
PERSON ON THIS DAY THE
SEPTEMBER ELEVEN WHO WAS
UNAFFECTED AND IF YOU STOP AND
THINK ABOUT IT. GOING FROM A
TIME OF RELATIVE PEACE IN A
SENSE. TO A TIME OF ABSOLUTE
CONFLICT WE ALL WERE DRAWN INTO
THAT SITUATION. WE ALL WERE
IMPACTED BY THAT. THE HEROES
THAT DAY AND WE TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO SERVICE HEROES AND
THEY ALL OUR HEROES BUT THERE
WERE TRUE HEROES THAT DAY
PEOPLE WHO RAN BACK INTO THE
PENTAGON WITHOUT. THOUGHT OF
THEIR OWN SAFETY. TO ATTEMPT TO
BRING PEOPLE OUT TO ATTEMPT TO
FIND THE NAVY PERSONNEL IN THAT
COMMUNICATIONS UNIT. IN
ADDITION TO THAT ARMY THREE
STAR GENERAL WHO WERE ALSO.
KILLED AND SERIOUSLY INJURED BY
THE PLANE GOING INTO THE
PENTAGON. SO IT'S NOT A DAY
THAT GOES BY THAT I DON'T THINK
ABOUT. THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN
NEW YORK CITY. THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE KILLED OR SERIOUSLY
INJURED AND EVEN THOSE WHO.
WE'RE NOT PHYSICALLY INJURED
BUT WERE. IMPACTED MENTALLY. BY
THAT PARTICULAR DAY SO. WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THEM WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THOSE IN
PENNSYLVANIA. ON THAT PLANE AND
WE SHOULD REMEMBER WHY WE DO
WHAT WE DO HERE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE INDICATED WINNIE.
SPOKE ABOUT THE WORDS ABOVE THE
DíAS WE ARE HERE TO PRESERVE
PEOPLE'S LIBERTY AND HELP TO
SELL JUST AS MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM. WHETHER IT'S A
CIVILIAN UNIFORM OR WHETHER
IT'S A MILLION MILITARY UNIFORM
DO AROUND THE WORLD EVERY
SINGLE DAY. SO I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN ASKING EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU. TO REMEMBER
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TO REMEMBER
THE SACRIFICES THAT WERE MADE
THAT DAY AND TO REMEMBER THE
CHALLENGE FRANKLY THAT WAS
ISSUED TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US. TO PRESERVE FREEDOM. TO
PRESERVE LIBERTY AND TO NOT LET
THOSE FOLKS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES THAT DAY. DO SO IN VAIN.
THANK YOU GENERAL ROSS FOR
SHARING ALL THAT I THINK WE'D
ALSO BE REMISS WITHOUT
ACKNOWLEDGING ALL THE FIRST
RESPONDERSCLEARLY THOSE A WIN
IN TODAY THE TWIN TOWERS AND
THEY'RE STILL RAMIFICATIONS
TODAY SO MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE SUFFERED ILL EFFECTS FROM
THE FROM THE SUBSTANCES THAT
THEY WERE EXPOSED TO AND
COURSES AT ADVERSELY AFFECTS
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL. SO AT
THIS TIME WE MOVE ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WHICH WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
NOW MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS THE NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO RULE TWENTY NINE
TEN DE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
ITEM SIXTY FIVE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE. ITEM SEVENTY NINE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN
ITEM ONE TWELVE AND ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE. PURSUANT TO RULE
PURSUANT TO SEVERAL TWENTY NINE
TEN BE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
ITEM FOURTEEN. PURSUANT TO
REGARD TO SENATE WROTE TWENTY
NINE TEN SEE THE PHONE BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM SEVENTEEN AN
ITEM EIGHTEEN. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION THE
DAILY FILE WILL MOVE TO SECOND
READING FILE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SOME OF THE ONE
OH NINE SENATE BILL. ONE TWELVE
ONE THIRTEEN ONE FOURTEEN ONE
FIFTEEN ONE SIXTEEN ONE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING
FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. AND THAT
WOULD TAKE US TO ITEM TWENTY
CENTER CUT THE ERA ARE YOU
PREPARED IN YOU ARE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY BY SENATOR
CAFIERO AN ACT RELATING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB
TWO THIRTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL WE
WILL REDUCE THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE BY POLICE OFFICERS AND
CHANGE THE CULTURE IN THE
WORKPLACE OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY RESOLVED
CONFLICTS IN DEFINITIONS AND
ALSO MADE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
MIRROR THE LANGUAGE ADOPTED IN
AB THREE NINETY TWO I WANT TO
THANK THE PRO TEM THE SPEAKER
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE HELP ON THIS BILL.
AND I THINK YOU AND IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE CONCURRENTLY. ANY FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION MADAM PRO
TEM. Q. JUST VERY QUICKLY I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR OF FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD SHE REFERENCE THE
OTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE PASSED AB THREE NINETY TWO
THIS BILL TWO THIRTY IT'S
REALLY A COMPANION PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S DESIGNED TO.
COVER ALL THE BASES IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OUR COMMUNITY AND I AM
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIS IS A
NATIONAL CONVERSATION AND I'M
VERY PROUD THAT WE DID THE WORK
BY THE LEADERSHIP THE GOVERNOR
THE SPEAKER THE MEMBERS. WHO
AUTHOR THESE BILLS MY COLLEAGUE
BUT ALSO THIS CHAMBER BOTH
CHAMBERS UNDERSTANDING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS REALLY TAKEN A
STEP FORWARD AND SET THE TONE
OF FOR WHAT CAN BE DONE IF WE
REALLY FIND A WAY TO WORK
TOGETHER SO IT'S MY THANKS TO
THE AUTHOR IT'S MY THANKS TO
LEADERSHIP TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A THIS IS AN
EFFORT THAT WE ALL GOT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE I
ANTICIPATE. A VERY POSITIVE
VOTE ON THIS FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE HOUSE BECAUSE THIS IS THE
WORK THAT WE DID AND I'M
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF THE WORK
THANK YOU I. STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE FROM ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEN TO PRO TEN SEEING NO OTHER
MIKE SET CENTER COPIER YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE IN A THANK YOU TO MATTER
PRO. TEM THANK YOU WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. HI BILL I PURCHASE BY
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE ALSO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BUYER TADO I
JACKSON BY JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK I'M REAL
BY NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN I STONE.
BY NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
CALL WITHOUT WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEMBERS WHO LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. THING
NINE WORK TAKE UP NEXT FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR
WINNER YOU PREPARED. HE HAS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SYMBOL FOR EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AN
APPLE INTO CRIMES. CENTER
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FOR EIGHTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER WHICH ELIMINATES THE
MANDATORY ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY COUNTY JAIL SENTENCE. THAT
A JUDGE IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED
TO IMPOSE FOR ANYONE GIVEN
SPECIFIC GIVEN PROBATION FOR
SPECIFIC LOW LEVEL DRUG RELATED
OFFENSES. THIS BILL INSTEAD IT
RETURNS A JUDGE'S DISCRETION TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO IMPOSE
THIS JAIL TIME AS A CONDITION
OF THE KIND INSPIRATION. TO BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT GET RID OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY COUNTY JAIL TIME. BUT
INSTEAD OF IT BEING MANDATORY
THE JUDGE WOULD HAVE DISCRETION
WHETHER OR NOT TO OPPOSE IT.
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES ARE
COSTLY OVERLY PUNITIVE IN AN
EFFECTIVE METHOD FOR DETERRING
DRUG RELATED CRIMES.
FURTHERMORE INCARCERATING MORE
INDIVIDUALS ONLY CONTINUES TO
ADD PRESSURE ON ARE ALREADY
OVERCROWDED AND BORDERLINE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PRISON
FACILITIES. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS BILL STILL ALLOWS
JUDGES TO IMPOSE. THE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IF THEY
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE. AND
ALSO TO BE CLEAR SERIOUS DRUG
OFFENSES ARE NOT ENCOMPASS BY
THIS BILL. BEAR IN ELIGIBLE FOR
PROBATION AND NOT INCLUDED
UNDER THIS BILL. AB FORTY FOUR
REMOVES ARBITRARY MANDATORY
JAIL TIME AND GIVES COURTS THE
ABILITY TO DECIDE WHETHER JAIL
TIME MAKES SENSE FOR A
PARTICULAR LOW LEVEL DRUG
OFFENDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL AYE PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. CHIANG NO DALY. DODD.
I DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI GROW. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO.
NO JACKSON HI JONES. NO NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONEY I'M MORE LOCK MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER. BY
KELSEY I WINNER BY WILK NOW.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
MISSING MEMBER. ALLEN. I'M
SORRY SIR WIENER MOVES TO CALL.
NO MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO CENTER
REQUIRE IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S
PREPARED SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL I MEAN PLEASE READ
A SOME OF THE SEVENTEEN A SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN
ACT RELATED TO ELECTIONS. THERE
ARE REQUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS RESIDENT GOOD MORNING RISE
RISEN AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE MEMBER BERMAN AND
APPRECIATE ALL HIS HARD WORK ON
THIS. THIS BILL PROVIDES
CLARITY FOR POLL WORKERS IN
ENSURE VOTERS HAVE EASY ACCESS
TO VOTER GUIDE INFORMATION. THE
BILL CLARIFIES THAT A PERSON
MAY NOT BE PROHIBITED MAY NOT
BE PROHIBITED FROM USING
ELECTRONIC DEVICE AT A POLLING
PLACE. PROVIDED THAT THE USE%
DOES NOT CONFLICT WITH OUR
ALLIES ENSURING THAT VOTING IS
PRIVATE IN FREE FROM
INTIMIDATION. CANDIDLY IT'S
ABOUT TIME THAT THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD HAS NO OPPOSITION. AS
WE SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SIR REQUIRE ANY
FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES BELL I PURCHASE.
BRADFORD BY CARRIER BY CHIANG
BY DELHI. DODD. BY DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. GROWTH BY HERTZBERG.
I HILL. I HIGHWAY SO DIRE TADO
BY JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA.
I'M MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL BY
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. NIELSEN. HI PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER. IA CATHY BY WINNER BY
WILK HI. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS.
ALLEN ATKINS. I BATES. GORGEOUS.
DALY HI HI GONZALEZ. HIGH
MORALE MORRELL NO STONE. THE
CENTER MOVES THE CALL NOW THE
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE CENTER DORADO
ARE YOU PREPARED. PASS ON FILE.
WITH THAT WE MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY THREE. AND THAT
WOULD BE SENATOR HILL AND
CENTER HILL IS PREPARED SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
CYNICAL A SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN RELATING
TO THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES CAMPAIGN
SPENDING ON BALLOT MEASURES HAS
REACHED UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN SPENT IN CALIFORNIA ON
BALLOT MEASURES HAD SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE TRY TO HIDE
THE TRUE IDENTITIES OF TOP
DONORS AFTER EMPLOYMENT OFTEN
EMPLOYING MISLEADING NAMES OR
BY MAKING THEM DIFFICULT TO
READ IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THE
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
INTRODUCED AB TWO FORTY NINE
WHICH ALLOWED VOTERS TO MORE
EASILY SEE THE TOP FUNDERS OF
BALLOT MEASURES AND INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE ADS TELEVISION ADS
ARE NOW REQUIRED AS WE KNOW TO
CHAU DISCLOSURES FOR FIVE
SECONDS LISTING THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS OF THAT AD. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT LAST YEAR
EXTENDED THE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS TO SOCIAL MEDIA
AND POLITICAL ADVERTISING SINCE
PASSAGE OF AB TWO FORTY NINE IN
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION RAISED A NUMBER OF
SMALL ISSUES THAT NEEDED
FURTHER CLARIFICATION AB EIGHT
SIXTY FORTUNATELY SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS. THIS
MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU CENTER
HILL ANY FURTHER DEBATER
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
SELECT A AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL FIVE LARGEST AYE BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG AYE
DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TACO HI
JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK I AM A REAL.
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER.
FIVE A CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK BY. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS
ALLEN BATES. GROVE I AM RAIL.
STONE HI. CENTER HILL MOVES THE
CALL NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE ONE
FORTY FOUR CENTER GONZALEZ
PASSES ON FILE. SITTING ON TO
SENATOR MCGUIRE. AND MISTER
MCGUIRE IS READY SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SENATOR REQUIRE.
MANY TEMPERATE PACIFY THANK YOU.
FAIR ENOUGH. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT AND THAT
WOULD BE SENATOR ALLEN WHOSE.
WILL TEMPORARILY PASS HE'S
PRESENTING A BILL IN THE OTHER
HOUSE SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY CENTER REQUIRE
YOU PREPARED TO DO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY. OKAY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THE ONE SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AN ACT
RELATING TO MOBILE HOMES.
CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A PRESENT APPRECIATE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH A TAX
ABATEMENT PROGRAM IS CALLED THE
REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA. IT'S A PROGRAM
COMMONSENSE FOR MOBILE OWNERS
WHO ARE UNABLE TO TRANSFER
TITLE THEIR HOMES INTO THEIR
NAMES DUE TO TAX AND LINKED AND
SEES THAT WORKER BY THE PRIOR
OWNER. SINCE THE PROGRAM
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN MOBILE MORE SO SAVED
OVER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION THE
PROGRAM IS ON PACE TO BE A
SIGNAL HOMEOWNERS TWO MILLION
BY THE TIME IT SUNSETS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. INTO THIS YEAR
AB ONE SEVEN THREE WOULD EXTEND
THE SUNSET ON THE REGISTER YOUR
MOBILE HOME CALIFORNIA TAX
ABATEMENT PROGRAM FOR TWELVE
MONTHS TO CONTINUE TO HELP
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS THE NAME IS
TAKEN CENTER PREPARATIONS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION FROM THE
BILL. APPRECIATE AS A MEMBER
CHALLENGES WORK RESPECTFUL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY FURTHER.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION THING NOW
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BILL BY BURGESS AYE
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DELHI HI DODD. HI DORADO HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO HIGHER TADO. I JACKSON BY
JONES BY LEYVA BY MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONEY. BY MORE
LOCKED NO MORRELL. BY NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER BY STERN
BY STONE. I AMBERG OUR CASKEY I
WINNER BY WILK BY. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS ALAN. ALLEN I CHANGE.
GROWTH. CHENEY I GROVE HI. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO THERE
MCGUIRE IS PREPARED TO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AN ACT
RELATING TO THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
A PRESENT APPRECIATED SIR A
SIMILAR GLORIA HAS BEEN WORKING
HARD AND EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE AND HAS REALLY BROUGHT
FORWARD A WONDERFUL COMPROMISES
CAN RESTRUCTURE. THE SAN DIEGO
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
pBOARD AND DIRECT THEM TO
INCREASE THEIR PROGRAM
RANSPARENCY. BEFORE TWENTY
THREE MODIFIES THE BOARD
COMPOSITION TO INCLUDE
REPRESENTATION FROM ADDITIONAL
SAN DIEGO CITIES AND OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IT ALSO INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING THE
BOARD TO AMONG OTHER THINGS
CREATE A SEPARATE WEBSITE APPLY
FOR. STATE WHY GRANT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS EVALUATE THEIR PUBLIC
COMPLAIN COMMA PROCESS AND
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
COMPREHENSIVE AIR MONITORING
PROGRAMS. BEFORE TWENTY THREE
SUPPORTED BY DIVERSE COALITION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL. JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT OF. THANK YOU SIR
ANY FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL I PURCHASE NO BRADFORD I
CARRY ERA I CHIANG. NO DALY.
DODD HI DORADO I GALGIANI. BY
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I WITH SO.
HIGHER TADO I JACKSON. HI JONES
NO LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK. NO MORALE NOTE NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE NO BURKE OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. GOV NOW THIS
IS SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS DELI NO. WILK WHAT NOW.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE CENTER GLAZER IS
PREPARED SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND ACTUALLY IN THE CAMPUS.
THERE GLAZER. MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. HI THIS BILL
INCLUDE THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL IN THE LEGISLATURE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS I THAT
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS IS
CONDUCTED BY THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES OF BOTH
HOUSES. SAYS PROVIDES FOR
STRONG LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OVER EACH BOARD'S LICENSING
PROGRAM PHYSICAL CONDITION AND
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS CURRENTLY
THIRTY SIX BOARDS IN EUROS
UNDER THE- DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. THE ONLY
EXCEPTION IS THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL WHICH OF
COURSE LICENSES CERTAIN
CANNABIS BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE. WITHOUT THE STRUCTURE IN
SCHEDULE SUNSET REVIEW THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL DOES
NOT RECEIVE THE OVERSIGHT THAT
WE WOULD EXPECT IN AND IT NEEDS
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY MAKE
THAT BUREAU GO THROUGH THAT
SAME PROCESS IS ALL THE OTHER
BOARDS. IN EUROS. AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I'VE A.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER. A FURTHER
DEBATERS KASSIAN. SEEING NO
MIKE SAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN HI ARCHULETA BY
ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL BY
BURGESS AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO BY. CHIANG BY DALY
AYE DODD. I JACKSON AYE JONES
HI LEYVA. I MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
BY MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. BY
AMARILLO. NIELSEN I PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBER I WOULD COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS GALGIANI BY.
GROWTH MORRELL. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE CENTER
BORDERS ARE YOU PREPARED AND HE
IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS. THEIR
BARGES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NIZARI IN THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE BOARDS OF CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS TO DIVEST PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT FUNDS FOR
MANY INVESTMENT VEHICLE OWNED
BY THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY. THE
LIQUIDATION OF INVESTMENTS IN
TURKEY IS CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF A FEDERAL LAW
ISSUING SANCTIONS AGAINST
TURKEY FOR FAILING TO RECOGNIZE
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. THIS
CONTINGENCY CLAUSE INJURES
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY TO DIVEST
FROM TURKEY REMAINS CONSISTENT
WITH PAST DIVESTMENT FROM FOUR
NATIONS INCLUDING SUDAN AND
IRAN. IN THAT PERSON STIRS WILL
NOT DIVEST UNTIL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN ACTION
FIRST. ALSO THIS BILL INCLUDES
A PROVISION PROTECTING THE
BOARDS OF CALPERS MCALISTER'S
BY STATING ACTIONS TAKEN TO
ALIGN WITH THIS BILL ARE NOT
REQUIRED IF THEY VIOLATE THE
BOARDS FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITIES. FURTHER
THERE'S A PROVISION INDEMNIFY
IN THE BOARDS IN EMPLOYEES FROM
CLAIMS BROUGHT FORTH BY ACTIONS
TAKEN IN ACCORDANCE WITH THIS
BILL. THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEYS
AND WILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE
THE GENOCIDE IN THEIR
UNRELENTING CAMPAIGN TO DENY
THE GENOCIDE CONTINUES TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ARMENIANS
GREEKS AND ASSYRIANS WHO
SUFFERED THE HANDS OF THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAR POLICY ON
THE GENOCIDE AS DEMONSTRATED BY
DECADES OF LEGISLATIVE
RESOLUTIONS AND GUBERNATORIAL
PROCLAMATIONS. ALLOWING PENSION
PLANS TO MAINTAIN HOLDINGS IN
PUBLIC TRUST THAT ARE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT BONDS INDIRECTLY
SUBSIDIZES TURKISH DENIAL OF
THE GENOCIDE THIS BILL
CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACT APPROPRIATELY
AGAINST COUNTRIES THAT HAVE A
RECORD OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE A
DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU IN
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR
BARGES ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. THING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BELL. BY BURGESS BY
BRADFORD. CABALLERO CHIANG HI
DOLLY. DODD I DORADO. HI
GALGIANI. BY GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
I GROW I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO I TITLE I JACKSON. JONES
BY LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. HI NIELSEN AYE PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO BY
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER IA CATHY. WIENER HI.
WILK HI. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
ALLEN HI BRADFORD. BY CAMBIADO.
DELHI BY BURKE. JACKSON MORE
LOCK. ROTH STONE WHY CASKEY.
HIGHS THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SIX. MR MAJORITY LEADER
YOU PREPARED 2% HE AS MUCH
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AN
ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. CENTER
HERTZBERG. MISTER PRESIDENT
THIS SUCH MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY ESTABLISHES A
SCHOOL PAVEMENT TO PARKS GRANT
PROGRAM. IT IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION THAT INCLUDES
BOTH LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE. ADULT WITH TO THE
ENVIRO SCREEN AS WELL AS THE
BROADER. GROUP OF COMMUNITIES
THIS IS THE IMPORTANT FRAMEWORK
I THINK BECAUSE SINCE SO MANY
COMMUNITIES. ONE POINT SIX
MILLION STUDENTS ARE SUBJECT.
TWO EXTRAORDINARY HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND AS SUCH I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD
IN PUTTING TOGETHER THIS SCHOOL
PAVEMENT THE PARKS PROGRAM THAT
WHERE WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES IT
REQUIRES A LOCAL MAN THAT GETS
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATIONS PLUS
A FIFTY FIFTY MATCHING GRANT
FROM THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD. AS WE CONTINUE TO
GREEN UP AND TO CONTINUE TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS IN
AREAS THAT ARE SUBJECT. TO TOO
MUCH PAVEMENT AND CONCRETE I
ASKED FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. THING NOW
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL BY
BURGESS. BRADFORD. HI CABALLERO
I CHIANG HI DOLLY. BY DODD.
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG. HI HI HILL. HUESO
HIGHER TACO I JACKSON. I JONES.
LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK.
MORALE BUT LIKE I. MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER BY
STERN AYE STONE. BY AMBERG OUR
CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK BY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PORTICI.
DODD HI GROWTH. HILL BY JONES.
ICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS TOO ONCE
AGAIN I NEED TO ADMONISH
MEMBERS TO PLEAD TO PLEASE HOLD
IT DOWN IF YOU HAVE
CONVERSATIONS TAKE TAKE IT OFF
THE FLOOR. WITH THAT WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY ONE AND THAT BE CENTER
MCGUIRE. AND HE'S GONNA TAKE IT
FROM SENATOR WINNERS DESK. I'M
SORRY MR REQUIRE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
EIGHT FIRST AGAIN THAT IT'S THE
MAJORITY LEADER I APOLOGIZE AND
HE IS PREPARED. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT OKAY NOW
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
ONE THAT HE SAID REQUIRES
PREPARES A MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
AN ACT RLATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THIS MISTER REQUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT WORK TODAY RISE RISEN
AB SIX HUNDRED ON BEHALF OF
SOME RIVER KANSEN CHU THIS BILL
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE CURRENT LAW
BY PRESERVING CITIES FROM
SELECTIVELY ABORTING ANNEXING A
NEARBY DISADVANTAGE AND
CORPORATE COMMUNITY. A
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT AS CITY MUST
APPLY TO CORPORATE A
DISADVANTAGE ON A CORPORATE
COMMUNITY WHEN ANNEXING NEARBY
TERRITORY IF THE CITY ANNEX IS
MORE THAN TEN ACRES OVER A FIVE
YEAR SPAN RECENT AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM
THAT CAL LAUGHED THOUGH I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR WIENER
WHO IS ALLOWED ME TO BE A TO
BORROW HIS. DESK AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIVEAU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I A I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF. AB SIX HUNDRED I HAD SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT IT AND THE
CONCERNS REMAIN AND THAT IS
THAT IN THE IN A VERY LARGE
PART OF MY DISTRICT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COUNTY IN
INCORPORATED AREAS THAT WERE
NON NOT ANNEXED INTO THE CITY
AND SO IT LEFT THEM AS DONUT
HOLES. AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
IF YOU'RE DRIVING THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY AT NIGHT YOU WILL SEE
STREET LIGHT CURBS AND GUTTERS
AND THEN YOU COME TO THE END OF
THE STREET AND THE REST OF THE
STREET IS DARK IT HAS NONE IT
HAS NO INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
NO CURBS GUTTERS SIDEWALKS AND
STREET LIGHTS IT HASN'T SEPTIC
TANKS AND IT HAS ITS IN THEIR
OWN SEPARATE WELLS. AND THE
CHALLENGE WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS I JUST DON'T THINK IT
GOES FAR ENOUGH THIS IS THE
COMMUNITIES ENDED UP JUMPING
OVER THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE VERY POOR
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE INCUMBENT UPON
THE STATE TO FORCE THESE
ANNEXATIONS AND TO REQUIRE THEM
THE COUNTY AND THE CITY ALONG
WITH THE STATE TO PUT UP SOME
MONEY. TO START FIXING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO GET THEM
INCLUDED AND FRANKLY THERE
ABANDONED THIS BILL DOES NOT
DOES NOT HELP THEM BECAUSE THE
PROPERTY ALL AROUND THEM HAS
BEEN ANNEXED ALREADY AND SO I
DON'T THINK THE BILL GOES FAR
ENOUGH BUT I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE IN THE EVENT THAT THAT
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT CAN
BE ANNEXED IF THERE'S OTHER.
PROPERTY NEARBY WE SHOULD DO IT
BUT I THINK THE STATE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO LEAD THE WAY AND BE
THE LEADER IN THIS AND SAY WHAT
WILL PUT UP SOME MONEY FOR IT
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO.
DO GREAT THANK YOU CENTER.
THEIR PORCHES. FAMOUS PRESIDENT
I HAVE A REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS FROM THE POSITION LOCAL
CONTROL I THINK WHEN WE START
DICTATING IN THERE ARE ALREADY
LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT CERTAIN
ON COUNTY ISLANDS FOR EXAMPLE
IF THEY'RE UNDER CERTAIN NUMBER
PARCELS OR A CERTAIN SIZE I
SHOULD BE NATURALLY ABSORBED BY
THE LARGER ENTITY NEARBY BUT
THE PURPOSE OF LASKO IS TO
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS OF A
GIVEN ENVIRONMENT AND FOR US TO
IMPOSE UPON A LOCALITY THAT A
GIVEN COMMUNITY OR GIVEN REGION
BE ABSORBED. IT WHAT'S THE
POINT OF LASKO IF WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE IN
POSITIONS LIKE THIS I THINK IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF LOCAL
CONTROL AND YOU MIGHT AS WELL
CARVE THIS OUT AS BEING WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION OF. LOCAL
ANNEXATION ENTITIES. THANK YOU
CENTER BARGES. SENATOR DIED YES
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD THE YING AND
THE YANG AND I THINK THAT
SENATOR HAS STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE HERE THIS IS A GOOD
BILL THAT WILL HELP PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE'VE SEEN IT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN WERE THESE
COMMUNITIES GET OVERLOOKED I
THINK THAT IS A GOOD BILL ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
SEE NO OTHER MIKE'S UP. THE BAY
DISCUSSIONS OVER SO YOU CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
YEAH I THINK THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM NAPA HIT THE COURT
YOU HAVE BOTH SIDES DISCUSSED
IN THIS BILL AND VERY GRATEFUL
THIS REALLY ADDRESSES THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SALINAS IS
CONCERNED SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THERE'S A LOOPHOLE IN STATE LAW
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE ARE
SEEN DOUGHNUTS IF YOU WILL
WITHIN INCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES. THEY'RE NOT BEING
ANNEX. THIS WILL HELP CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO BE ABLE TO
ANNEX AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS KNOW. CAL LASKO THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION HAS
DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION FROM
THIS BILL I APPRECIATE ASSUME
EVER CHOOSE WORK ON THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU SIR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BY BATES.
BILL I PURCHASED NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO BY CHIANG. DALY DODD.
HI DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL NO WITH SO HI
TADO NO JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY BY MORE LOCK. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO
SKINNER. STERN BY STONE. NUMBER
HI BY. WHAT COUNTY HI WINNER HI
WILK NO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
BATES NO. CHIANG DALY. GROWTH
PAN. RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SKINNER
BY. NO. FIVE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE CARRIES
MOVING ON MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY THREE SENATOR MINING
IS PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE AN ACT REALLY TO
REDEVELOPMENT THEIR MINING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB FOR
ELEVEN ALLOWS THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ TO USE THE BOND PROCEEDS
FROM ITS FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY IN ORDER TO BUILD MUCH
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESS FACILITIES THIS WILL
FREE UP APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE USED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO NAVIGATE THE
DISSOLUTION PROCESS THROUGH THE
APPROVAL OF THE LAST AND FINAL
RECOGNIZED OBLIGATION PAYMENT
SCHEDULE. VERY FEW FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE IN A SIMILAR
POSITION AS IS THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ IN THAT WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THE
DISSOLUTION PROCESS HAVE NO
LITIGATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY LEVERAGED ARE
TWENTY ELEVEN HOUSING BONDS.
ARE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE
DISSOLVED IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZIS CURRENTLY
FACING A HOUSING CRISIS AND
ACCESS TO THESE ONE TIME FUNDS
WILL HELP THE CITY TO ME IT'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOALS
MEMBERS THIS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT IN AND COLLEAGUES. IT
WAS CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDABLE
DURING OUR BUDGET CRISIS WHEN.
OUR FORMER GOVERNOR CHOSE TO
GRAB REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET. AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE CITY TO MACULA
FOR TWELVE YEARS AND TEN YEARS
ON A BOARD SUPERVISOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. THOSE TWO ENTITIES
ACTUALLY USE REDEVELOPMENT
FUNDS FOR THE RIGHT REASONS
INCLUDING. THE 20% SET ASIDE
FOR LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING. TO ME THIS AGAIN IS
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS. YES
MAYBE THE CITY IS IN A POSITION
WHERE. THEY CAN CASH IN ON SOME
OF THE TRUE INTENTIONS OF
REDEVELOPMENT TO PROVIDE LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING THAT'S
A STRUGGLE THAT ALL OF OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT ABOUT THE ONES
THAT FOLLOW THE RULES AND
LIQUIDATED EARLIER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WHEN IN
FACT THEY HAD WONDERFUL PLANS
LIKE THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE IN
THE CITY OF TEMECULA DID TO
FURTHER PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT'S FAIR FOR ONE
SHOULD BE FAIR FOR ALL WITH THE
STATE THAT HAS A GOAL OF
PROVIDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHY ARE WE GIVING
SPECIAL. SPECIAL TREATS. TO ONE
PARTICULAR ENTITY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT. MAYBE THE
LADY AND THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY OR FOR
WHATEVER REASON STILL HAS FUNDS
THEY CAN USE FOR LOT LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT. BUT I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IS A WE
FORCE OTHER AGENCIES OTHER
MUNICIPALITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
LIQUIDATE THOSE FUNDS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING IT'S AN ISSUE OF
FAIRNESS. IF WE'RE GONNA GRANT
SOME CONCESSIONS TO ONE ENTITY
WE SHOULD BE GRANTED
CONCESSIONS TO ALL ENTITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
PROVIDE SOME TYPE OF INCENTIVE.
SOME SET ASIDE A PROPERTY TAXES
TO ALLOW. MUNICIPALITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO FULFILL THE
REINA. REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
SHUT DOWN THEIR THROATS. TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE
SHOULD BE DOING AT MY FRIENDS
WITH. WITH A. A LIGHT BRUSH
RATHER THAN A HARD STICK. SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE'RE NOT
CONSISTENT WE SHOULD BE
EXPANDED THESE BENEFITS TO ALL
CITIES ALL COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE GETTING A SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION TO ONE FOR THOSE
REASONS I REQUEST A NO VOTE ON
EIGHTY FOUR ELEVEN. THIS PLACE
TO TRY TO HOLD IT DOWN IN THE
CHAMBER AT CENTRE BELL WAS
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING SO.
YOU WANTED TO GIVE HIS
PRESENTATION AGAIN. MOLLY
KIDDING ON THAT BUT LET'S LET'S
LET'S SHOW RESPECT TO OUR
FELLOW MEMBERS IN AND HOLD IT
DOWN. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE IS A
CENTER MONEY MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WELL I
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVES OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ HAS ABIDED
BY EVERY REQUIREMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
COURTS. WE HAVE A HOMELESS
CRISIS IN SANTA CRUZ IS CREATED
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND THIS
IS A PATHWAY TO DEAL WITH AN
IMMEDIATE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
IN THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
MEMBERS I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MINING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I A ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS
AYE BATES NOBEL I BRIDGES NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
NO DALY NO DODD I. DORADO HI
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI.
HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE HI
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE MONNING
BY MORE LARK. RAIL NO NIELSEN
BY PAN. HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE. NO NUMBER. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FOUR SENATOR
ARCHULETA ARE YOU PREPARED. AND
HE SO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL. SO FAR
TEMPORARILY PASS. PASS ON FILE
OR TEMPORARILY PASS OKAY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR. UP NEXT
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN
SENATOR MCGUIRE. ARE YOU
PREPARED WHEN HE IS. MISTER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
ECHOING TO HOUSING AND MAKE AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE THERE
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IN
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
ONE THIRTY THESE TRAVEL
RESIDENTS LIVE BELOW THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. IT WATER
SEASON WORKING HARD ON A. B.
TEN TEN FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT NATIVE AMERICANS GAVE
AMERICA RESERVATIONS OR INJURY
IS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS MANAGED BY THE
CITY CALIFORNIA AB TEN TEN
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S TRAVEL COMMUNITY
IS NOT EXCLUDED FROM MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING. ASSISTANCE.
WOULD RESPECTFUL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BELL BY BURGESS
AYE BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG. DALY I DODD HI DORADO
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO
I JACKSON BY JONES BY LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK I'M- AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE. I AMBERG OUR CASKEY
AYE WIENER I WILK HI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBER CHIANG HI. HI SPORTY
KNOWS ZERO WE FINALLY HAVE OUR
FIRST UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VERY
GOOD MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SENATOR PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED AND HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OR SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO
HELP FACILITIES THERE PAN THE
FLOOR. CENTER PAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS SIGNED
PLEASED TO PRESENT. EIGHTY FIVE
A SIX BY SUMMER KALRA WHICH
PLACES AN OUTDATED AND
CONSISTENT CAUSATION TEST FOR
DETERMINING CLASS DOUBLE A
CITATIONS FOR LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY WITH MORE CURRENT
STANDARD AND A TERMINATE
LEGENDS. A SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR
CURRENTLY THE LAW SAYS IT MUST
BE A QUOTE A DIRECT PROXIMATE
CAUSE ND PUT TO DEATH WHICH IS
A STANDARD HAS BEEN REJECTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE IT IS A CONFUSING
STANDARD. HOWEVER THE BURDEN OF
PROOF IS STILL ON THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUBSTANTIATE
CITATION AND AMENDMENTS TAKEN
AND SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
STRUCK AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT
PROVED TO DEATH WAS A
FORESEEABLE RESULT OF THE
VIOLATION WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH CREATOR CASE LAW.
REGARDING ILLEGAL BECAUSE OF
HARM ADDITIONALLY AB FIVE A SIX
A TOP THE STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
CITATION AMOUNTS WHICH IS NOT
CHANGED IN EIGHT YEARS FOR
CLASS BE CITATIONS. IN NINETEEN
YEARS FOR CLASS A. AND DOUBLE
A. CITATIONS THESE INCREASES IN
PENALTY AMOUNTS CLOSELY REFLECT
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX. THE
OTHERS WORK TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FACILITIES ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NETWORK AND LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA. AB FIVE THE SIXES
TRILLION CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR VULNERABLE
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS BY
HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FEW.
THAT ACTORS VOWED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A NURSING HOME.
RESIDENTS HARM OR DEATH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR PAT ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE THERE
ANY OBJECTIONS TO THAT. THREE
NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY ONE SENATOR HUESO. YEAH
HE'S PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATED TO TRANSPORTATION THERE
HUESO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF A SOME AND MEMBER
GONZALEZ TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY THIS BILL
WOULD EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR
THE SENATE ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS TO FINALIZE A NEW
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
BY TWO YEARS THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND HAS A
BROAD LOCAL SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR JONES THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE PART OF HIS BILL IS NEEDED
THE TWO YEAR EXTENSION FOR
SANDBAGS TO GET ITS ACT
TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
FOR SENATOR REGION AND THE
WHOLE SAN DIEGO REGION. HOWEVER
THERE'S A LITTLE SECRET IN THIS
BILL THAT SANDBAG
REPRESENTATIVES ARE GLOSSING
OVER AND SOME MADE MIGHT EVEN
SAY TRYING TO HIDE. IT IS A
CLAUSE THAT LIMITS FUNDS FROM
GAS TAX TO PROJECTS INVOLVING
BIKES IN BUSES. WHAT THAT MEANS
IS NONE OF THE GAS TAX MONEY
THAT THE VOTERS SUPPORTED COULD
BE EVER USE FOR ROADS HIGHWAYS
AND THAT'S INVOLVES TRANSIT.
WHICH IS CODE FOR BIKES AND
BUSES. THE SENDER REPRESENT IS
UP HERE ARE PLAYING GAMES
TRYING TO DENY THIS BUT IT'S
ALL SPELLED OUT. IN THE
DEMOCRAT FOR ANALYSIS AND THE
REPUBLICAN FOR ANALYSIS AND
I'LL QUOTE FROM ANALYSIS AND
THAT'S ON OUR DESKS. QUOTE THE
REQUIREMENT TO NARROW SENDAK
ELIGIBILITY TO PROJECTS THAT
ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR SPECIFIED
TRANSIT. AND BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVELY PREVENTS
SAN DAG FROM USING THESE FUNDS
FOR HIGHWAY PROJECTS SUCH AS
ADDING LANES THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE. IN QUOTE.
BACKORDERS DIRECTLY OUT OF OUR
FLOOR ANALYSIS AS I STATED
SANDBAGS CURRENT MANAGEMENT
SEEMS TO BE ANTI MOTORISTS. AND
THIS IS A WAY OF GETTING
SACRAMENTO TO DO SOME OF THEIR
DIRTY WORK. IF WE PASS THIS IT
WILL ROUTE REPRESENT ANOTHER IN
A LONG LINE OF BROKEN PROMISES
THE VOTERS IN MY DISTRICT AND
OTHERS DISTRICTS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. DOWNTOWN TRANSPORTATION
LEADS AND THE MAJORITY IS UP
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. IT IS A
BAIT AND SWITCH. YOU PROMISE
EASE COUNTY IN NORTH COUNTY THE
UPGRADES TO THE ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS IN EXCHANGE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT. AND THEIR VOTES FOR
THE GAS TAX HIKE. PRODUCES
SPENDING PLAN THAT EXCLUDES
SOME OF THE BUSIEST PARTS OF
THE COUNTY. I THINK IT MIGHT BE
TIME FOR A REVIEW OF THE
MANAGEMENT AT ST DAG AND I
WOULD ASK ALL OF US TO VOTE NO
ON THIS. ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR JOHN
CENTER BELL. I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THE BILL THE BILL I
THINK I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TALK ABOUT. THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES REYES I THINK WE
HAVE TO ALL UNDERSTAND ONE
THING ABOUT TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING AND THAT'S YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN ADOPTED AND CONCURRED WITH
BY THE COMMUNITY AND THE
SANDBAG BOARD BEFORE YOU CAN
GET OUR TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
SO. ALTHOUGH THIS DELAYS ALLOWS
HIM TO HAVE TWO MORE YEARS
AFTER THAT TWO YEARS COMPLETED
THEN UNDER THE LAW THEY WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR ALL THE FUNDS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND I DON'T
THINK IT'LL RESULT IN REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT SAN
DIEGO SAID ACTUALLY WILL
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
IF THEY CAN GET A CONSENSUS ON
THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN SO WITHOUT I WOULD URGE IN.
OUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THING NINE CENTER HUESO YOU MAY
CLOSE YEAH THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANTED TO THANK US IN A BILL
FOR CLEAR FIND THAT THAT IS.
NOT A CONDITION THAT WAS PUT ON
THIS BILL BUT SAN DIEGO IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT SENDAK. IS
PUSHING FOR THIS BILL HAS GONE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND WE KNOW HOW THAT
IS IF THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT
AND THAT. OF THE EGGS THAT.
POLICY ADDED TO THE BILL WAS
SIMPLY TO ENCOURAGE SENDAK TO
COMPLY. AND ONCE THEY DO THE
FUNDING WILL WOULD COME
THROUGH. AND THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION. AMENDMENT. THAT
WAS ADDED TO THE BILL AND OF
COURSE THE. THE AUTHOR DIDN'T
WANTED I DIDN'T WANT TO SEND
AGAIN WANTED BUT- IF WE ARE.
GOING TO HELP. SENDAK COMPLY
WITH THE. THE POSITION THE RENT
CURRENTLY THEY'RE THEY'RE%
BETWEEN HOT ROCK AND A HARD
PLACE. AND THEY HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO WORK WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY FINALIZE OUR PLANETS
THAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
AND THEY DIDN'T COMPLY AND THEY
WERE WENT TO COURT AND THEY
LOST AND NOW THEY'RE THEY'D
THEY NEED AN EXTENSION ON THAT
SO. HELPLESS WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL AGENCY HELP THEM COMPLY
WITH STATE LAW AND THAT MONEY
WILL COME THROUGH EVENTUALLY
ONCE THEY COME TO AND I HAVE
COMPLETE CONFIDENCE TO SEND A
COULD SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. AND
THAT ONCE AGAIN THE THOSE
MONIES WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE PROJECTS AND THIS IS JUST
ONE OF THOSE THINGS. TO IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT VOTE BUT I
REALLY ENCOURAGE. EVERYBODY
SUPPORT THIS AYE AYE AYE. YOU
KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO ALSO ENCOURAGE HIM TO
SUPPORT THIS IS SOMETHING. THE
SENDEK NEEDS AND LOCAL LEADERS
NEED I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULTY. THAT WORK IN WITH
THE SITUATION BUT- ALL THIS
WILL WORK FOR THE BETTER WE
NEED THIS BILL TO PASS TODAY SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR HUESO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BILL BY
BURGESS. NO BRADFORD I COVER
YELLOW BY CHAIN NO DALY. DODD.
HI DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ BY GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO I JACKSON. BY JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL BY
MONEY BY MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE. NOVEMBER
OUR BECAUSE HE- WINNER. HI WHAT
KATHY BY WILK BY. THIS IS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS. BATES DALLY.
MCGUIRE THIS ONE MORE TIME IS
PLEASE CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS.
BATES DALY MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW I'M. NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTIES TO SENATOR
PANEL AND HE'S GOING TO PASS ON
FILE MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR HUESO
ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL A FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC BANKS. THAT ARE HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER. PRESIDENT
THIS IS A LOCAL A REALLY GOOD
LOCAL CONTROL BILL FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT OUR- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
AND IT'S ALSO A BILL THAT GIVES
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ADDITIONAL
TOOLS. TO MEET SOME OTHER GOALS
TO PROVIDE. OFTEN TIMES
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT WILL
HELP THEIR LOCAL ECONOMY. IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT THING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK WITH THE
BANKING INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
LOANS TO UNDERSERVED AREAS.
ALTHOUGH I'VE I'VE WORKED IN
THAT AREA IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
VERY DIFFICULT AREA TO WORK IN.
SO THIS BILL AB FIFTY STATE
FIFTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW. THE
LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
ESTABLISH CREATURES A PROFS
PROCESS TO. ALLOW THEM TO
CHARTER A PUBLIC BANK IN THEIR
CITIES IT DOES NOT ESTABLISH
PUBLIC BLANCA SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO CHARTER A PUBLIC
BLANK A LONG MULTI YEAR
PROCESS. WITH MANY REGULATORY
HURDLES HOWEVER IT IT ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO THIS
THIS IS NOT A NEW IDEA IT'S
BEEN DONE IN NORTH DAKOTA IT'S
BEEN DONE FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS SUCCESSFULLY. AND THIS
COULD WORK FOR OUR LOCAL CITIES
LET THEM DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO
WORK ON THIS I THINK THIS IS A
FANTASTIC BILL. FOR ALL OF ALL
OF YOU THAT SUPPORTER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIS WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO KEEP THEIR THEIR
ATTACKS SOLIS WORKING FOR THE
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY THAN
RATHER THAN. HAVING TO RELY ON
ON ON BANKS SOMETIMES IN MANY
CASES LIKE IN MY DISTRICT SOME
SOME BANKS HAVE MOVED OUT AND
LET MET MANY COMMUNITIES ON
BANK. AND THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM
I KNOW SOME BANKS HAVE STEPPED
UP BUT OTHERS HAVEN'T OTHERS
HAVE FLED. UNDERSERVED AREAS IN
THIS WILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LEASE PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE WHERE BANKS ARE
LEAVING THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATER DISCUSSION
CENTER MORE OCT. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
ITS CORE MISSION. THERE SHOULD
NOT BE A STYLE DRIFT AND THERE
SHOULD BE EXTREME EXTREME
CAUTION WHEN A MUNICIPALITY
ATTEMPTS TO PERFORM FUNCTIONS
BEST DONE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
I HAVE ENJOYED THE EXERCISE. OF
CONSIDERING THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF A BANK SHORTLY AFTER I
BECAME THE TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR OF ORANGE COUNTY. IT
TURNED OUT THAT. THE MAJOR
BANKS WERE IN NO MOOD. THEY
HAVE THE FIFTY THOUSAND WELFARE
RECIPIENTS. COME INTO THE
BRANCHES ON THE FIRST OF THE
MONTH. AND I WAS HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME TRYING TO
CONVINCE. I ALMOST WANT TO SAY
THEIR NAMES BUT I WON'T THAT
SAID THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT.
NEEDED TO BE DONE AND BECAUSE
THEY HAD NO LEVERAGE I
CONTACTED A LAWYER IN THE
BANKING INDUSTRY WE. CONTACTED
THE FBI SEE AND THEY SAID THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN IT BUT- WILL GIVE
THE GREEN LIGHT. WROTE THE
FEDERAL RESERVE BOARD. THOUGHT
ON IN YOUR RESERVATION GAVE ME
THE GREEN LIGHT. I MET WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF BANKS IN
DOWNTOWN LA. AND I SAID I'M
HAVING TROUBLE WITH MY WELFARE
RECIPIENTS AND I WANT TO START
A BANK. AND I THOUGHT. THEY
WOULD KICK ME OUT WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES BUT THEY START ASKING
QUESTIONS CAN YOU DO AUTOMATIC
DEPOSITS TO PAY RENT CAN YOU DO
POINT TO SELL CARDS CAN YOU DO
THEY WERE LIKE WE JUST HAD A
GREAT A GREAT TIME. AND THEY
SAID YOU KNOW WE'RE SO WE'RE SO
FRUSTRATED THAT SO MANY OF OUR
WELFARE RECIPIENTS ARE GOING TO
CHECK CASHING SERVICES AND
PAYING A HEFTY PREMIUM TO GET
THERE FUNDING AND IF YOU CAN
MAINSTREAM THEM WITH MAKING
PAYMENTS TO THEIR UTILITIES AND
TO THEIR TO THEIR LANDLORDS
THAT WOULD BE REAL HELPFUL I. I
HAD A GREAT TIME WITH THE STATE
BANKING REPRESENTATIVES AND
THEY SAID PLEASE COME BACK WITH
A BUSINESS PLAN. SO I DID. I
TRIED TO THE BUSINESS PLAN WENT
THROUGH THE MECHANICS REALIZE I
WAS GOING TO SAVE A MILLION
DOLLARS IF I STARTED A BANK FOR
THE COUNTY TO HANDLE THIS.
POPULATION END UP. I EVEN
PASSED THE CEOS OF ALL THE
SMALL BANKS IN ORANGE COUNTY
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK OF THIS
IDEA SHOULD WE PURSUE IT. AND
THEY CAME BACK AND SAID NOT
ONLY DO WE LIKE THE IDEA WOULD
LIKE TO BE ON YOUR BOARD. SO
THEN I DID SOMETHING REALLY
INTERESTING I WENT TO SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND I SAID I AM GOING
TO CHARGE YOU YOUR DEPARTMENT
FOR YOUR SPECIFIC COSTS FOR
ISSUING WELFARE CHECKS I HAD
ONE. BANK LOCATION WHERE IT WAS
IN A GROCERY STORE. AND ON THE
FIRST OF THE MONTH THE SHOPPERS
OF THAT STORE COULD NOT GET
INTO THE STORE BECAUSE THERE
WAS SUCH A LONG LINE OF. PEOPLE
TRYING TO CATCH THEIR WELFARE
CHECK TODAY THEY HAD TO PUT A
VAN IN THE PARKING LOT. AND
THEY CHARGED ME FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH.JUST FOR THAT
ONE DAY THE CASH CHECKS FOR THE
COUNTY. SO. WAS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM A
YEAR THAT WILL THAT SOCIAL
SERVICES WAS COSTING MY
DEPARTMENT SO I TOLD THEIR
BUDGET ANALYST YOU'RE GOING TO
BE RESPONSIBLEFOR. HE WAS
PRETTY UPSET. BUT HE CAME BACK
ABOUT A WEEK LATER AND SAID YOU
KNOW IF YOU GIVE ME A SPECIFIC
BILL FOR THE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS I CAN TURN
THAT OVER TO THE FEDERAL
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THEY
WILL REIMBURSE ME 80% OF MY
COST AND I THOUGHT MY GOODNESS.
OBVIOUSLY THE COUNTY WAS LITTLE
FLOPPY AND DIDN'T CHECK INTO
THIS BEFORE BUT IF I'M GOING TO
SAVE A MILLION DOLLARS IS
STARTING A BANK I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO SAVE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO AFTER ALL THAT
WORK. I SAID I REALLY DON'T TO
DO THAT. BUT IT WAS A FUN
EXERCISE AND I WAS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF EVERYONE ALONG
THE WAY BUT I WILL TELL YOU
FROM THAT EXERCISE. THAT THE
PROFIT MARGIN IS THE MINIMUS I
MEAN YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND IT IF YOU START A
BANK IS A MUNICIPALITY THAT YOU
HAVE. MORE DOWNSIDE THEN YOU
HAVE UP SIDE. AND YOUR DRIFTING
FROM WHERE YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE. WE DON'T DESIGN GOVERNMENTS
TO RUN BANKS. AND SO GIVING
PERMISSION FOR THIS ONLY
EXPOSES THOSE THAT HAVE GONE OR
WISH TO GO INTO THIS AREA TO
MORE DOWNSIDE AND RIGHT NOW
LOOKING AT THEIR FINANCIAL
SATEMENTS THE OUR CITIES AND
OUR MUNICIPALITIES DO NOT NEED
MORE. DOWNSIDE BECAUSE THEY ARE
READY FISCALLY DISTRESSED WITH
EVER INCREASING PENSION COSTS
AND THE REST SO I'M I'M UST
TELLING YOU AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
GONE DOWN THIS ROAD. THAT IT
ISN'T A PRUDENT WAY TO GO IT
WON'T BE BENEFICIAL. AND WE
DON'T HAVE A DIRT THE BANKS
LEAVING COMMUNITIES WE HAVE. SO
MANY CHASIN. BANK OUTLETS IN
SHOPPING CENTERS AND BUILDINGS
POPPING UP EVERY WE DO NOT HAVE
A BANK SHORTAGE SO WITH THAT I
ALSO WOULD SAY THAT NORTH
DAKOTA IS NOT A GOOD EXAMPLE
IT'S LIKE COMPARING APPLES
VERSUS ORANGES SO COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE ON
A. B. EIGHT. FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU SIR MORE LOCK CENTER BELL.
JUST BASICALLY. I THINK THE OF
THE CLAUSE IN THE BILL THAT
REQUIRES A ANALYSIS. AND THAT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT IS
EXACTLY THE KIND OF. THINGS
THAT WILL HAPPEN IF ANYBODY
EVER WANTS TO CONSIDER A PUBLIC
BANK SO THERE IS A SECTION IN
THE BILL THAT DEALS WITH THAT
ISSUE CORD REQUIRES THAT KIND
OF STUDY. IT'S PRUDENT TO DO
THAT KIND OF STUDY AND A LOT OF
A LOT OF STUDY BEFORE THESE
KINDS OF THINGS OR ESTABLISH
HOWEVER I THINK THERE IS A NEED
TO HAVE IS MANY TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX. OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND FINANCING AGENCIES THAT
FINANCE INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
OTHER KINDS OF ACTIVITIES AND
HAVING SUCH A- THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE WHETHER IT'S LIMóN
EARNED OR OR QUITE. OPEN COULD
BE AN A TOOL THAT WOULD BE IS
OF BENEFIT TO OUR COMMUNITY SO
HARD SUPPORT FOR THIS. IT
DOESN'T SAY PUBLIC BANKS CREDIT
SENSORS A PROCESS TO GO THROUGH
TO CREATE A PUMP. THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES ARJAN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU AND MISTER PRESIDENT
NUMBERS I THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
I'VE HEARD A LOT FROM MY
DISTRICT ABOUT THERE'S A LOT OF
APPEAL TO THE IDEA OF A PUBLIC
BANK BECAUSE OF ARGUMENTS THAT
THE FLOOR MANAGER HAS REYES AND
CERTAINLY THE SENATOR FROM SAN
JOSE IS REYES THAT WE HAVE SOME
ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITIES WERE
PUBLIC BANKING OR FINANCIAL
HELP COULD BE A BENEFIT AND
THAT'S HOUSING THAT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE. CERTAINLY FOR
THOSE OF US FOR FOLLOWING THE
WHOLE BITING CANNON THIS COMING
INDUSTRY WE KNOW THAT AND THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS THE
PROHIBITION BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALLOWING BANKING IN
CANNABIS IS CREATING ENORMOUS
PROBLEMS THE TO THE STATE
TREASURER THE PAST SAYS
TREASURER JUDGE JOHN. TRAVEL
AROUND THE STATE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY COULD TO DEAL WITH
THAT ISSUE NAY IT DIDN'T SETTLE
ON THIS IS AS A VIABLE SOLUTION
BUT IT IT HAS A LOT IT HAS A
LOT OF APPEAL THE LA TIMES THAT
HAD A VERY GOOD EDITORIAL ON
THE SUBJECT ENCOURAGE YOU TO
READ IT. IN THIS CASE
ENCOURAGING OF DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT I'M GONNA CAST TODAY WHICH
IS THE COURAGE TO KNOW VOTE ON
THE ISSUE BUT THEY RAISE A VERY
GOOD ISSUES ABOUT THE ABILITY
OF GOVERNMENT TO MAKE CHOICES
THAT COULD HAVE THE TINGE OF
POLITICS INVOLVED IN THOSE
CHOICES AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S THE RIGHT FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR A PUBLIC
ENTITY. I THINK THAT THE PART
OF THIS MEASURE THAT I GUESS.
TELLS ME TO THE SIDE OF SAYING
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
VOTE FOR TODAY'S BECAUSE IT
ONLY AUTHORIZES. A PROCESS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN GO
THROUGH. AND SURVIVE. FEELINGS
TO THE TO THOSE WHO WOULD
CONSIDER IT LOCALLY IS TO BE
VERY VERY CAREFUL. I HOPE THAT
WERE NOT CREATING A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THIS AUTHORIZATION. BUT
GIVEN ITS LIMITED SCOPE IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE STATE IS
DOING. SOMETHING THAT I CAN
SUPPORT TODAY AND ENCOURAGING
EITHER. THANK YOU SIR GLAZER
NAY DID CATCHER POND. SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS BRIEFLY I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS IN MY
DISTRICT TO THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CRUZ THE CITY OF WATSONVILLE
ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING PARTNERSHIPS MORE
BROADLY REGIONALLY WITH SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SAN BENITO COUNTY
MONTEREY COUNTY. AS A MEANS OF
POTENTIALLY KEEPING INVESTOR
MONEY COMMUNITY MONEY IN THE
COMMUNITY WORKING FOR THE
COMMUNITY THIS BILL SUPPORTS.
LOOKING AT HOW THE MECHANICS OF
COMMUNITY BASED BANK MIGHT MOVE
FORWARD I URGE AN EYEFUL. THANK
YOU SIR SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
HUESO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MUST PRESENT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THIS GREAT
DEBATES IN OF COURSE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE VERY.
LUCKY TO HAVE A BIG BROTHER
LIKE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM COSTA
MESA THAT WILL IS THERE TO
PROTECT THEM FROM THEMSELVES.
BUT THE TRUTH IS. YOU KNOW I
WANT TO AGREE WITH A LOT OF HIS
COMMENTS AND ONCE A ONE AGREE
WITH WAS. THE YOU CAN'T COMPARE
THE. NOTE THE QUARTERBACK TO
OTHER BANKS WHEN THE LEADERS OF
NORTH DAKOTA WE'RE ASKING YOU
KNOW IT'S A REPUBLICAN
STATEMENTS RUN BY A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE WHEN
THEY WERE ASKED DO YOU SUPPORT
PUBLIC BANKING THEIR RESPONSES.
WE LOVE OUR PUBLIC BANK BUT WE
DON'T RECOMMEND ANYBODY ELSE TO
IT. AND THAT'S THAT'S A
CONTRADICTION IN AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT IT'S BECOME OF.
A NEW ISSUE. THAT IT SEEMS TO
BE SOMEWHAT PARTISAN WHEN IT
REALLY ISN'T. THE NORTH DAKOTA
BANK WAS ACTUALLY STARTED BY
FARMERS. TO GET GET THEM ACCESS
TO CAPITAL. WHERE THE REGULAR
BANKING COMMUNITY DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. TO BANKING WAR OR
FINANCING. SO IT WORKS IN
ACTUALLY IN NORTH DAKOTA. THEY
THEY HAVE HELPED MAKE BANKING
MORE COMPETITIVE IN THEIR STATE
SO THEY HAVE MORE BANKING
COVERAGE THAN ANY OTHER STATE
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THEIR PUBLIC
BANK BECAUSE OF THE BACK AND
ACTUALLY BRINGS A LOT OF
CAPITAL A LOT OF REVENUE TO
THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT. SO YES
IT IS NOT A FAIR COMPARISON
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC BACK IN
NORTH DAKOTA IS HELPING PUT
MONEY FOR PUBLIC SERVICES IN
NORTH DAKOTA TOPPING TO ENHANCE
BANKING IN COMMUNITIES SO IT'S
BEEN A GREAT PRODUCT FOR NORTH
DAKOTA AND I DON'T SEE WHY IT
WON'T WORK FOR CALIFORNIA SO. I
WANT TO ADD THAT AND THE OTHER
THING IS. YOU KNOW IF
GOVERNMENT SHOULD FOCUS ON THIS
MISSION. WHERE WHERE WAS A
SCREAMING AND YELLING ON THAT
ISSUE WHEN THE BUSH WHEN THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION. DID A
MASSIVE BAILOUT OF BANKS. HERE
WITH WITH THE WITH THE BANK
FAILURES HERE WERE TAXPAYER
FUNDS BEING USED TO BAIL OUT.
BANKS THAT WERE NOT MANAGED
PROPERLY. SO YES BANKING CAN BE
OF. COMPLICATED BUSINESS AND.
AND IT CAN CREATE PROBLEMS BUT
GUESS WHAT BANK WASN'T BAILED
OUT BY THE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR ANY OTHER
GOVERNMENT THE NORTH DAKOTA
THANK. SO THERE ARE VERY STRONG
ARGUMENTS THERE IS HIS ALL.
JUST A MATTER OF LET THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DECIDE WHETHER THIS
WORKS FOR THEM IT MIGHT WE THIS
BILL MAY NEVER CREATE A PUBLIC
BANK IN CALIFORNIA BUT WHY NOT
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT TO PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES
FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND I
TELL YOU. THAT THE BANK OF
NORTH DAKOTA BRINGS MORE
REINVESTMENT CAPITAL TO THAT
STATE. BECAUSE IT EXISTS AND WE
CAN DO THAT THE CALIFORNIA WHY
NOT BRING IN. LEVERAGE MORE
FUNDING BRING IN MORE MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND
FROM. IN INVESTORS TO PROVIDE
LOANS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE.
OUR BUSINESSES DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO LOANS I'M I CAN GO ON
AND ON VERY SORRY ABOUT THIS
LONG TIRADE BUT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S SO MUCH MISINFORMATION
ABOUT THIS THAT I. I JUST HAD A
CLEAR THE RECORD AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A GREAT BILL
WE SHOULD SUPPORT IT AND. AND I
THINK THIS WOULD IT WOULD TURN
INTO A GREAT PROGRAM FOR OUR
STATE SO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SIR HUESO WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I. CHIANG
NO DALY NO DODD BY TERRAZZO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
GROVE NO HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO HIGHER TADO NO. JACKSON
BY JONES. LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LARK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. PORTANTINO HI ROTH. RUBIO
HI. SKINNER. HI STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY I WIENER
BY WILK NO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN HI BATES NO. YES
HERTZBERG. JONES NO AND ROTH.
PRICE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE KERRY'S RIGHT NOW
MEMBERS REMOVED BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE CENTER
BRADFORD ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AFTER THE FLOOR SHORES THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SOBEL'S LIBERTIES
MEASURE THAT WOULD PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION AND BIOMETRIC
SCANNERS. EMBODY CAMBER'S
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED BODY CAMERA
PROGRAMS TO HELP INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MEN TRUSTS
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
SWORN TO PROTECT AND SERVE.
HOWEVER COMBINING FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE WOULD BODY
CAMERAS CAN LEAD TO A DIRE
CONSEQUENCES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
MAKING COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE
WHILE SUBJECTING LAW ABIDING
RESIDENTS TO PERPETUAL POLICE
LINEUPS WITHOUT. THEIR CONSENT
THE USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE IS OFTEN INACCURATE
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR ACCORDING TO THE MIT
STUDIES LAST YEAR STUDY WAS
CONDUCTED USING THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND FALSELY MAX TWENTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN PHOTO
MODE MUGSHOT DATABASE THE SAME
TESTS WAS EVEN WORSE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO FALSELY IDENTIFYING
TWENTY SIX STATE LEGISLATORS
INCLUDING MYSELF AND
ASSEMBLYMAN. TING AS WELL AS
SENATORS. ARCHULETA BAIL DOLLY
GALGIANI GLAZER HE'LL. HUESO
JONES MORALE AND WIENER. IN
BOTH CHECKS AND BOTH TESTS
MEMBERS OF COLOR WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY
MISIDENTIFIED AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
PREVENTS THE MAGIC MISUSE OF ON
RELIABLE TECHNOLOGY WHICH YOU
MAKE MORE ABOUT COMMUNITIES
EVEN MORE DISTRUSTFUL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND FOLLOWING THE
MAN'S IN THIS HOUSE THE BILL IS
NOW IMPOSES A THREE YEAR
MORATORIUM ON THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN BODY
CAMERAS LET'S BE CLEAR IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE REINFORCE
THAT THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES TO
BODY CAMERAS. WERE FACIAL
RECOGNITION ERRORS IN THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE TECHNOLOGY
ARE MORE LIKELY TO OCCUR THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY AT NINE
AND OTHER DEVICES OR SETTINGS
ULTIMATELY INTRUDING
INDIVIDUALS OUR PRIVACY BEEN
SUBJECTING COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
BIASED AND INACCURATE
SURVEILLANCE'S WILL NOT BE
PUBLIC TRUST NOR MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. UNFORTUNATELY
HIGH RISE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON AND I
APPRECIATE WITH THE AUTHOR
TRYING TO DO WITH THE MEASURE
BUT I AM OPPOSED TO NOT RIDE
BAN ON THE NEW TECHNOLOGY I
THINK THE TECHNOLOGY SHOULD BE
RESEARCH SHOULD BE BROUGHT UP
TO STANDARDS AND IT WILL BE
FAIR AND EQUITABLE IF SOMEONE
CAN LOOK IN THE CAMERA AND
THERE IS NO DEVIATION FROM THE
SCREEN. SO I BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP WORKING ON THE
TECHNOLOGY IT SAID ABOUT
BLOWING THE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE I THINK THE STATE
SHOULD BE GETTING OUR CITY
PARAMETERS AROUND THE USE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY AND I THINK
THAT'S THE ISSUE IS THE USE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY WHICH WE ALL
KNOW IT'S UNFAIR NOT EQUITABLE
AS WILL AS I TOO AM A VICTIM OF
THE CAMERA. BUT THIS DOESN'T DO
THAT CALIFORNIA IS THE LEADER
OF A TECHNICAL SECTOR AND AS
THE LEADER WE SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTING THE BEST PRACTICES
OF TECHNOLOGY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RATHER THAN OTHER
STATES SO FOR THIS REASON I
THINK THAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME IS
FLAWED AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE IT ON THE NEXT ONE. IS
OVER THIS I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER HERTZBERG.
BRIEFLY MISTER PRESIDENT I
AGREE WITH. THE SENATOR FROM
PICO RIVERA THAT THERE'S A
CHALLENGE HERE BUT WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION DOES. IS VAN THE
FACIAL RECOGNITION SYSTEM FOR
THREE YEARS NOW I KNOW IN
TECHNOLOGY THREE YEARS IS A
LIFETIME BUT ORIGINALLY WRITTEN
I THINK IT WAS TEN YEARS OR
SEVEN YEARS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THE BALANCE OF CIVIL
LIBERTIES THE BALANCE OF THE
NEED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE LIKE AGAINST WHAT IS PROVEN
TO BE SECTION EIGHT EIGHT
ABSOLUTELY L
SOURCE OF INFORMATION THE
IMPACT ON INDIVIDUAL LIVES THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY RESOURCES. A FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TODAY THAT HAVE
NEVER EXISTED BEFORE THE
QUESTION IS. GIVEN THAT BALANCE
IS IT THE RIGHT THING TO DO TO
GET THE TECHNOLOGY CORRECT
WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS IN BIAS
IN OTHER AREAS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT WHERE THERE'S THIS GROWTH
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT BOTH HAS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO
HELP GOVERNMENT IN MANY WAYS.
BUT YET ISN'T QUITE THERE YET
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT OUR THREE
YEAR AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
BY THE AUTHOR ARE VERY GENEROUS
AND A THREE YEAR DELAY IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO BALANCE IS
THE NECESSARY NEEDS AGAINST
NECESSARY RISK IT AS SUCH I'LL
BE VOTING FOR THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATER DISCUSSION CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO REINFORCE THE COMMENTS BY MY.
CALLING FROM THE VALLEY AND-
THE- I THINK THE DANGER OF. OF
ARE NOT TAKING THE ACTION
THAT'S BEFORE US. IS THAT A
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS STILL FLAWED.
COULD THEN BE USED IN A WAY
THAT COULD BE VERY HARMFUL AND
I THINK NONE OF US WANT THAT.
WE DO WANT OUR. LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR JOBS
ABSOLUTELY AND WE ALSO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO. PURSUE THE FOLKS
THAT WE FEEL ARE THE POTENTIAL
PERPETRATORS OF A CRIME. AND
HAVE THE SECURITY THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN APPREHEND THEM.
BUT THE TECHNOLOGY IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. IS AS WAS EIGHTY
EIGHT EVERY BIT OF DATA THAT
YET TESTED IT SHOWS. IS IN A
LOT OF MISTAKES IN VERY VERY
SADLY THOSE MISTAKES I DON'T
WANT TO SEE SADLY BUT I SUPPOSE
TYPICALLY THOSE MISTAKES ARE
MOSTLY. IT ACCURATELY CAPTURING
THE FACES OF BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE KNOW MY FACE SO WHEN THE
NEWSPAPER ARTICLE THAT SHOWED
WHICH OF THE LEGISLATORS IT
INACCURATELY DEPICTED AS A
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL. I WAS IN ON
IT. BUT THE AUTHOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM WAS LISTED. I DON'T
THINK THERE WAS ONE WHITE
LEGISLATOR ON THE LIST THAT THE
TEST SHOWED. THERE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN OKAY SORRY ALL RIGHT I
GUESS WE HAVE A FEW CRIMINALS
SORRY SORRY. ALL RIGHT WELL.
BUT THE POINT BEING THE POINT
BEING THEY TESTED. ALL OF OUR
FACES SO. IT IS AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE VALLEY POINTED OUT.
IT'S ONLY THREE YEARS. AND
TECHNOLOGY CAN GREATLY IMPROVE.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT. ACTION TO TAKE TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR SKINNER SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AS ONE OF THOSE
LEGISLATORS THAT DID SHOW UP ON
THE LIST I DO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIFTEEN ALSO
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS SOME
DEBATE AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF
US DISCUSS THE DEBATE REGARDING
THE USE OF THE TECHNOLOGY ON
THE 80% VERSUS THE 99% IF THEY
HAD YOU KNOW. CHANGE ALGORITHM
OR WHATEVER BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
BEAT REGARDLESS OF ALL OF THAT
I'M NOT SURE I'M COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY BEING USED
MAYBE EVER SO I KNOW THAT THE
ADVOCATES OF THE BILL HAVE
WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY THIS
YEAR TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT MAKES SENSE I KNOW THE
AUTHOR AND THE FLOOR JOCKEY
HAVE WORKED VERY DILIGENT
DILIGENTLY ON IT AS WELL I
THINK THE THREE YEAR SUNSET IS
MORE THAN REASONABLE AND JUST
TO PUT THAT INTO PERSPECTIVE.
COLLEAGUES WERE ON THE LAST.
THREE DAYS. OF OUR FIRST YEAR.
AND THIS LEGISLATURE. TIME
FLIES. SO THREE YEARS IS GONNA
GO BY REALLY FAST AND I HAD
ASKED THAT WE ALL SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
CENTER GALGIANI. I RISE IS ONE
OF THE LEGISLATORS WITH THE
TWIN OUT THERE I HAVE TWO
POINTS THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
ONE IS THAT WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I WAS ASKED TO VOTE ON
A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES WE HAD
NEVER HAD ANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT SUBJECT MATTER IT
WAS THE FURTHEST THING FROM MY
MIND AND I REALLY DIDN'T FEEL
THAT I KNEW ENOUGH ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY TO CAST A VOTE. BUT
WE ALL DID CAST VOTES. I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY REALIZE HOW
QUICKLY THE TECHNOLOGY WOULD
ADAPT AND HOW SOON. THERE WOULD
BE ELECTRIC SELF DRIVING CARS
OUT THERE BEING TESTED ON THE
ROAD WE COULDN'T WE COULDN'T
PREDICT WHAT THE ADVANCEMENTS
IN THAT TECHNOLOGY WOULD BE.
SECONDLY I REPRESENT STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND EARLIER. THIS MONTH
WE HAD A STRAIGHT PRIDE PARADE
AND MODESTO. AND WHILE WE WERE
VERY FORTUNATE THERE WERE THAT
THERE WERE NO NOT ANY VIOLENT.
ISSUES ARE INCIDENTS. I WOULD
WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO A PUBLIC EVENT LIKE
THAT WHERE. INDIVIDUALS WERE
UNDER THREAT AND TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE WHO THEY SHOULD WATCH
MORE CAREFULLY AND CAUTIOUSLY.
TO AVOID AN ASSAULT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER CENTER
MITCHELL. I STAND UP IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL FOR ONCE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT I
DIDN'T SHOW UP ON A LIST FOR
ONCE WHEN IT COMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO. GOAL HOLLY I. I
THINK A THREE YEAR PAUSE. IS
APPROPRIATE WE ARE DEALING WITH
LOTS OF CONCERNS AROUND BIAS
IMPLICIT EXPLICIT OTHERWISE.
AND SO AS WE ARE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TALKING ABOUT
TRAINING. ELEVATING THOSE
ISSUES WITH REGARD TO YOU KNOW.
POLICE STOPS ARRESTS I HAVE
BEEN IN. IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
AT A DISPROPORTIONATE RATE
COMPARED TO ANOTHER I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE HAVE A
PAUSE TO ALLOW TECHNOLOGY TO
CATCH UP. AND TO ALLOW OUR OVER
ALL THINKING AND ATTITUDES
ABOUT COMMUNITY INTERACTION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO CATCH
UP AS WELL. JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A SENSE OF EQUITY
ACROSS THE BOARD. IN TERMS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT INTERACTIONS
WITH THE GENERAL PUBLIC THE
LOBBY SUPPORTING ON MR KING'S
BAIL ON. ANTI GAY THREE YEAR
PAUSES MORE THAN REASONABLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. CENTER
GLAZER WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS LIKE
IF THE ISSUE BEFORE US WAS
ABOUT THE USE AND ABUSE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S A HEALTHY
DEBATE BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
TO BE TRAMPLED ON. NOBODY WANTS
THAT. BUT THE ISSUE HERE IS
WHETHER WE ARTIFICIALLY STATE
GOVERNMENT ARTIFICIALLY PUTS A
STOP. TO THE POTENTIAL FOR THAT
TECHNOLOGY. THE HELP IS
CATCHING THE BAD PEOPLE. SO WHY
WOULD WE PUT OUR HEAD IN THE
SAND AND SAY WE'RE GONNA STOP
IT ARTIFICIALLY BECAUSE OF OUT
OF WORRY. THAT THAT THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY GETS THE USER
REVIEWS. THAT'S WHAT THE
QUESTION THAT'S THE QUESTION
THAT SHOULD BE BEFORE US. WE
WANT PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS TO BE PROTECTED. WE
DON'T WANT TO ARREST TO BE MADE
FOR THE WRONG REASONS OR
PROSECUTIONS TO BE MADE FOR THE
WRONG REASONS. THROUGH ABUSE OF
ANYTHING CIVIL RIGHTS DUE
PROCESS. OR THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY AND SO BECAUSE OF
THAT I THINK THIS BILL IS.
PREMATURE AND ADDRESSES THE
WRONG STANDARDS THAT WE SHOULD
DEBATE THE DEBATE ON THIS
FLOOR. AND ACCORDINGLY I'M
RECOMMENDING IN NOVA. THANK YOU
SIR GLAZER CENTER DIED. I
APPRECIATE THAT RED YOU KNOW
THOSE REMARKS FIRM. IT WAS THE
GETS THE GOOD CENTER FROM
LIVERMORE. AREA BUT YOU KNOW I
WAS AGAINST THIS BILL WHEN IT
FIRST CAME TO THIS HOUSE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS AN
OVER REACH YEAH I TO WHAT YOUR
SAFETY IN MY COMMUNITY. BUT
WHEN HE CAME OVER HERE I THINK
IT LOOKED YEAH PRETTY TOUGH AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FROM SAMPSON SAID GOOD SEMI
MEMBER FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
COMPROMISING A AND BRING IN
THIS FROM SEVEN YEARS TO THREE
YEARS AND IT HAS THE CENTER
FROM SAN DIEGO SAID THREE YEARS
IS NOT A LONG TIME WHEN IT
COMES TO LEGISLATIVE TIME FOR
SURE AND I CERTAINLY DO NOT
THINK THAT THIS WILL. STIFLE
THAT INNOVATION PEOPLE STILL BE
ABLE TO WORK ON THESE TYPE OF
THINGS TO REFINE THEM AND GET A
BETTER TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY.
SAFE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER DIED.
NOT SEEING ANY OTHER MIKE SUB
SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK THOSE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE ADDED THEIR VOICE TO THIS
BUT IT'S NOT LOST ON ME THAT
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WEBER INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO PASS OFFICERS TO
WEAR BODY CAMERAS THE
RESISTANCE FROM MANY MEMBERS
HERE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OF WHY
THEY WEREN'T NECESSARY NOW
THREE YEARS LATER AFTER WE'VE
INTRODUCED BODY CAMERAS NOW
EVERY BY WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD
AND ADDING ADDITIONAL
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS YET TO BE
FULLY DEVELOPED. AND ALL THE
KINKS WORKED OUT OF IT THIS IS
NOT PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM USING FACIAL RECOGNITION
AND OTHER DEVICES TO IDENTIFY
BAD GUYS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
BODY CAMERA WORK USE THE LAW
OFFICERS MOVING AND THE SUB A
SUBJECT IS MOVING YOU'RE NOT
FOCUS SEEN TAKING A STILL SHOT
OF SOMEONE SO UP PICTURES
DIFFUSE THE LANDS IS NOT FOCUS
SO IT'S GREAT ROOM FOR ACT
INACCURACIES HERE BY USING A
BODY CAMERA TO IDENTIFY ONE'S
FACIAL FEATURES. AGAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN STILL USE THAT.
TECHNOLOGY ON OTHER DEVICES AND
OTHER. METHOD TO IDENTIFY FOLKS
REDUCING NOT ON A BODY CAMERA
AND AGAIN THE SAME BODY CAMERAS
THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
ADVOCATED FOR THREE YEARS AGO
AS A TOOL FOR. GREATER PUBLIC.
TRUST AND GREATER OFFICER
SAFETY SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND
MANY OTHERS BUT AGAIN THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE TECHNOLOGY IS
NOT OF ALL WE HAVE ARE THàNH
THOMAS CARS RIGHT NOW THAT
WE'VE HEARD STORIES OF PEOPLE
BEING KILLED. BY AYE THOMAS CAR
SELECTED TECHNOLOGIES DEVELOPED
AND IN THREE YEARS I THINK
WE'LL ALL BE IN SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING THE USE OF. BODY
CAMERAS FOR FACE RECOGNITION I
RESPECT LESS RIVAL. THANK YOU
SIR BRADFORD WITHOUT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI. ARCHULETA. DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI NO GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
HI AYE HILL AYE HUESO. BY TITLE
NO. JACKSON BY JONES BY LEYVA
BUY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCKED. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. RUBIO. BY
SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE. NO
NUMBER. NO BY CASKEY I WINNER
BY WILK BY. THIS IS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BILL DALY NO ROTH. STERN. PRICE
TWENTY TWO KNOWS FIFTEEN
MEASURE PASSES. AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER LEYVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU CENTER
LABOR CENTER PAN THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WE MEDIA
IMMEDIATELY AND ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE TO SIT AS WE RECESS
TO BE FOLLOWED BY THEN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SIR SENATOR DODD. I YES MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATE GEO COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN
OF THE ENERGY UTILITIES A
COMMUNICATIONS. COMMITTEE IN
ROOM THREE ONE NINE ONE TO HEAR
ONE BILL. THANK YOU SIR CENTER
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WILL BE
MOVING MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. TEN MINUTES AFTER THE
CALL A RECESS. THANK YOU SIR
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UP
HAN ADJOURNMENT OF GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BETTER ALLEN YEAH SENATE
INFORMAL QUALITY IS
UNFORTUNATELY THIRD FIDDLE IN
THAT ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND WILL
BE MEETING ON ADJOURNMENT OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO A
LOT OF EXCITEMENT OVER THERE.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT YOU'VE GOT
ALL THE COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS
WE WILL NET NOW BREAK AND WE
WILL RECONVENE HERE. AT ONE PM
SHARP THANK YOU MEMBERS
WELCOME BACK MEMBERS. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. PURSUANT TO SET A
RULE TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE
TEN DE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE. AND SB
FIVE FIFTY. AND CENTER PAN
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT BY SOME NEVER LOW
TO THE ACTIVE FILE. THE DESK
WHEN OF MAKING. EIGHTY ANYTHING
ELSE UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES SEEING NONE WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING UP FIRST IS FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE. AND
SENATOR DODD IS NOT AT HIS DESK.
WELL HERE IS. ARE YOU PREPARED
SIR. OR. YEAH IT IS. THAT'S
OKAY BABY YEAH YOU COULD BUT
YOU CAN PERCENT. I AM MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND NECK
GOING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND MAKING A PROPOSED
THEREFORE CENTER DIED MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. MAY I PRESENT IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. TIME AND AGAIN WE'VE SEEN
A FOR PROFIT COLLEGES PREY ON
LOW INCOME STUDENTS CHARGE
EXORBITANT AMOUNTS IN TUITION
BILL TO PROVIDE THE SKILLS AND
JOB PROSPECTS THAT OUR PROMISE
IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIOS.
CLOSE CAMPUSES WITHOUT ANY
RETRIBUTION. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX WILL ALLOW VICTIMS FOR NOT
FOR PROFITS SCHOOL CLOSURES AND
MISREPRESENTATION RECOVER FUNDS
SPAT WHILE ATTENDING SCHOOL
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WOULD NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SIR DOT ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATERS QUESTION
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE QUITE A
FEW MEMBERS SAW OFF THE FLOOR
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE ROLE ONCE AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO PLACE IT ON CALL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL BY
BURGESS RADFORD I CABALLERO.
CHIANG I DALY. DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
WITH SO. HI TITLE. JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. MONNING. BY MORE LARK
I'M A REAL. NIELSEN PAN HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. STONE HI NUMBER
IRAQ OWSKI. WIENER WILK BY.
CENTER DIED MOVES THECALL BUT
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX
CENTER DRAWS ARE YOU PREPARED
AND SHE IS MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX BY SOME
MEMORY AS AN ACT REALLY INTO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND CLING
THERE'S THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR RAZA THE
FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT TODAY PRESENT TO YOU
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES THIS BILL
IS A LOT THE YOU KNOW CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL AND IT REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY OFFICER.
OFFICE TO PARTNER WITH LOCALLY
CONTRACTED EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO MAKE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TWENTY TWENTY FEDERAL DECENNIAL
CENSUS AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
AT SCHOOL THIS BILL ASSET
FAMILIES BE PROVIDED WITH
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SENSES AND
ANY OTHER INFORMATION THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COMPLETE
COUNT SENSES OFFICE DETERMINES
IS NECESSARY OR CONVENIENT TO
ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN OUR
SENSES IN ORDER FOR TECH
CALIFORNIANS TO RECEIVE OUR
FAIR SHARE OF FEDERAL FUNDS
THERE MUST BE AN ACCURATE COUNT
OFEVERYONE THE TWENTY TWENTY
SENSES IS THE TOOL THAT WE HAVE
IT'S CRITICAL THAT EVERYONE.
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA IS
ACCURATELY COUNTED FOR SCHOOLS
OUR TRUSTY TRUSTED INSTITUTION
AND THE OFFER A SAFE HAVEN FOR
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE. THAT
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE DISCUSSION CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
CHILDREN ARE ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS
SO OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE DON'T.
THIS A KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO
REPORT CHILDREN IN THE
HOUSEHOLD ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
LIVING WITH GRANDPARENTS OR
OTHER RELATIVES ARE AND OTHER
FAMILY SITUATIONS SO IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE PARTNER WITH
SCHOOLS AND THAT THE CHILDREN
THOUGH THAT THEY NEED O BE
PART OF THE CENSUS THAT. BOTH
THIS CURRENT CENSUS AND THOSE
IN THE FUTURE AND THEIR
FAMILIES KNOW WHATEVER FAMILY
ARRANGEMENT THEY MAY BE IN SO I
STRESS STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS AT THIS BILL THANK YOU
TONIGHT BUT- THANK YOU SIR AND-
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THREE
NINE SENATOR ALSO YOU MAY CLOSE
JUST AS WE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL. BILL I. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
HI DOLLY DODD AYE DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROW. HERTZBERG BY
HILL. WITH SO HI TADO. JACKSON
I JONES LEYVA I AM A CHOIR. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL. NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER. STERN STONE.
NUMBER FIVE A CASSIE. WIENER HI
WILK HI HI. SENATOR RAZA MOVES
THE CALL TEMPORARILY
TEMPORARILY PASS ON FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN SO NOW
MEMBERS WILL BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE CENTER
HUESO ARE YOU PREPARED. HE HAS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SOME OF THE ONE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AN
ACT RELATING TO ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. BY WEEKS
AT BILL IS READY YET MISTER
PRESIDENT SO. EARLY YES. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY CENTER MCGUIRE YOU
PREPARED. TEMPORARILY PASS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE
EIGHTY ONE SENATOR DODD WE HAVE
A WINNER CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION THE
FLOOR IS YOURS BOB IT'S
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX. OH MY GOODNESS ARE
YOU KIDDING ME. WE NOW HAVE THE
RIGHT. SCRIPT HERE. I I'M
AFRAID THIS IS THE WAY THIS
DAY'S GONNA GO FOR ME. NOW
SERIOUSLY AS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS PROGRESS IS OFTEN
STYMIED WHEN THE NEEDS OF ONE
NEIGHBORHOOD OR CITY DIFFERENT
FROM THE NEEDS OF A
NEIGHBORING. COMMUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY NEITHER SUBREGION
REALIZES ANY BENEFIT AND THE
SAME FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER BE TRANSIT ROAD REPAIR
GOES WITHOUT IMPROVEMENT FOR
DECADES. AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
SIX TO CHANGE THAT BY ALLOWING
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES THE ABILITY TO
ADVANCE IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS BY
SUBREGION SUBREGIONS THAT HAVE
SHOWN A DESIRE TO GET PAST THE
POLITICAL GLIB GRIDLOCK IN AN
EFFORT TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS BY
ENABLING LOCALS TO GENERATE
SELF HELP REVENUE THOSE
IMPROVEMENT DOLLARS GO EVEN
FURTHER WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO
PULL STATE GRANTS. WHICH MAY
REQUIRE SELF SUSTAINING SOURCES
OF FUNDING AS A CONDITION OF
ELIGIBILITY. I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
DISCUSSION SENATOR NIELSEN. THE
SPREAD IS LET YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE YOU KNOW
THIS KIND KINDA SOUNDS SIMPLE
THEN IT'S LIMITED THREE
COUNTIES ONE OF WHICH I DO
REPRESENT ONE WHICH I DID
REPRESENT. BUT IT'S DANGER HERE
IT'S CALLED WHAT I CALL SHOP
FOR YOUR VOTERS. YOU CAN NOW.
WHERE YOU WILL HAVE THE BOAT
TAKE. NOW IF THAT'S IN A REGION
OR AREA. COULD BE SEVERAL MILES
COULD BE A FEW BLOCKS. BUT
PEOPLE AROUND THAT NECK OF THE
WOODS MIGHT NOT LIKE WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE. AND SHOW A
MINORITY GROUP. OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO LIVE IN SOME AREA. MIGHT BE
HAPPY TO HAVE IN THE TAX
IMPOSED UPON. AND THEN SOME
KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT
THAT IS AGREE JUST ONEROUS TO
ALL OF THEIR NEIGHBORS. THE
DANGER DEN. IS GETTING DOWN THE
SLIPPERY SLOPE. OF ALLOWING
ELECTIONS. WHERE YOU'RE VOTERS
ARE PICKED BY THE AUTHORITIES
WHO ARE TRYING TO SECURE. YES
VOTES. THANK YOU SENATOR. IN
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION THING
NINE SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU
CARE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR A THANK YOU SIR WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
BRIDGES EFFORT I COVER YELLOW I
CHIANG NO DALY. DODD. I'D
RATHER AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG BY HILL. WITH
SO. HI TADO. JACKSON BY JONES
NO LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO
PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN STONE
NO BURKE NO KATHY WINNER BY
WILK NO. CENTER DIED MOVES THE
CALL YEAH MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO
SENATOR HUESO ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS TEMPORARILY OR PASS ON
FILE. PASS ON FILE THANK YOU
SIR. NINETY FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE SENATOR DRAW SO
SHE'S UP SO MISTER SECRETARY IF
YOU COULD PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AN
ACT RELATED TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SENATOR OSLO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. AB
TWELVE NINETEEN WOULD PROVIDE
THE STATUTORY CHANGES NECESSARY
TO IMPLEMENT A NEW STREAMLINED
AND TRANSPARENT SYSTEM FOR
MONITORING THE PROPER
ASSIGNMENT OF TEACHERS IN OUR
SCHOOLS RESEARCH OVER DECADES
AS MADE ONE THING VERY CLEAR.
THE PREPARATION OF THE
CERTIFICATION OF OUR TEACHERS
IS THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
PREDICTOR OF STUDENT SUCCESS
THE PROPER ASSIGNMENT OF
TEACHERS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS. MISS
ASSIGN TEACHERS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO LEAVE THE PROFESSION
CREATING AN UNSTABLE AND LESS
EFFECTIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
FOR STUDENTS WHO NEED THE MOST
SUPPORT. THE NEW MISS
ASSIGNMENT MONITORING SYSTEM
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE ANNUAL MONITORING OF
ASSIGNMENTS AT ALL SCHOOLS
REPLACING THE CURRENT SYSTEM A
MONITORING ONE QUARTER OF
SCHOOLS PER YEAR. IT WILL ALSO
TRANSITION SOME OF THE WORK
FROM A PAPER AND PENCIL SYSTEM
TO A MORE EFFICIENT AUTOMATED
SYSTEM RECENT AMENDMENTS I
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RELIABLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
EIGHTY. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI BATES.
BILL HI PORGES. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO BY CHIANG AYE DALY
DODD AYE DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROW
HERTZBERG AYE HILL WITH SO TADO
JACKSON HI JONES. LEYVA I AM
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK MERRELL. NIELSEN
PAN HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN STONE.
NUMBER IRA CASKEY. WIENER. HI
WILK HI BY. SENATOR ALSO MOVES
THE CALL MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO. AND CENTER
HUESO IS PREPARED TO PRESENT SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. THERE ARE
WAYS OF THANK MISS FIRST
PRESIDENT A. B. TEN EIGHTY
THREE AUTHORIZED MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST AN
ANALYSIS BY THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY. ON PROPOSED
MEASURES DEALING WITH ENERGY
PROCUREMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
MANDATE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONER TO BAIT.
THREE NINE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
BY ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
PURCHASED BY BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. AYE CHAIN I DALY
DODD. HI TERRAZZO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ OUR
GROWTH HERTZBERG. BY HILL WITH
SO BY TACO JACKSON. JONES
JACKSON HIGH JONES ACT LEYVA
I'M MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL
WELL LIKE I MORRELL. HI NIELSEN.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN
STONE HI AMBERG OUR KELSEY
WIENER. BY WILK HI. CENTER
HUESO MOUSA CALL. MOVING ON
WILL NOW PROCEED TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FOUR CENTER GLAZER
YOU PREPARED HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEIR FOR
THEIR GLAZER THE FLORIDA THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS ON PLEASE PRESENT TO US
ON THE BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY BY
THE- DISTINGUISHED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. HI THIS IS A SUNSET
BILL FOR THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD. COURT REPORTERS BOARD IS
AN ENTITY INTO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS AS MANY OF
YOU NOW. RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING COURT REPORTERS AND
SHORTHAND REPORTERS THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE OPERATION OF THAT
BOARD FOR AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
YEARS. MAKE SEVERAL ADJUSTMENTS
TO ITS PRACTICE ACT IN RESPONSE
TO ISSUES RAISED DURING OUR-
SUNSET REVIEW. THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES OF BOTH
HOUSES OF WILL CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE ON. FURTHER
SUBSTANDARD ISSUES RELATED TO
THE BOARD OVER THE COMING YEAR.
ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO
CONTINUE THE OPERATIONS OF THE
COURT REPORTER SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES BELL BY
BURGESS. BRADFORD BY CARRIER I
CHIANG BY DAILY DODD. BY THE
RAZA. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG. I
HILL. HUESO. HI TADO JACKSON I
JONES BY LEYVA BY MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL BY NELSON. I
PAN BY PORTANTINO. BY ROTH BY
RUBIO I SKINNER STERN. STONE I
AM BURKE TYLER CASKEY. WIENER
AYE WILK HI. THERE ARE GLAZER
MOUSA CALL NOW MEMBERS MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
CENTER GLAZER YOU PREPARED HE
IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
A SOME OF THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
PARKS THERE GLAZER THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
SURE MY COLLEAGUES ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS BILL THAT BANS
SMOKING IN OUR STATE BEACHES
AND PARKS. I HAVE HAD A BILL ON
THIS FLOOR THAT WE HEARD
EARLIER IN THE YEAR AND
ASSEMBLYMAN LEVINE IS DONE THE
SAME THE THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY
PROCESS. SO I THINK YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL. THIS A
WILL ENSURE THAT OUR PARKS AND
BEACHES ARE KEPT PRISTINE AND
SAFE FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS TO
ENJOY MANY FIRES HAVE BEEN
CAUSED BY. SMOKING AND OF
COURSE ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
TRASH ITEMS ON OUR BEACHES. IS
THAT CIGARETTE BUT SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR GLAZER. ANY
FURTHER JUST THE BETTER
DISCUSSION THING I MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL FIVE GORGEOUS. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALY DOT.
TIRADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER BY
GONZALEZ BY GROVE HERTZBERG AYE
HILL WITH SO. BY TADO JACKSON.
HI JONES NO LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORRELL. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROUGH.
HI RUBIO I SKINNER STERN STONE.
NO BURKE OUR CASKEY WINNER BY
WILK BY. ONLY GOING TO THE ROLE
ONE TIME SO CENTER GLAZER PUTS
THAT ON CALL NEXT ITEM UP FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX CENTER
ALLEN IS NOT AT HIS DESK MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN DOCTOR PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED YOU ARE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL HEALTH I TO
PAN THE FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS AYE
RICE PERCENT EIGHTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
BERMAN WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH UNIT WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA THE PART OF
EDUCATION FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HEALTH RELATED PROGRAMS AND
ADVISING ON ISSUES RELATED TO
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH BASED
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WHEN POORLY TREATED
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS CAN HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE BEHAVIOR AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT A SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH UNIT WOULD ASSIST
SCHOOLS AND DRYING DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS AND ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS MAY
CONTINUE RECEIVING HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL SITES I THINK WE ALL
KNOW WE HAVE CHILDREN AND THEY
ARE MAY HAVE CONDITIONS WHETHER
IT'S CHRONIC HEALTH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. THOSE ISSUES DO
NOT GO AWAY JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE DROPPED OFF AT SCHOOL
WE NEED TO GET IN THE HELP WE
NEED TO GET FUNDING FOR THIS
THIS IS THE. BILL TO HELP US
GET IN THAT DIRECTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. EIGHTY
DEBATER DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL BY
BURGESS. BRADFORD I COVER
YELLOW I CHIANG BY DELHI DODD.
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI BY SIR I
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HUESO. HIGHER TADO.
JACKSON. BY JONES NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK MERRELL. NO
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER STERN
STONE. NO BURKE OUR CASKEY
WIENER AYE WILK HI BY. DOCTOR
PAN MOVES THE CALL OBJECTS FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. SENATOR
DIED WITH THE CORRECT SCRIPT.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACT REALLY INTO
RESOURCES CONSERVATION. SENATOR
DIED. MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I OBJECT TO THIS
SCRIPT SHAMING A COMMENT THERE
MISTER PRESIDENT BUT I AM
ROUTED TO PRESENT AB. SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO A BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO FORM
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS WITH
WORKFORCE IN EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. TO PROVIDE VALUABLE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE A RANGE
OF SINCERE CHALLENGES WHEN RE
INTEGRATING BACK INTO SOCIETY
SUCH AS REDUCE TIES TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
BARRIERS TO HOUSING AND GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT POST RELEASE. THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO THIS WORK
HAVE RECEIVED THE TRAINING
EXPERIENCE AND SKILLS THERE ARE
DEEPLY VALUABLE IN CRITICAL IN
THE AREAS OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION AND MANAGEMENT.
FUEL AND VEGETATION CONTROL A
DISASTER SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE FOLLOWING COMPLETION THE
FOLLOWING THE COMPLETION OF
THEIR SENTENCE THESE
INDIVIDUALS CAN APPLY IN YOUR
LIFE THE SKILLS THEY HAVE
ATTAINED TOWARD THE PROTECTION
AND DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR STATE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN IT'S A WIN
FOR CALIFORNIA IT'S A STEP
FORWARD IN INCREASING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND HELPING OUR
STATE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER DODD
EIGHTY DISCUSSION DEBATE MR
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT JUST BRIEFLY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS IN THE BIG
PICTURE OF THINGS. A QUITE
ELEGANT SOLUTION BETWEEN THE
KIND OF TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE
THAT OUR PROFESSIONAL FIRE
FIGHTERS ENGAGE IN AND THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO SIT DOWN IN AN
APPROPRIATE MANNER WITH WITH A
WHOLE GROUP OF PEOPLE AND TO
BRING THEM IN. AND TO CREATE
YOU KNOW I SAW ON THE BIG FIRES
THE LARGEST FIRE IN MY CITY AND
TALK ABOUT IT A LOT ON THIS
FLOOR IS EVERYBODY ELSE HAD A
LOT OF BIG FIRES BUT I THE
LARGEST FIRE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND I WATCHED A LOT OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
COULD BE INCARCERATED BEING
INVOLVED AND HOW IMPORTANT THEY
WERE AND THE BOND BETWEEN THEM
THE FIREFIGHTERS AND SO I THINK
THAT THIS IS A REALLY SMART
APPROACH. AND I JUST WANNA IN
ADDITION TO STAND IN SUPPORT
BUT TO JUST APPLAUD THOSE
INVOLVED BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
THE KIND OF THINKING THAT WE
NEED TO ENGAGE IN. IN THIS
INNOVATIVE CALIFORNIA TO COME
UP WITH NEW APPROACHES THE DEAL
WITH SO MANY OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN THE
HIGH STANDARDS ON THE ONE HAND
GIVE PEOPLE OPPORTUNITIES ON
THE OTHER AND MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF THE DAY WHATEVER
THAT DISASTER MIGHT BE. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE. NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BILL FIVE LARGEST I
BRADFORD. ZERO I CHIANG. DALY.
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI. I
HILL WITH SO. I TADO. JACKSON I
JONES. BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. BY MONEY. HI MORE
LOCK I AM A REAL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN STONE.
I AM BURKE POWER CASKEY WIENER
AYE WILK HI. SENATOR DODD MOVES
A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY NINE SENATOR HILL IS
NOT AT HIS DESK FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SENATOR HILL IS NOT AT
HIS DESK MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY ONE SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE YOU PREPARED AND
HE IS SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE AN ACT RELATING TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. CENTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU I MISS
PRESIDENTE MEMBERS. SENATE BILL
ACTION ME ASSEMBLY BILL ONLINE
TWENTY TWO WILL TREAT REACT
RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS EQUITABLY
BY REMOVING THE PROHIBITION ON
COMPENSATION FOR WOMEN
PARTICIPATING IN EGG DONATION
FOR MEDICAL RESEARCH. WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM THESE WILLING
PARTICIPANTS IN RESEARCH IN
FACT BECAUSE OF RESEARCH WE
HAVE MADE MEDICAL ADVANCEMENTS
IN RAW RESULTING IN TREATMENTS
FOR DISEASES THAT WERE ONCE
CONSIDERED INCURABLE AB NINE
TWENTY TO ENSURE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA JOINS FORTY SEVEN
OTHER STATES. THAT PERMIT
COMPENSATION FOR RESEARCH
PARTICIPANTS TIME TROUBLE AND
INCONVENIENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR ANY ADDITIONAL TO DISCUSS
OR DEBATE. THING NOW I'M MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL BY BURGESS HI BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG. DALY DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. GROWTH HERTZBERG. BY
HILL. HUESO I TADO. JACKSON
JONES. BY LABOR. TIME ACQUIRE
BY MITCHELL. MONNING BY MORE
LOCK RAIL. NIELSEN PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. STERN STONE HI. NO
STONE OF NUMBER HI WHAT CASKEY.
WIENER HI WILK. CENTER
PORTANTINO MOVES THE CALL. THE
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY TWO. SENATOR BELL.
AND HE IS READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CENTER BELL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE PROPERTY TAX
WELFARE EXEMPTION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
WHICH IS. IS AN EXEMPTION ON
THE PROPERTY TAX FOR THOSE KIND
OF PROJECTS THIS WOULD INCLUDE
THIS WOULD BILL WOULD INCLUDE
THE MELLOW ROOMS SPECIAL TAXES
AND PREVENTS THESE DEVELOPMENTS
FROM BE DENIED BASED ON THE
PROJECTS ELIGIBILITY TO RECEIVE
A WELFARE VISIT EXEMPTION.
ARJUN I BUILD THE SAYS NO NO
VOTES AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NO MIKE'S RAISED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BELL. I PURCHASE I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DELHI DODD I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO.
JACKSON BY JONES HI LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. STERN AYE STONE. I AM
BURKE BOB AKOWSKI. WIENER AYE
WILK HI HI. THIS PLEASE HOLD
DOWN THE CHAMBERS CENTER BILL
MOVES THE CALL. WE'RE NOW
MEMBERS CAN GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX SENATOR
ALLEN I KNOW HE'S READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AN ACT RELATING TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
ALLEN MEMBERS. I'M PRESENTING
AB ONE THIRTY AND OUR OUR
AUTHOR SOBRE LOS YOU'RE ON THE
FLOOR. THIS BILL. ESTABLISHES
THE HIGHER EDUCATION
PERFORMANCE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COURTNEY SHE COMMISSION. AS A
SUCCESSOR TO THE CALIFORNIA
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
COMMISSION SEE BACK. OUR TALKS
ABOUT FOLLOWING THIS AREA NOT
KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN WITHOUT A COURT NEEDING
ENTITY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE. WE'RE ONE
OF ONLY TWO STATES. WITH NO
COORDINATION OVERSIGHT
CAPACITY. AT THE STATE IS
PROJECTED TO BE ONE MILLION ONE
POINT ONE MILLION COLLEGE
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES SHORT
OF MEETING THE DEMANDS OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. BY TWENTY
THIRTY. THE INDEPENDENT BODY.
THAT FILLS THE GAP IT'S BEEN
LESS SPICY BAG WILL ADVISE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR. AND
THE VERY SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATON. IDENTIFYING
STATEWIDE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION GOALS MEASURING. WITH
SUPPLY AND DEMAND OF JOBS IN
VARIOUS FIELDS EVALUATING THE
SEGMENTS BUDGETARY PROPOSALS
REVIEWING PROPOSALS FOR NEW
DEGREES MAJORS. AND CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS ALL ABOUT CREATING
BETTER COORDINATION BETTER
BECAUSE HE'S IN. TO MEET OUR
BROADER STATEWIDE GOALS. IT
WILL ALSO SERVE AS A RESOURCE
FOR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TO AID THEM IN MAKING MORE
FORMS COLLEGE DECISIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND I HAVE
WORKED COOPERATIVELY TO MERGE
AB ONE THIRTY IF FOLKS MAY
REMEMBER I HAD SB THREE. WE
MERGE THEM INTO ONE BILL. AND
THAT WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLE HIGHER
EDUCATION COORDINATION ENTITY
THAT WE COULD WE COULD FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS COMMISSION WILL
ESTABLISH GREATER CLARITY IN
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR HER TO
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS
PERFORMANCE IN MEETING OUR
STATEWIDE GOALS AND I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS AB THREE ONE
THIRTY. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL BY BURGESS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. BY CHAIN AYE DALY
AYE DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. JACKSON BY JONES. HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LOCKED. I'M A
REAL. BY NELSON. PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER BY STERN. BY STONE
HI NUMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK BY. THERE ALLEN MOVES
A CALL. LIL OUT IN HERE TODAY
SO AS PLEASE TRY TO HOLD IT
DOWN IF YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS
TAKE HIM OUTSIDE OF THE CHAMBER
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE SENATOR
HILL. ARE YOU PREPARED YOU ARE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SOME OF THE NINE NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE NORRIS AN
ACT RELATING TO DRUG AND
ALCOHOL PROGRAMS CENTER HILL
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB NINE
NINETEEN TO ESTABLISH
ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND
ENFORCEMENT TO PREVENT BODY
BROKERING SCHEMES THAT PREY ON
VULNERABLE PATIENTS SEEKING
LEGITIMATE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. THE PACIFIC Là AB
NINE NINETEEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH AN
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM TO STOP
BODY BROKERING SCHEMES THAT
PREY ON VULNERABLE PATIENTS
SEEKING LEGITIMATE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL LIMITS HEALTH
FACILITIES OFFER HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION IS INDUCEMENTS
TO TREATMENT THIS MEASURE HAS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL COLLEGE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BILL I PURCHASE HI
BRADFORD HI KELLY GHETTO I
CHIANG. HI DALY AYE DODD. I
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO.
JACKSON HI JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY MONNING
HI MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL I
NIELSEN I PAN BY PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG IOWA
CASKEY I WIENER I WILL BUY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE MISSING MEMBERS. GROWTH BY
FURTADO. HI HI. BUT ALTHOUGH I.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WILL BE
GOING TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SENATOR HILL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND KNACK RELATING TO
MEDICAL EVIDENCE HEERY
EXAMINATIONS THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR THANK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF FISSION SEE AND
QUALITY OF MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMINATIONS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS AFTER AND DURING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT TIMELY ACCESS TO
TRAUMA INFORMED AND EVIDENCE
BASED CARE CAN PREVENT ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND ALLOW FOR
THE PROPER COLLECTION OF
EVIDENCE. THIS BILL WOULD
IMPROVE THE VIABILITY OF EXAM
TEAMS UPDATE EXISTING LAW TO
REFLECT THE BEST PRACTICES IN
HAN'S PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION
AND TRAINING FOR EXAMINERS AND
PROTECT THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
FORENSIC RECORDS AB FIVE THIRTY
IT HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU CENTER
HILL. HE NEED DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ARE THERE ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE NOW
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT MR MAJORITY LEADER.
MR MAJORITY LEADER YOU PREPARED
ON FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL A TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AN ACTUAL
IN A BUSINESS THROUGH THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW HOW. MEMBERS.
AMONG THE ARRAY OF ISSUES THAT
WE GRAPPLE WITH. IN THIS ON
THIS FLOOR. HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
OF HEALTHCARE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HEALTHCARE COSTS
DOMINATE NOT JUST THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HE'S WITH SO MANY OF
THE OTHER ISSUES AND PROVIDING
KIND OF THE CORE VALUES OF WHAT
WE NEED TO DO AS A GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE CARE OF THE FOLKS. THAT
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT HEALTH CARE
COSTS IS PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATION. YESTERDAY I WAS SAY
IN THE RENTS TO TALK TO THEM I
TODAY PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES
ARE TOO HIGH 17% OF OVERALL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE UNITED
STATES YOU GUYS CENTER SKINNER.
OUR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS 17% BIG
NUMBER. SO WHAT ASSEMBLY WHAT
THE CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN THE OTHER HOUSE
DOCTOR WOOD IS DOING HERE IS
FOUND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEY'RE EXPENSIVE. ONE OF THE
REASONS IS THAT OFTEN THERE'S
LASUITS PATENT LAWSUITS
BETWEEN DRUG MANUFACTURERS ARE
AMONG DRUG MANUFACTURERS HAS
BEEN A HOST OF LITIGATION ON
THIS. AND IN ORDER TO SETTLE
THE CASE THEY ENGAGE IN WHAT'S
CALLED HEY FOR DELAY AGREEMENTS
THINK ABOUT THIS. I'LL GIVE YOU
A FEW BUCKS WILL DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION I GET TO MAKE A
BUNCH MORE MONEY IN MY COMPANY
YOU GET TO MAKE A FEW BUCKS AND
WHO PAYS WE DO THE GOVERNMENT
DOES. EVERYBODY WHO PAYS THE
BILL DOES IT'S WRONG WHAT
DOCTOR WOOD IS DOING IN THIS
BILL IS PLUGGING THE HOLE
THERE'S BEEN A TUNNEL
LITIGATION TO STOP THIS HEY FOR
DELAY INSIDIOUS ACTIVITY.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE BRAND
NAME COMPANIES DRUG COMPANIES
TRANSFER SOMETHING OF VALUE IS
THE QUESTION TO DELAY THE
COMPETITORS RESEARCH MARKING OR
SALES IN A COMPETING VERSION OF
THIS DRUG. I DON'T YOU GO ON A
DETAILS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM ANY PHARMACIST
IN THE ROOM. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT THIS IS INTELLIGENT
APPROACH IT SETS A STANDARD TO
AVOID THIS ANTI COMPETITIVE.
BEHAVIOR I ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU MS MAJORITY LEADER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I
RESPECT THE RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FOUR. IS A VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE DELIVERY OF MEDICATIONS ON
TO THE MARKET AND- WHEN THEIR
PATENTS EXPIRE AND THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN BRAND NAME COMPANIES
AND OTHER COMPANIES INCLUDING
ENGINEER MANUFACTURERS AT.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT ACTUALLY
BRING SOME GENERIC DRUGS TO
MARKET SOONER THAN. THEY
LEGALLY COULD BE. THERE ARE
MANY GENERIC MEDICATIONS AT A
BECOME AVAILABLE DUE TO PATENT
SUPPLEMENTS AND SOME OF THEM
FOR YEARS BEFORE THOSE PATENTS
WERE TO EXPIRE. BUT BECAUSE
THIS BILL ALLOWS A CAUSE OF
ACTION WITHIN FOUR YEARS AFTER
SETTLEMENT AS OCCURRED THERE
ARE MANY MEDICATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PULLED OFF THE MARKET
BECAUSE THOSE SUPPLEMENTS. MAY
NOW BE CALLED INTO QUESTION.
BASED ON DIFFERENT LEGAL
STANDARDS IF THIS BILL IS
APPROVED. THIS COULD CAUSE
PRICES FOR MEDICATIONS TO
INCREASE AS LOWER COST
GENERICS. ARE PULLED OFF THE
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA AND I WANT
TO GIVE YOU SOME REAL EXAMPLES.
NAIAS SPANS DRUG USE KINDA
LOWER YOUR CHOLESTEROL MODIFIED
VERSION OF NIACIN. HAS
PRESCRIBED FOR HIGH CHOLESTEROL
THE PATENT SETTLEMENT. I CAN
HEAR MYSELF. A PATENT
SUPPLEMENT ALLOWED GENERIC
VERSIONS OF THIS DRUG ON THE
MARKET LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THREE YEARS BEFORE ITS PATENT
EXPIRED. THIS DRUG COSTS FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS AND SIXTY TWO CENTS FOR
TYPICAL PRESCRIPTION PRIOR TO
THE GENERIC COMING AVAILABLE.
NOW THE AVERAGE COST IS TWO
HUNDRED FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
IF YOU'RE CONCERNED WITH HIV.
LIKE MANY OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
INCLUDING I AM. MANY HAVE BEEN
PRESCRIBED ABSECON AN ANTIVIRAL
MEDICATION. THE COSTS OF THIS
DRUG PRIOR TO A PATENT
SETTLEMENT WAS TWELVE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE SEVENTY ONE. FOR A
TYPICAL PRESCRIPTION. BUT DUE
TO A PATENT SETTLEMENT GENERICS
WERE ALLOWED TO BE FILLED
EIGHTEEN MONTHS EARLY. AND NOW
HAVE THE AVERAGE COST OF LESS
THAN HALF. AT FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT DO YOU
REALLY WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
HIGHER COST DRUG ONLY. THERE TO
MORE WITH PRICE EXAMPLES MANY
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THESE
YOUR PARENTS INCLUDING SOME MY
RELATIVES HAVE BEEN USING
CELEBREX FOR. ARTHRITIC
CONDITIONS IT WAS. SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FORTY SEVEN
THIRTY DOLLARS AND FORTY FOUR
CENTS FOR THE STAND. NOW AN AVERAGE IS
A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY SIX CENTS FOR THE
GENERIC THE CAME ON THE MARKET
A FULL YEAR EARLY DUE TO A
PATENT SETTLEMENT. AND LUNESTA
STREETS IN THE BUTTERFLIES ON
TV FOR THE TREATMENT OF
INSOMNIA. THAT WAS NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE DOLLARS FOR A
TYPICAL PRESCRIPTION AND NOW IT
AVERAGES. FORTY DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY EIGHT CENTS AND IT CAME
TO MARKET DUE. TO A PATENT
SETTLEMENT. THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS A PATENT SUPPLEMENTS
ARE ONE WAY GENERIC COMPANIES
WHO WANT TO SELL DRUGS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BRING LOWER COST.
DRUGS TO THE MARKET SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER. WHILE THE
AUTHOR SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR
TRYING TO SOLVE A LARGE AND
COMPLEX ISSUE. THIS BILL IS TOO
BROADLY WRITTEN AND WILL
UNFORTUNATELY DO NOTHING MORE
THAN RAISE THE PRICE OF DRUGS.
SOMETHING I KNOW WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED ABOUT. FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASKED FOR A NO VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING NONE THAT
HERTZBERG YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
PHARMACOLOGIC HAS A REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT THIS
THE FIRST QUESTION IS THERE AN
AGREEMENT WORST MONEY WAS PAID
OR SOMETHING OF VALUE WAS PAID.
THEN THERE'S THE QUESTION OF
WELL IS IT PRO COMPETITIVE OR
ANTI COMPETITIVE AND WE LOOK AT
THE STANDARDS AND THEY WORK
WITH THE WITH THE COMMUNITY THE
WHO WAS INVOLVED WITH THIS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WERE WORRIED
THAT SOMEHOW THE STANDARD WAS
TOO HIGH IN TERMS OF PROVING
THAT THE AGREEMENT WAS PRO
COMPETITIVE BECAUSE SOMETIMES
IT COULD BE PRO COMPETITIVE AND
SO THIS IS ALL WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO GET A DIFFERENT SET OF
EYES ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND MAKE SUCH A DETERMINATION.
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
REDUCE COSTS AND PRINT AND
INCREASED. COMPETITION IN THE
SPACE I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR SO
WE ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO PLACE. THE MATTER ON
CALL SO WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I CHIANG
I DALY DODD. BY DORADO I
GALGIANI. GALGIANI. I GLAZER BY
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG.
GROW AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO HI TADO. BY JACKSON THE
BY. JONES NO LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE
HI MITCHELL. MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER. BY WHAT CASSIE
BY WINNER BY WILK BOOK I.
MISTER SECRETARY WAS CALLED THE
MISSING MEMBERS. BATES. BATES
NOW FOR JUST NO DALY. DORADO.
MITCHELL IT'S A LIE. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED IN THE MISSING
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DALY
DORADO. GROVE I TO KNOW. ALL
RIGHT THE CENTER HAS MOVED THE
CALL NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY TWO CENTRE
BELL. BE PREPARED. ARE YOU
PREPARED FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
TWO. PASS ON FILE. WE TO FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY THREE SENATOR
STERN. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ AND ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACCOLADE OIL AND GAS.
STERN THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WOULD MAKE
INFORMATION ON LEAKS FROM OIL
AND GAS WELLS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE CREATING A BODY OF
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES MORE AWARE
ABOUT THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
EMISSIONS. FROM IDLE AND
DESERTED WELLS THIS LIKE
AWARENESS IS IT IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE IN MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IT HAS
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION THANKS
TO A VERY SUCCESSFUL
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. THIS
AWARENESS HOPEFULLY WILL HELP
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
FIGHT OUR ENVIRONMENTAL CRISES
WHEREVER THEY MAY LAY THIS. IT
IS BILLS CRITICAL MEASURE THE
BUILDS ON SOME OF THE WORK
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN DOING THIS
SESSION WHEN IT COMES TO
PLUGGED IDLE ABANDONED WELLS
THIS IS ONE MORE COMPONENT TO
THE TO THE LARGER PUZZLE THAT.
WE NEED TO SOLVE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AB. THANK
YOU SENATOR ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES. HI
BILL I PURCHASE AYE BRADFORD
AYE KALLIO. CHANGE HI DOLLY I
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ BY GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL. HI HUESO BY
TITLE. JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. BY MITCHELL
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. IOWA CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI BY. WHERE TO
GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE MORE
TIME AND THEY WERE IN CLOSE AND
THEY WERE IN CLOSE IT OUT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE MISSING MEMBERS ATKINS.
CABALLERO HI. GALGIANI GROWTH
TADO HI MOORLACH. NICE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS FOR MEASURE PASSES WE
ARE NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS. DELHI
DORADO HI. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR.
MAJORITY LEADER'S READY SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AND ACT REALLY INTO CONSUMER
PRIVACY. IN HERTZBERG. VASE
MARE WE'RE BACK ON PRIVACY.
LAST YEAR AFTER MONTHS AND
MONTHS OF HARD WORK THIS BODY
TOGETHER WITH THE OTHER HOUSE
IN THE GOVERNOR PASS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT. BUT THIS ADDED AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS MANY PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS. UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
AND AMONG THOSE PROTECTIONS TO
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS FIRST. THE
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT INFORMATION
A BUSINESS IS COLLECTING ABOUT
YOU AND WHETHER IT'S BEING SOLD
OR DISCLOSE. SECOND THE RIGHT
TO TELL A BUSINESS NOT TO SELL
YOUR INFORMATION. DISCLOSURE
AND PERSONAL CONTROL.
DISCLOSURE AND PERSONAL CONTROL
THOSE WAR AT THE FOUNDATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACT. THAT LANDMARK
POLICY CO AUTHORED MY. MY DEAR
FRIEND FROM NAPPER SOMEWHERE
THAT WINE COUNTRY. PUT
CALIFORNIA AT THE LEADING EDGE
OF DEFINING PRIVACY LAW
NATIONWIDE AND IT WAS I THINK
IS MOST MEMBERS HERE FOR WHICH
YOU WERE HERE TO BOARD FOR TO
YOU TO STEP FORWARD. BUT MUCH
TO MY DISMAY INTO THIS MAY OF
MY. CO AUTHOR FROM APA.
HOWEVER PERFECT HE IS THE BILL
WASN'T PERFECT. THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE NEEDED
AND WE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
DUE TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT
AS AND IT'S TWENTY TWENTY
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AS THE
TWENTY TWENTY IMPLEMENTATION
DATES APPROACHES UP. APPROACHES
AND SEVERAL CONCERNS REMAIN.
WITH THE GUIDANCE OF THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHO IS TO MY RIGHT.
THIS MEASURE ONLY PHYSICALLY.
THIS MEASURES RESULT OF
EXTENSIVE WORK TO BRING THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO THE TABLE
AND UNDERSTAND HOW TO BEST
MPLEMENT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PROTECTION ACT WITHOUT
ON INTENDED CONSEQUENCES THE
BILL TAKES TO CRITICAL TO
CRITICAL ISSUES WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION. IT ADDS A
REASONABLE STANDARD TO AVOID
OVER EXPANSIVE INTERPRETATION
AND IT REMOVES RESTRICTIONS
PLACED ON USING INFORMATION
FROM PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
GOVERNMENTAL RECORDS IN ORDER
TO HELP THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER. PROTECTION ACT. AVOID
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. IT ALSO AVOIDS
COSTLY CONFUSION IT WOULD
PROLONG IMPLEMENTATION PUSHING
BACK WHEN CALIFORNIA'S COULD
UTILIZE THEIR NEW RIGHTS
PROMISED TO THEM BY THE SEA
CPA. IT IS A IMPORTANT GET
SMALL BUT YET IMPORTANT PART OF
THE LARGER SAGA AS WE DEAL WITH
PER TWO WITH PRIVACY AND THE
UNBELIEVABLE CHANGES THAT ALL
OF US ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FACE
THIS TECHNOLOGY INFORMS THE
FUTURE. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP WITH MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES TO MY LEFT. BUT ONLY
PHYSICALLY. OUR END AND THANK
HIM OF COURSE FOR HIS HARD WORK
IN ACCOMPLISHING WHAT. IS THE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY PRIVACY
LAW. AT A TIME WHEN OUR
INFORMATION IS BEING SOLD USE.
ANLYZED IT AFFECTED AGAINST US
IN OUR POLITICAL WORLD IN IN
OUR- PERSONAL LIVES AND FOR OUR
FAMILY THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT IS THE FIRST AND
ONLY ONE IN THE COUNTRY. AND SO
I BELIEVE IT IS BEEN CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MAINTAIN ITS ELEMENTS
WITHOUT WEAKENING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL OR TAP
LOCATION. THIS MEASURE.
ACCOMPLISHES THAT GOAL WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME IT DOES GIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY SO THAT
AS IT IS IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. IT WILL
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF THOSE
PRIVACY CONCEPTS WHICH WERE
ARTICULATED BY MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM LA ON DISCLOSURE AND
CONTROL. THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
MAINTAINS THOSE IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS WHILE PROVIDING
DIRECTION AND GUIDANCE TO THE
INDUSTRIES AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
THIS IS ONE OF A FEW ADDITIONAL
BILLS THAT WILL BE SEEING. ON
THIS FLOOR. THAT ADDRESS THIS
SIMILAR CONCEPT BUT DO IT WITH
THE SAME PARAMETERS
EXPECTATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
SO THAT THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
OUR RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS
PROTECTED AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THING NINE OF THE FOR
THE ROLES CALLED WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR SO
WHERE TO GO TO THE ROLE ONE
TIME. NEVER GONNA PLACE IT ON
ON CALL MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSESSMENT ABOUT. MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL HI PORSCHES BY BRADFORD HI
CAMBIADO I CHIANG I DALY. DODD.
HI DORADO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE I JACKSON AYE
JONES. BY LEYVA BY MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL BY MONNING AYE
MOORLACH. I'M A REAL I NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY
ROTH RATHER. RUBIO I SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE AYE HAMBURG.
OUR CASSIE I WINNER. WILK HI HI.
THE CENTER PUTS IT ON CALL UP
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN
CENTER WHITE HOUSE GEAR YOU
PREPARED YOU ARE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON AN ACT
RELATING TO CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS SENATE RIGHT
CASKEY MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
SIXTH ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCURACY IN THE REPORTING OF
GIFTS IN KIND THESE ARE THE NON
CASH. DONATIONS BY CHARITIES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO REGULATIONS
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS
A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL NOT AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ADDRESSES
REPORTED PRACTICES BY SOME NOT
ALL CHARITIES BUT BY SOME
CHARITIES THAT GROSSLY INFLATE
THE VALUE OF THE REPORT
REVENUE. AND PROGRAM EXPENSES
CITY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
DONATIONS OF PHARMACEUTICAL
DRUGS. OVER VALUATION THAT'S
THE PROBLEM OVER VALUATION OF
SUCH DONATIONS LEADS THAN
INFLATED TOTAL REVENUE FOR THE
CHARITY WHICH MAKES A CHARITY
APPEAR MORE CHARITABLE
INEFFICIENT UP TO THE PUBLIC
AND POTENTIAL DONORS. AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE WHICH REQUIRED THESE
CHARITIES EMPLOY A DIFFERENT
ACCOUNTING METHOD TO ACCOUNT
FOR PHARMACEUTICAL DONATIONS
WHEN REPORTING ANNUAL DATA TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. BUT ONLY
IN CASES WHERE THE DONOR HAS
RESTRICTED THE DISTRIBUTION AND
USE OF THE DRUGS TO BE OUTSIDE
THE UNITED STATES WHOSE ONLY
RESTRICTING THE USE OF THE
DRUGS OUTSIDE THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE IN THESE CASES. THE
BILL REQUIRES CHARITIES TO
REPORT THE VALUE OF THE
DONATION TO REFLECT ITS FAIR
VALUE IN. THE MARKET. IN THE
COUNTRY WITH THE ULTIMATE. A
BIG AND DISTRIBUTED NOT THE
VALUE OF WHAT IS GOING TO BE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES MARK.
IF THE DONATION HAS NO SUCH
DONOR RESTRICTIONS ON ITS USE
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY WE SAY
THAT AGAIN IF THE DONOR IF THAT
THE NATION DOESN'T HAVE A SUCH
A RESTRICTION BY THE DONOR. FOR
THIS ULTIMATE USE IT DOES NOT
APPLY. AS AMENDED THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO PHARMACEUTICAL
DONATIONS. THEREFORE IN KIND
DONATIONS FOR CLOTHES FOR FOOD
FOR TOOLS AND ALL OTHER KINDS
OF IN KIND ARE ALSO EXEMPT FROM
THE BILL. IN ALL THOSE CASES
INDUSTRY CAN PRINCIPLES STILL
APPLY WHEN IT COMES TIME FOR
THE VALUATION A DONATION RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL. DELAYED
THE IMPLEMENTATION BY YEAR WITH
THAT I REGION I VOTE. AND
ANTICIPATE AND ACCOUNTING
QUESTION. THANK YOU SIR BYE
CASKEY EIGHTY. THE BETA
DISCUSSION SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. BY
A LITTLE FRUSTRATED THAT THIS
BILL WAS NOT HEARD IN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IT DOES
DEAL WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. MATTER IT'S AN INCOME HE
YELLS OUT FOR SHAQ CERTAINLY.
THIS PLACE SO LITTLE RESPECT TO
THE SENATOR PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. I'M
ALSO DISAPPOINTED DIDN'T GO TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
BECAUSE IT IS A MATTER THAT IS
OF NATIONAL IMPORT AND THIS
BILL IS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT IT'S PROBABLY NOT THE
APPROPRIATE VENUE I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT IT WON'T BE
IMPLEMENTED FOR YEAR WHICH-
DOES GIVE THE. FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD
SOMETIME ALTHOUGH THERE IKE A
GOVERNMENT TO THEY DON'T MOVE
AS QUICKLY AS YOU WOULD LIKE
BUT THE FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS BOARD. THROUGH ITS
NOT FOR PROFIT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. HAS ALREADY TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO EVALUATE
THE PRACTICES AND PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH DETERMINING THE
FAIR VALUE OF NON CASH GIFTS IN
KIND. THEY HAVE BROUGHT
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
ACCOUNTING PROFESSION
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS STATE
CHARITY REGULATORS AND CHARITY
WATCHDOG GROUPS TO ADDRESS THE
VERY CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. THIS
GROUP IS ALREADY IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING HOW GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRACTICES
CAN BE REVISED TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OVER THE VALUATION OF
GIFTS IN KIND FOR CHARITABLE
PURPOSES. THEREFORE MISTER
PRESIDENT WOULD BE BETTER TO
HAVE AN A STRONG NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION LIKE WE CALL IF AS
BEER THAT THAT BE IS BE THE
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING STANDARDS
BOARD TO COME DOWN AND REQUIRE
THIS FOR ALL NON PROFITS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AS
OPPOSED TO BEING AND OUT LIAR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. HAVING A
SEPARATE APPROACH. SO THIS BILL
SHOULD BE DEFERRED IT SHOULDN'T
BE DEFERRED ONE YEAR BUT IT
SHOULD BE DEFERRED TO TELL THE
FAST BEAT OUR FASB. HAS ISSUED
A PROPAGATION ON THIS MATTER IF
BASS WE DOESN'T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER WITHIN A YEAR TWO OR
THREE THEN WE SHOULD BE DOING
THIS LEGISLATION BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I'M A NO. ON AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBASING KNOW MIKE'S UP THERE
Y. KASKI MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT TO BE CLEAR
THE FAST BE THE FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD HAS
KNOWN ABOUT THIS OVERVALUATION
PROBLEM FOR A LONG TIME AND IS
THE CLIMB TO TAKE ACTION
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE VALUE
VALUATION OF GIFT IN KIND
DONATIONS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
PUBLIC EXPOSURE AND CRITICISM
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE WITH
MULTIPLE NEW STORIES AND
PUBLICATIONS. WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
REMINDER WE DO HAVE MEMBERS OFF
THE FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME AND
THEN PLACE IT ON CALL. MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES
NOBEL HI BURGESS HI BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. CHANGE I DALY. DODD
BY TERRAZZO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TITLE AYE JACKSON AYE JONES. NO
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LUCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN. PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
WILK YEAH NO. CENTER Y. KASKI
MOVES THE CALL NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT CENTER HER TITLE
ARE YOU PREPARED PASS ON FILE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE SENATOR BELL HE IS
READY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TEEN AND ACT RELATING TO
SURPLUS LANDS FLUSH YOUR CENTER
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL BRING CLARITY AND PROVE IF
ENFORCEMENT OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
CLARIFYING EXISTING PROVISIONS
OF THE ACT IN FORCING THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT THROUGH THE
HOUSING COMMUTE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND LEVERAGING
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW TO PROMOTE
HOUSTON IF EFFICIENCY OF
SURPLUS LAND ACT WE HAD SOME
RECENT AMENDMENTS I KNOW A
LETTER DATED SEPTEMBER NINTH IN
THE FILE REMOVING OPPOSITION OF
SERVER GROUPS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NO MIKE SET
UP A MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. ATKINS
BATES. NOBEL BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG NO DALY. DODD. HI DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. I TACO NO
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH PORTANTINO
ROTH IRA RUBIO. SKINNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER. OUR
COUNTY I WINNER. WILK NO.
SENATOR BELL MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
HUNDRED SENATOR STERN AND HE IS
READY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH
AN ACRYLATE A FIRE SAFETY.
CENTER STERN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THIS SESSION WORKING ON. ONE
ISSUE RELATED TO WILD FIRES.
AROUND A UTILITY RISK FRAMEWORK
WE PASSED. IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION IN THAT REGARD BUT
OUR JOB IS FAR FROM COMPLETE.
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE WILD IN
URBAN INTERFACE ARE STILL AT
RISK OF THEIR POWER BEING SHUT
DOWN THEIR HOMES BURNING DOWN
AGAIN EVACUATIONS BEING IMPEDED.
AND AB THIRTY EIGHT I THINK IS
A- IS A CRITICAL FIRST STEP. IN
A STATEWIDE EFFORT. TO START
EMPOWERING HOMEOWNERS IN A
STATE TO DO SOMETHING
THEMSELVES ABOUT PROTECTING
THEMSELVES FROM WILD FIRE IT'S
ONE THING FOR SACRAMENTO TO
STEP IN AND SAY WE'VE WE'VE
BUILT A RISK MITIGATION
FRAMEWORK IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE IT'S ANOTHER TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO YOUR NEIGHBOR
AND SAY HERE TOOLS YOU CAN USE
TO MAKE YOURSELVES SAFER. AND
MAKE YOUR NEIGHBOR SAFER. AB
THIRTY EIGHT WITH LAUNCHES
STATEWIDE PILOT PROGRAM FOR
FIVE YEARS. TO START THE
PROCESS OF ALLOWING HOMEOWNERS
TO HARDEN THEIR HOMES. NOT JUST
ON A HOME BY HOME BASIS BUT ON
A COMMUNITY BASIS. THE CLIMATE
CRISIS PRESENTS US WITH NOT
JUST AN ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGE
BUT THE CIVIC CHALLENGE. WE'RE
NEIGHBORS ACTUALLY HAVE TO WORK
WITH OTHER NEIGHBORS TO MAKE
THEMSELVES SAFER. IF YOU
RETROFIT YOUR HOME AND YOUR
NEIGHBOR DOES NOT YOUR HOUSE
CAN STILL BURNED DOWN. AN
INSURANCE INDUSTRY RECOGNIZES
THAT BECAUSE. THEY'RE STARTING
TO LEAVE THE MARKET PLACE WE'RE
SEEING CANCELLATIONS AND NON
RENEWALS ALL OVER THE STATE. SO
THIS MEASURE IS NOT JUST ABOUT.
EMPOWERING HOMEOWNERS TO MAKE
THEMSELVES FEEL SAFER. BUT IS
MY HOPE THAT IT'S A MEASURE TO
GET US BACK TO A SUSTAINABLE
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE. AND
HOPEFULLY GIVE PEOPLE SOME
TOOLS TO TAKE CONTROL BACK OVER
THEIR LIVES AND NOT JUST TO
FEEL POWERLESS IN THE FACE OF
FIRE. I APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE A
CRITICAL ISSUE OVER THE BREAK.
WE HAVE A BOND PENDING THAT HAS
FUNDING FOR THIS HOME HARDENING
THAT WE'VE NOT YES PASSED OFF
THIS FLOOR. BUT I THINK WILL BE
A CRITICAL COMPONENT. BUT THE
BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY A
PARTICULAR FUNDING SOURCES. IT
IT TALKS ABOUT UTILIZING A
BROAD RANGE OF FUNNY INCLUDING
SUGGESTING FEDERAL FUNDS FROM
THE HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM. AND PRO ACTIVELY
TARGETING AT RISK COMMUNITIES.
SO I HOPE WE ALL STEP UP TODAY
AND START GIVING SOME POWER
BACK TO OUR PEOPLE. THE FIGHT
BACK AGAINST THE FIRES WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK
YOU CENTER STERN ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SITTING NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OUT AGAIN WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH IT ONE TIME AND THE
PLACE IT ON CALL MR. PLEASE
READ. ALAN. I ARCH LETTER I
ATKINS BATES. BELL I BURGESS HI
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHAIN I DALY. DODD HI DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO. HIGHER TADO. I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING
HI MORE LUCK I AM A REAL. NO
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE. HI NUMBER IOWA
CASKEY I WIENER BY WILK HI BACK
CENTER STERN MOVES TO CALL
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO THAT TOO ONE
CENTER JACKSON I SEE IF SHE'S
PREPARED SO MISTER SICK MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL. SEVENTY NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND ACT
RELATED TO BUSINESS. TWO THINGS
WE'VE BEEN RE LEASE. TWO OUT
TODAY IT IS DISRESPECTFUL TO
THOSE THAT ARE SPEAKING INTO
YOUR VERY LETHARGIC WE NEED TO
GET WE NEED TO PICK UP THE PACE
HERE MARIE BE HERE ALL NIGHT
WITH THAT CENTER JACKSON THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND- MEMBERS SITE
PERCENT. I PRESENT TO MY
DISRESPECTFUL AND LETHARGIC
COLLEAGUES. A MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WHICH
MIRRORS PENDING EUROPEAN UNION
REGULATIONS BY ENSURING THAT
OUR MOST BASIC NOTIONS OF
FAIRNESS ARE PART OF THE
BUSINESS PRACTICES OF MARKET
PLACES TREATMENT OF THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS PARTNERS THIS BILL
REMINDS ME A BIT OF A BILL I
DID A FEW YEARS AGO DEALING
WITH FRANCHISEES THAT SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE REMEMBER
WELL THERE IS FREQUENTLY A TRUE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE BIG GUYS
AND THE SMALLER COMPANIES THAT
ARE TRYING TO DO BUSINESS AND
DO IT FAIRLY HERE WE HAVE WHAT
WE SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
MEGA MARKET PLACES. THINK OF
AMAZON IS A MAKE A MARKET PLACE
AND THERE ARE MANY COMPANIES
THAT DO BUSINESS ON AMAZON
TRYING TO SELL THEIR PRODUCTS
ON AMAZON TRYING TO COMPETE
WITH OTHER COMPANIES AND
SOMETIMES END UP COMPETING WITH
AMAZON THE TERM TIME SHOWS
THEY'RE VERY PRODUCTS AND
SOMETIMES AT A LESSER PRICE SO
THIS IS A BILL THAT REALLY
TALKS ABOUT A DISCLOSURE AND
FAIRNESS THIS IS A BILL THE
FIRST REQUIRES A MARKET PLACE
THINK OF AN AMAZON. THEIR TERMS
AND CONDITIONS TO BE WRITTEN IN
PLAIN AN INTELLIGIBLE LANGUAGE
WITH THE COMPANIES WITH WHOM-THEY DO BUSINESS TO MAKE SURE-THAT THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS
ARE EASILY AVAILABLE ONLINE FOR
THE SELLERS THESE ARE THE
SMALLER COMPANIES THAT SELL
THEIR PRODUCTS AT THIS MARKET
PLACE AT ALL STAGES OF THE
COMMERCIAL RELATIONSHIP AND
DESCRIBES THE GROUNDS FOR WHEN
THE MARKET PLACE CAN HOLD A
BUSINESSES FUNDS PENDING
RESOLUTION OF A DISPUTE. SECOND
IT REQUIRES A MARKET PLACE THE
PERMITS SELLERS TO PAY TO
INCREASE THE RANKING OF THEIR
PRODUCT WE KNOW THAT IS DONE
YOU WANT TO GET YOUR YOUR
BUSINESS UP HIGHER WHEN SOMEONE
CLICKS ON AND YOU PAY THE TO DO
THAT IT WILL REQUIRE THE MARKET
PLACE TO DESCRIBE THE PROCESS
AND. PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW THE SELLER CAN OBTAIN THAT
WRITTEN. PRICE INFORMATION WHAT
THEY'RE CHARGING TO ONE COMPANY
OR ANOTHER TO GET THEMSELVES UP
HIGHER IN THE LIST. THIRD THE
BILL REQUIRES MARKET PLACES TO
PROVIDE THAT SELLER WITH A
WRITTEN STATEMENT OF REASONS
WHEN THAT SELLERS ACCOUNT IS
BEING SUSPENDED OR TERMINATED
FOR A VIOLATION OF LAW OR SOME
TERM OR CONDITION OF THE MARKET
PLACE. AND FINALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES MARKET PLACES TO
EXPLAIN WHETHER DECISION TO
SUSPEND OR TERMINATE AN ACCOUNT
CAN BE APPEALED AND IF SO WHAT
THEIR PROCEDURE FOR THE APPEAL
IS. WITH SUCH A LARGE FOOTPRINT
IN THE RETAIL MARKET PLACE
THESE LARGE MARKET THE PLACE
COMPANIES. BOTH ONLINE AND
PHYSICALLY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THE
TRANSPARENCY EXISTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT RELY
ON THESE RETAIL SPACES TO REACH
CUSTOMERS. AND TO GENERATE
REVENUES THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
TAKES A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
WHILE ALLOWING THESE MARKET
PLACES TO PROTECT THEIR
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION AND TO
ENSURE USER SAFETY. THIS IS A
BILL ABOUT BASIC FAIRNESS FOR
THE LITTLE GUY WHO WANTS TO
COMPETE IN THE MARKET WORLD AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
AT DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
SAYING NINE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCH Là
I ATKINS BATES. BELL I PORGES.
NO BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DALY BY DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO AYE
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NOPE NIELSEN NO PAN HI BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE NO
BURKE ABA CASSIE AYE WIENER AYE
WILK BY. SENATOR JACKSON MOVES
THE CALL. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
SENATOR ALSO AND SHE IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SOME OF THE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYEE SAFETY.
SENATOR OSLO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION. TO CONDUCT
STUDIES ON A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE OF FACILITIES WERE FIRE
EQUIPMENT IS MAINTAINED IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE THE RISK OF
EXPOSURE TO CARSON NOTE GENIC
MATERIAL. THE FIRE MECHANICS
THESE STUDIES WILL INCLUDE A
MEASUREMENT OF CARCINOGENIC
LEVEL EXPOSURE THE FIRE
MECHANICS AS WELL AS INTERVIEWS
WITH CURRENT AND FORMER
MECHANICS REGARDING THE
EXPOSURE TO THE MATERIAL. THE
INCIDENCE OF CANCER ON THE
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS THEY TAKE AT
THEIR WORK SITE THIS BILL IS
NEEDED TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF HARM BEING DONE TO
THESE WORKERS WHO ARE UNSURE.
OF THE RISK THEY ARE FACING
DOING THEIR JOB LITTLE RESEARCH
HAS BEEN DONE ON FIRE MECHANICS
RISK OF CANCER EVEN THOUGH THEY
WORK AROUND THE SAME
CARCINOGENIC MATERIAL. THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE INSIGHT AND
QUANTIFIABLE DATA ON THE RISK
POSED THESE INVALUABLE PUBLIC
SERVANTS SO THAT WE THEN CAN
MOVE FORWARD IN PROVIDING
PROTECTIVE MEASURES THAT WILL
SAVE THEIR LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. NINE
MYSTIC MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES BELL I
PURCHASED. BRADFORD BY CARRIER.
CHIANG HI DOLLY. DOT HI DORADO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA.
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROSS I RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN BY STONE. BURKE ABA
CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK. BY
SENATOR PUTS THE BILL ON CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO OH
THREE CENTER STERN ARE YOU
PREPARED. HE HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS CENTER
STERN FAME MISTER PRESIDENT
THIS BILL WOULD ENHANCE VOTERS
EXPERIENCE BY PROVIDING COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WITH
GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO DESIGN
BALLOT LAYOUTS THAT ARE USER
FRIENDLY AND COMPATIBLE WITH
NEW VOTING SYSTEMS. THANK YOU
SIR STERN ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. I WILL REMIND EVERYONE
IN THE CHAMBER THAT. WE HAD
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR SO WE ARE
GOING TO O THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE TIME AND THEN PLACE THE
MEASURE ON CALL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ME
PLEASE CALL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS. HI BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO. CHIANG. I DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO. GALGIANI BY
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROW AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TULLOW I JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
I MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORALE.
NO NIELSEN AYE PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY BY WIENER
AYE WILK HI. CENTER STERN MOVES
THE CALL MEMBERS WERE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO FOR
MR MAJORITY LEADER YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE BUT NEXT FILE ITEM
TWO OH FIVE SENATOR DORADO AND
SHE IS READY SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO IMPLEMENT SENATOR
ALSO YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. AB FIVE
FORTY SEVEN. THIS BILL WORKS TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF
HARASSMENT AND FEAR IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY AB FIVE
FORTY SEVEN WILL MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE TRAINING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE CREATED UNDER THE
PROPERTY SERVICE WORKER
PROTECTION ACT RECONVENES TO
DEVELOP REQUIREMENTS FOR
QUALIFIED ORGANIZATIONS AND
PEER TRAINERS THAT EMPLOYERS
ARE REQUIRED TO USE IN TRAINING.
I HOPE YOU NOTICED YOU MIGHT
HAVE SEEN SOME OF THESE
JANITORIAL WORKERS AT THE
CAPITOL YESTERDAY AND TODAY IN
THEIR WONDER WOMEN OUTFITS AND
SOME OF THEM ARE RIGHT HERE
TODAY IN THE GALLERY. FOR YEARS
THESE WOMEN HAVE BEEN WORKING
SO HARD TO BRING ATTENTION TO
WHAT GOES ON IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT WHILE WE'RE ASLEEP
AND THEY'RE WORKING. THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING SO HARD TO BRING
ATTENTION TO THE DANGERS THAT
THEY FACE. AND THEY SLOWLY HAVE
ONE STEP BY STEP. THE ATTENTION
THAT THEY SO WELL DESERVE AND
WHILE MUCH ATTENTION IS PAID TO
THE CELEBRITIES AND TO FAMOUS
PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE HARASSED.
IT IS TIME THAT WOMEN WHO WORK
IN THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY ARE
ALSO PAID ATTENTION TO FOR WHAT
THEY GO THROUGH. THIS
LEGISLATION EMPOWERS THOSE
JANITORIAL WORKERS BY UTILIZING
EXISTING PEER COUNSELORS OR
WHAT IS KNOWN IN OUR CULTURE AS
PROMOTE TAUGHT US TO PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT TRAINING
ON HOW TO PREVENT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IN THE
WORKPLACE. I ALSO RISE TO
CONGRATULATE MY SISTERS FOR ALL
OF THEIR HARD WORK AND EVERYONE
WHO HAS SUPPORTED THEM TO GET
AS FAR AS THEY HAVE COME TODAY
THEY TRULY ARE WONDER WOMEN AND
HEROES. COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
SINCE THE MOST RECENT
OPPOSITION HAS MOVED TO NEUTRAL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE IN THEIR- IN THEIR HONOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
GONZALEZ. VIEW OF CAPE CENTER
SKINNER FIRST. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE FOLKS FOR BEING HERE
TO SHOW US THEIR SUPPORT I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
EVERYONE WHO WORKED ON IT CAN
YOU IMAGINE. AT FIRST MOST IN
MOST OF OUR BUILDINGS JANITORS
WORK AT NIGHT WHEN ALL OTHER
STAFFER GOING THERE'S NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE BUT IT IS VERY
COMMONLY THE CASE SO YOU'RE
THERE YOU'RE WORKING THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE. AND EITHER YOUR
SUPERVISOR OR PERHAPS EVEN THE
VERY BOSS OF THE COMPANY.
ASSAULTS YOU HARASSES YOU.
YOU'RE ALREADY THE LOWEST PAID
WORKER YOU ALREADY FEEL THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY REAL RIGHTS
AND THEN YOU'RE VERY LIVELIHOOD
YOU FEEL MAY BE AT RISK FOR.
EVER. FILING ANY TYPE OF
COMPLAINT ABOUT SUCH HARASSMENT
I MEAN JUST THE TO IMAGINE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE TO ME IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE AS A PERSON A
WORKER SOWE'VE ALREADY DONE
LEGISLATION THAT GAVE THEM THEY
GAVE OUR JANITORIAL CIRCUS
STUDIO STAFFER HOTEL STAFF MUCH
MORE POWER IN RELATIONSHIP TO
THE WHEN THEY CONFRONT THOSE
KIND OF CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT SO
MANY ALREADY HAVE THAT THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL BECAUSE
ANY TYPE OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
EVEN HARASSMENT ID LEAVE A SCAR.
AND IT'S A SCARRED THAT TAKES A
VERY LONG TIME TO GET OVER AND
GET PAST I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
SENATOR GONZALEZ. I TO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HAVING WORKED WITH US SENATOR
THAT ALSO IN MY FORMER TIME AND
AS ALONG WITH CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND ENSURING THAT HOTEL
WORKERS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS IN
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH I AM SO
PROUD TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THESE WOMEN HERE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT OTHER
INDUSTRIES AND SIMILAR TO WHAT
SENATOR RUSSELL SAID THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
IN THE WORKPLACE. IN A HOLISTIC
VIEW NOT JUST THE CELEBRITIES
IN THE A WELL KNOWN BUT EVERY
SINGLE WOMAN IN FACT THE WORK
THAT WE DID IN LONG BEACH WAS
SO GREAT THAT. ONE OF THE TIME
MAGAZINE ME TO WOMEN WANNA WAS
ACTUALLY FEATURED IN TIME
MAGAZINE WHICH IS REALLY
INCREDIBLE WE DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN AGAIN WE WANT TO BE
FEATURED AGAIN BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO LIFT UP
THESE VOICES AND- AGAIN THANK
YOU. FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU SIR GONZALEZ. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEE NOW I HAVE SOME GREAT NEWS
WE HAVE EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR
BUT THE P. T. SO WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE TWICE AND WE
SHOULD BE GOOD TO GO SO WITH
THAT SENATOR ALSO YOU MAY
CLOSE. AGAIN I GET ALL THAT
LESS GLASS I LOVE MORE HEAD IS
BY LEE AND THIS GENTLEMAN
ALTHOUGH DONE BILL AND SUE ON
THE MOTHER DENTAL SPASO HOUSE
AND SU VIDA BUT I YEAH MODERATE
THIS YONI IGNITED A SPENT OKAY
MEDICINE SO I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR STRUGGLES AND
FOR. EVEN THOUGH IT'S TAKEN
YEARS OF FOR THEM TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY ARE TODAY TO
BE RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND FOR TAKING EMBRACING
EACH OTHER I WORKING WITH EACH
OTHER AS A COMMUNITY TEACHING
EACH OTHER TEACHING THEIR
EMPLOYERS TEACHING THEIR
SUPERVISORS THAT'S WHAT THE
PROMOTE THOUGHT US CONCEPT IS
ALL ABOUT AND NOTHING MAKES ME
PROUDER THAN THE DAY WHEN THEY
WERE OUT HERE WHEN THEY DID A
FAST. A WHEN THEY DID THEIR
MARCHES TODAY IS THE
CULMINATION. OF ALL THE HARD
WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO. OKAY MISTER SIT WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCH OF THAT
A I ATKINS BATES. BELL HI
PORGES. NO BRADFORD I CABALLERO
BY CHIANG I DALY. DODD I DORADO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN. HIPORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER TYLER
CASKEY. BY WIENER AYE WILK HI
THIS IS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE MISSING MEMBERS ATKINS.
EIGHT DALY HI GROWTH. JONES
MORE LOCK WELL NIELSEN STONE.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALRIGHT MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWO THOUSAND I
MEAN TWO THOUSAND SIX TWO OH
SIX SENATOR DODD. ARE YOU
PREPARED. TEMPORARILY PASS.
PASS ON FILE OKAY PASS AND
FOUND MOVING NOW ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO OO EIGHT CENTER
JACKSON. AND SHE'SREADY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE AN
ACT RELATING TO IMPLICIT BIAS
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL REQUIRE
ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES. TO
PARTAKE IN CONTINUAL EDUCATION
ON IMPLICIT BIAS EVERY THREE
YEARS AND REQUIRE THE COURT
PERSONNEL TAKE THIS CONTINUING
EDUCATION EVERY TWO YEARS.
IMPLICIT BIAS IS THE
UNCONSCIOUS AND UNINTENTIONAL
MENTAL SHORT CUT THAT HUMAN
BEINGS CAN AND FRANKLY DO
DEVELOP. THAT AFFECTS US ALL.
IT'S OFTEN SUBTLE ASSOCIATIONS
WE MAKE BETWEEN GROUPS OF
PEOPLE AND STEREOTYPES ABOUT
THOSE GROUPS IT'S USUALLY NOT
INTENTIONAL SOMETIMES IT'S JUST
WHAT WE GROW UP WITH THAT WE
DON'T REALIZE THAT WE HAVE
THESE BIASES THEY'RE NOT
MALICIOUS BUT THEY'RE THERE.
AND BECAUSE THERE ARE WE
ADDRESS. TAX ON THE PEOPLE
AGAINST WHOM THAT BIAS IS
REFLECTED. SUFFERED SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES EMOTIONALLY
SOMETIMES ECONOMICALLY AND
CERTAINLY THERE SOMETHING THAT
I DON'T BELIEVE IN I DON'T
THINK THE AUTHOR BELIEVES AND I
DON'T THINK MOST OF US BELIEVE
ARE THE WAY WE WANT TO LIVE IN
THE KINDS OF REACTOR OF
RELATIONSHIPS WE WANT TO HAVE
WITH OTHERS SO WE HAVE TO COME
TO TERMS WITH THE FACT THAT
EVERYONE DOES INDEED HAVE THEIR
OWN UNCONSCIOUS AN IMPLICIT
BIASES. MOST OF US SAYS I SURE
WOULD LIKE TO BE FREE OF THOSE
BIASES IN THOSE ATTITUDES THAT
LEAD US TO JUDGE PEOPLE BASED
ON THE SOCIAL CATEGORIES THEY
BELONG TO SUCH AS RACE GENDER
ETHNICITY RELIGION ETCETERA WE
KNOW THAT EXPLICIT BIAS
PURCHASE LIKE RACISM SEXISM AND
OTHER FORMS OF BIGOTRY AND
DESPITE PEOPLE'S BEST
INTENTIONS RESEARCHERS. HAVE
FOUND THAT SUBJECTS CAN
CONSCIOUSLY EMBRACE IDEAS OF
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY AND YET
ON TESTS THAT MAY OR SO
CONSCIOUS TENDENCY STILL SHOW A
STRONG PROPENSITY TO LEAN ON
THE STEREOTYPES THE FILL IN THE
BLANKS ABOUT PEOPLE. THEY DO
NOT KNOW. GIVEN THE JUDGES AND
ATTORNEYS AND COURT PERSONNEL
PROVIDE THE SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
WITH WHICH WE ALL AT SOME POINT
OR ANOTHER ARE LIKELY TO ACCESS
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE
WITHOUT SUFFERING BIAS THAT IS
THE NATURE OF THIS MEASURE. AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SITTING NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL I PORGES I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
BY DELHI. DODD HI DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO. I
JACKSON AYE JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I AM A
REAL. NO NIELSEN. PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
AMBERG OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK I. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
ATKINS DALY. GROWTH JONES.
NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY THREE
KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE SENATOR
ALSO AND I SEE THAT SHE IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AND ACT
REALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT SENATE
FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
PROTECT CALIFORNIA CALL CENTERS
JOB ACT IT HAS BECOME COMMON
PRACTICE FOR COMPANIES TO REAP
THE BENEFITS OF STATE FUNDING
AND TAX CREDITS WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME EXPORTING JOBS
OVERSEAS. CALL CENTER JOBS
SHOULD BE BASED IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE. AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS SEEKING
TO RELOCATE CALL CENTER JOBS
FROM CALIFORNIA TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY. GIVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS NOTICE. IN ADDITION
EMPLOYERS TO EXPORT CALL CENTER
JOBS OVERSEAS WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING ANY
STATE GRANTS GUARANTEED LOANS
OR TAX CREDITS FOR FIVE YEARS.
TWENTY NINE STATES INTRODUCED
OR PASSED LEGISLATION
PROHIBITING OR CLAWING BACK
STATE FUNDING FROM CALL CENTERS
INCLUDING LOUISIANA NEVADA AND
NEW YORK. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
SUPPORT OUR CALL CENTER WORKERS
AND PRIORITIZE STATE GRANTS AND
SUBSIDIES TO CORPORATIONS ARE
RETAIN CALL CENTER JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RUN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NO MIKE SUTTON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES NOBEL.
GORGEOUS. BILL HI PORGES NO.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DOT. DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
HI TADO. I JACKSON. I JONES
NOPE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NOPE NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH.
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE OUR CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK NO. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS ATKINS COVER YELLOW BY.
DODD I. ROTH BROTHER. HI IS
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND TEN
TO TEN. SLOW DAY TODAY AND I
SEE THAT CENTER BY CASKEY IS UP
SO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THEM FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVACY THROUGH THE
FLOOR SHORES MISTER PRESIDENT
AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX WOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT NEW MTOR VEHICLE
DEALERS ON THE ONE HAND. MAY
RETAIN VEHICLE AND OWNERSHIP
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO SHARE
IT WITH AN AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURER ON THE OTHER HAND
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ENABLING
WARRANTY WORK OR MANUFACTURED
RECALL FOR YOU THIS BILL IS
NARROWLY TAILORED ONLY THE COMP
WHICH THIS OBJECTIVE AND
CONSUMER WOULD RETAIN THEIR
OTHERWISE RIGHTS IN CONSUMER
REMEDIES UNDER THE LANDMARK
PRIVACY BILL. I RESPECTFULLY
PERJURING AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SIR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS MEASURE IS A CANNON FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE THERE
ANY OBJECTIONS. SEEING NINE
EYES THIRTY NINE NINE ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO FILE I AM TO ELEVEN
SENATOR DODD IS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSUMER PRIVACY
THERE FLOOR SHORES. I MISS
RESIDENTS SENATORS LAST YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH NEW
RIGHTS OVER HOW THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED AND
SHARED. IN ORDER FOR CONSUMER
EXERCISE THEIR NEW RIGHT THE
CCPA REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE A TOLL FREE PHONE
NUMBER FOR CONSUMERS TO MAKE
ACCESS IN DELETION REQUEST
ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THIS THAT
OPERATES EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE IT
HAS A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH
CONSUMERS FROM WHO A COLLECT
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO PROVIDE
AN EMAIL ADDRESS IN LIEU. OF A
TOLL FREE NUMBER. PROVIDING THE
EMAIL ADDRESS IS CONSISTENT
WITH HOW CONSUMERS ENGAGE WITH
BUSINESSES GENERALLY IN ENABLES
THE BUSINESS TO WORK WITHIN THE
BEST PRACTICES TO VERIFY IT
RESPOND TO REQUESTS. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN AMENDMENTS IN JUNE STATE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVERS.
THANK YOU CENTER DIED
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HAPPY TO
REPORT THIS IS ANOTHER CAñADA
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE
THERE ANY OBJECTIONS. SEEING
NINE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT FILE
ITEM. TO TWELVE SENATE GLAZER
YOU PREPARED HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
THE FIFTEEN NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE
HEALING ARTS CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU I MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SPENT A LONG DAY ARE
READY THAT APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION THIS IS
THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE DENTAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THE OTHER SUNSET
BILLS THAT WILL BE PRESENTING.
HI IS THE PRODUCT OF
COMPREHENSIVE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT. I TAKEN BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IN THE SENATE. IN
THE SENATE AND IN THE ASSEMBLY.
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO EXTEND
THE OPERATION THE DENTAL BOARD
WHICH IS CURRENTLY SCHEDULED
FOR REPEAL AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR. NOW THE THIS BILL DOES A
NUMBER OF SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
I ONE OF THESE HAVE ON THE
RECORD IT MERGES THE BOARDS TO
SPECIAL FUNDS ELIMINATES THE
SUSPENDED REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANT PRACTICAL EXAM
REQUIRES THE BOARD REPORT ON
THE STATUS OF PORTFOLIO
EXAMINATIONS THE TRANSITIONS
APPROVAL FOR FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS TO A NATIONAL CREDITOR
HE CLARIFIES THE APPLICATION OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
LIES. AND REQUIRES DANCES ON
PROBATION TO MAKE DISCLOSURES
JUST LIKE. A DOCTOR'S. HI THIS
BILL ALSO MAKES VARIOUS
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE DENTAL
PRACTICE ACT IN RESPONSE TO
ISSUES RAISED DURING THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS AND AS I SAID
THAT PROCESS BEGAN FEBRUARY.
THAN EXTENSIVE COMMITTEE REPORT
AND WE WENT THROUGH HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING AND
SUMMER. EVERY FOR THE PROVISION
IN THIS BILL IS SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO AN ISSUE DISCUSSED
IN THE COMMITTEES JOIN SUNSET
BACKGROUND PAPER. WHICH AS I
SAID WAS PUBLISHED LAST
FEBRUARY. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR. EIGHTY
DISCUSSION DEBATE CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT TO THE QUESTION FOR
THE FLOOR MANAGER PLEASE.
MISTER SERRA GLAZER YES AT THE
HORSE THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
PRESIDENT I. HAD. INDIVIDUALS
COME IN ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
PARTICULAR. ITEM THIS BILL AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK I GOT MY
QUESTIONS ANSWERED BUT AFTER
DEALING WITH THE APPOINTMENTS I
WONDERED WHY. A BILL THAT
SHOULD JUST BE EXTENDING A
SUNSET WOULD HAVE SOMETHING SO
CONTROVERSIAL IN IT THAT IT
WOULD MOTIVATE. SO MANY PEOPLE
WANT TO SET UP AN APPOINTMENT
WITH ME WHEN THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN IN A IN A SEPARATE BILL SO
WE TAKE CARE OF THE SUNSET AND
ONE AND THEN THIS X. RAY
PROVISION IN ANOTHER I'M JUST
WONDERING SHOULDN'T THESE
SUNSET BILLS BE LIKE OMNIBUS
BILLS I JUST KIND OF. SHOULD BE
FLYING THROUGH ALMOST ON
CONSENT THAT'S MY QUESTION
MISTER PRESIDENT. I GUESS I
HAVE A TWO PART ANSWER IF I MAY
FIRST WHEN THE LAST TIME YOU
HAD A DENTAL EXAM. I JUST HAD A
ROOT CANAL. AND I HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS SO I
DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'D NEED TO
REMIND ME. WELL FOR SOME THIS
BILL IS LIKE ROOT CANAL. BUT NO
MORE SERIOUSLY. TELL YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF INNOVATIONS IN
EVERY FIELD OF HEALTH CARE IN
THIS ONE IS CERTAINLY NO
EXCEPTION TO THAT AND TELE
DENTISTRY IS ONE OF THOSE
PLACES IN WHICH FOLKS ARE.
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE IN
DIFFERENT AND INNOVATIVE WAYS
AND IN SOME CASES IN THAT
REMOTELY WHERE YOU DON'T GO
INTO AN OFFICE AND YOU HAVE
THAT EXAMINATION SO THERE'S A
LOT OF INNOVATION IN THIS
SPACE. AND SO IT REALLY WITHIN
THE LAST FEW SEVEN LATE IN THE
PROCESS THOSE WHO PRACTICE TELE
DENTISTRY HAVE. WORRIED THAT
THIS THIS SUNSET BILL AND THE
PROVISIONS IN IT REGARDING
STANDARDS OF CARE AFFECT THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL HOW THEY
INTERACT WITH PATIENTS WHAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO. AND
THAT IS WHETHER OR NOT A PERSON.
WHO IS GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT TELL OF DENTISTRY. IS
PROVIDING TO HI A LICENSED
DENTIST BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU. I
THAT SERVICE OUT OF STATE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE IT REVIEWED BY A
LICENSED DENTIST IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SUNSET
EXTENSION. IS GOING TO PUT
PRESSURE ON THEM TO HAVE DONE A
AN EXAM. THAT MEETS THE
STANDARD OF CARE. AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THAT LAST MINUTE
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED BY
THESE COMPANIES THAT I THINK
YOU'VE GOTTEN THOSE VISITS IN
THOSE PHONE CALLS. BUT I THINK
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THE
CHAIR OF A BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS THE ASSEMBLY AND
MYSELF. AND OUR STAFF TO HAVE
LOOKED AT THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY'VE RAISED. WE FEEL THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING
DIFFERENT TO EXTEND THEIR
SANDERS A PRESS OF CARE THAT.
ARE IN LAW. THAT WE DO REQUIRE
THAT. A LICENSE DENTISTS BE A
PARTICIPANT IN THOSE TYPES OF
PROCEDURES THEY ARE INVOLVED
IN. AND DATE THAT THEY'RE GONNA
MOVE PEOPLE'S TEETH IN SOME
FIELD OF WORK. THEY'RE ACTUALLY
MOVING PEOPLE'S TEETH. THAT
THEY HAVE TO IF WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THAT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE FOR THE WHICH
THIS BILL WE THINK DOES AND ITS
EXTENSION SO I THINK AND HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
WELL IF IT COMES CLOSE IF I MAY
SURPRISE. ASK ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. OF COURSE YOU MAY
RESIDENT TO. I THE COR THE
QUESTION IS THE GOOD AS HIM A
MAN HAS BEEN DOING A LOT OF
SUNSET EXTENSION BILLS THEY'RE
ALL. PRETTY GENERIC IN IN A IN
ANOTHER THEY JUST FLY THROUGH.
BUT THIS ONE IS GENERATED A LOT
OF. ACTIVITY SO I I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY DID WE ANSWERED
THE LANGUAGE WHY DON'T WE JUST
DO A SEPARATE BILL. SO WE CAN
YOU KNOW GET THE X. SUNSET
TAKING CARE OF EXTENDED IN AND
THEN DEAL WITH THE- PEACE
MOVEMENT IN A IN A SEPARATE
DEBATE. WELL WITH A THIS IS I
THINK THE FULL REVIEW OF EACH
OF THESE HEROES IN AND THE WORK
THAT'S DONE. I DOES LOOK AT
POLICY IN FACT IF YOU READ OUR
POLICY PAPERS THAT. OUR STAFF
PROVIDES BEFORE EVERY HEARING
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE AN
EXAMINATION OF A LOT OF ISSUES
INCLUDING STAFFING IN FINDING
AN- ENFORCEMENT SEND AND ALSO
INCLUDES POLICY SO IT'S A
COMMON PRACTICE TO. EXAMINE THE
WIDE RANGE OF WORKING BEHAVIOR
IN THESE HEALTH PROFESSIONS AND
TO APPLY WHAT WE THINK ARE
APPROPRIATE. CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN IN IN BILLS LIKE
THIS SO I DON'T THINK THAT WHAT
YOU SEE HERE IS ANY BIG RADICAL
DEPARTURE. SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED DEBATED TO
EXAMINE PUBLIC HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT. THE WHOLE YEAR. AND
I DON'T THINK THAT I THINK IT'S
IT FITS WITHIN THE PRACTICE OF
OUR WORK AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
FIND THAT IT AS A WHOLE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. PROVIDES THE
PROPER LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR MORE
LIKE CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT CENTER I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETEEN WHICH WILL REQUIRE
DENNIS TO DISCLOSE BASIC AND
THEN FINDING INFORMATION TO THE
PATIENT'S PRESERVE THE ABILITY
FOR PATIENTS REPORT LICENSEES A
DENTAL BOARD EVEN THE SIGN A
NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT. AND
REQUIRED A DENTIST MUST REVIEW
THEIR PATIENTS MOST RECENTLY
TAKEN X. RAYS TO CONFIRM THE
BONE STRUCTURES UNDERNEATH THE
GUM LINE ARE HEALTHY ENOUGH TO
SUSTAIN ANY TYPE OF ORTHODONTIC
TREATMENT LET'S KEEP IN MIND
YOUR TEETH DON'T JUST FLOAT
THERE THEY HAVE TO BE ANCHORED
IN THE JOB AND THE BONE AND IF
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HEALTH
OF THAT BONE IS. YOU CAN'T
PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE CARE SO
PROVIDING DENTAL CARE TO
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY THE
MOVEMENT OF TEETH WITHOUT THIS
DIAGNOSTIC INFORMATION
INCLUDING REVIEWING X. RAYS AND
I'VE ACTUALLY TOWARD THAT TELL
A DENTAL PROGRAMS. DO YOU CAN
HAVE A POTENTIALLY SERIOUS HARM
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
LYING UNDERNEATH AND THAT
INCLUDES PAIN CRUDE CRACK LOOSE
TEETH GUM RECESSION TO FLOSS
AND I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
THIS IS AN EX EXISTING STANDARD
OF CARE SO IN TERMS OF THIS
BEING AN EXTENSION. ARE OF THE
BOARD. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT. WAS NEARLY PUT IN INTO
THE BOARD RENEWAL. I WOULD LIKE
NOTE THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPEDE
A DENNIS ABILITY TO MAKE
CLINICAL JUDGMENTS IT MERELY
SETS A FLOOR FOR NECESSARY
DIAGNOSTIC INFORMATION THAT WE
EXPECT DENNIS TO REVIEW PRIOR
TO DIAGNOSTIC DOSING IN
TREATING PATIENTS WITH OR DIE
CARE AGAIN ESTABLISHING YELP
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY ESTABLISHING
MAINTAINING A STANDARD OF CARE
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
CERTAINLY SUPPORTED BY. WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE NOW TO ME OF THE
MOUTH SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTES
EVEN IT IS TO ENSURE THAT BOTH
AS WE HAVE NEW TECHNOLOGY
TELEHEALTH OF AUDIENCE OR THE
I'M A SUPPORTER OF TELE
DENTISTRY. BUT WE NEED TO.
WHATEVER MODALITY. FOR GETTING
YOUR TEETH TAKEN CARE OF. IT IS
OUR JOB AND THE BOARD JOB THE
DENTAL BOARD TO PROTECT THE
PATIENTS AND BE SURE THEIR
SAFETY IS A PRIORITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THOUGHT.
CONSIDER PAN CABALLERO. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT LET ME
START OFF BY SAYING I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL THIS IS A
SENSE THAT EXTENSION BILL BUT I
HAD THE SAME VISITS THAT MY
GOOD CALLING FROM COSTA MESA
HAD AND THE CONCERN HERE IS
THIS IS THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
PAST OUR RULES REQUIRED THAT IF
YOU WERE GOING TO DO AS SUNSET
EXTENSION THAT IT NOT CONTAIN
ANY POLICY SO THAT WAY WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THE SUN THESE
BOARDS DO NOT SEND SAID AND
THAT THEY ARE APPROPRIATELY
EXTENDED SB AND GIVEN OUR OUR
INTENSE REVIEW THAT WE DO IN
OUR BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
CODE SECTION BUT BUT THE THIS
THE IF THERE IS POLICY IT'S
GOING TO AFFECTED THE BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP THAT THAT BE IN A
DIFFERENT BILL AND I THINK I AM
LIKE I SAID I'M GONNA END UP
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I'M A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE AT THE
VERY LAST MINUTE GETTING THESE
PHONE CALLS AND VISITS FROM
INDIVIDUALS THAT SAY WE HAVEN'T
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
HAVE A ROBUST ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT THESE POLICY ISSUES AND
THEY THEY'RE THEY'RE REQUESTING
A NO VOTE I WILL AND I DO URGE
YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
RETURN TO THE DAYS WHEN WE JUST
AS THE SUN SETS AND DIDN'T WIN
INCLUDE A LOT OF DIFFICULT
POLICY ISSUES YOUR REMEMBER IF
YOU WERE AROUND THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN WAS FACED WITH THAT ISSUE
AND ENDED UP SUNSET IN THE
NURSING BOARD AND IT WAS A BIG
MESS AND I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT BIG MESS AT THE TIME THAT
IT HAPPENED I'M REAL FAMILIAR
WITH HOW DIFFICULT IT IS WENT
ABOARD SUNSETS WE JUST CAN'T
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN AND SO BUT
WITH. ALL DUE RESPECT TO ACT.
WE MAY NEED TO GO BACK TO THE
OTHER WAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SITTING NINE CENTER
GLAZE REMAIN CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THOSE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY IN SALINAS AND CERTAINLY
THE SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
WEIGHING IN WITH THEIR VIEWS.
YOU KNOW IN IN I APPRECIATE THE
IF THE FEEDBACK ABOUT SUNSET
REVIEWS BUT KEEP IN MIND IN IN
THESE HEALTH PROFESSIONS. WE
DON'T LEGISLATE EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENS IN THESE PROFESSIONS WE
RELY UPON THE PROFESSIONALS IN
THOSE FIELDS PROVIDE STANDARDS
OF PRACTICE AND HOW THEY GO
ABOUT THEIR WORK AND WHAT WE DO
ALRP IN MANY CASES IN ALMOST
ALL IN ALL CASES REINFORCE.
THOSE PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COULD THAT THE
STANDARDS OF CARE ARE IN PLACE
AND THAT'S REALLY OUR FOCUS AND
SO WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IN
ALL AREAS OF HEALTH CARE WITH
INNOVATION HAPPENING IS THAT
THERE ARE THOSE WHO I ENGAGE IN
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES IN THAT
RESPECT AND SO WHEN WE COME IN
AND DO THE SAME THING WE DO AND
A LOT OF OUR SENSE THAT'S WHICH
IS IT REINFORCED THE STANDARDS
OF CARE IF. IT DOES CREATE SOME
ANGST IF THEY FEEL LIKE.
THEY'RE STRETCHING. THE MARGIN
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE FITTING. THE STANDARDS
OF CARE. AND SO IN THE IN THE
DENTAL WORLD YOU KNOW. AT THAT
THAT IT YOU YOU KNOW THAT
INNOVATION ITS TEETH TEETH
WHITENING YOU HAVE TO GO INTO A
DENTIST TO GET TEETH WHITENING.
DO YOU HAVE TO GO INTO A
DENTIST TO GET VENEERS. YOU
HAVE TO GO INTO A DENTIST TO
HAVE ALIGNMENTS. AND THE ANSWER
IN ALMOST ALL THESE CASES THERE
YES AND- AND THEN IT DEPENDS.
BUT IN THE IN THE CASE OF
ALIGNMENTS WHERE YOU ARE MOVING
THE BONE OF SOMEONE'S MOUTH.
THE STANDARDS ARE CARE. REQUIRE
THAT YOU HAVE A FULL
EXAMINATION WHICH MAY IN MANY
CASES WILL INCLUDE AN X. RAY.
SO WHEN YOU START TO MESS
AROUND IN TELEHEALTH AN ENEMY
MESS AROUND BUT WHEN YOU START
PRACTICING IN THE FIELD OF
TELEHEALTH. WE ARE NOT YOU
DON'T HAVE SOMEBODY IN YOUR
OFFICE. THEY FORCES THE
STANDARDS OF CARE YOU HAVE TO
BE SURE THAT THEY ARE IN FORCE
THAT THEY ARE. APPLIED
APPROPRIATELY. AND SO WHEN WE
DO SUNSET REVIEW WHEN WE TRY TO
REINFORCE. THOSE COULDN'T THOSE
HEALTH CARE AND WHO WERE
PROTECTIONS. AYE THOSE
COMPANIES THAT MAYBE ENGAGE IN
THAT TYPE OF WORK CAN GET A
LITTLE UNEASY. AND MAYBE NOT
THE IN AND ENGAGED IN OUR WORK
AS THEY SHOULD BE BUT- IT
HAPPENS. AND IN THIS CASE. THE
CONCERN FOR REYES ONLY RECENTLY
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS NOT ONE
BEGAN OUR PROCESS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE SOME. UNEASINESS
ON THE FLOOR CALL THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE. IN CLOSING LET ME
SAY THE OPERATIVE IS YOUR
DENTIST TWICE A YEAR. FOR YOUR.
HEALTH I AM WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER. MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL I PURCHASED BY BRADFORD.
CAPPIELLO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD AYE DORADO GALGIANI.
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO. I JACKSON. I JONES
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL BY MONEY I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE I NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN. AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG ABA CASKEY. WIENER
AYE WILK. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
BRADFORD BY DORADO GALGIANI HI
MORE LOCK. MORE LIKE I. WHY
BECAUSE HE- WILK. FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES YEAH
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TO THIRTEEN. SENATOR
PORTANTINO IS PREPARED AS
ALWAYS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ENACT REALLY IN THE CAL WORKS
THERE PORTANTINO FULLER SHORES
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AB TWO EIGHT THREE
BRINGS THE WELFARE INSTITUTIONS
CODE INTO ALIGNMENT WITH OTHER
PORTIONS OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
REGARDING CHIU AND SEE AN IMAGE
M. IMMUNIZATIONS THE BILL
REMOVES THE DUPLICATE
REQUIREMENT AND FINANCIAL
PENALTIES REGARDING TRUANCY
PLACED ONLY ON FAMILIES THAT
QUALIFY FOR CAL WORKS GRANTS
FURTHER PROVIDES CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WITH THE IN PARTY TO NOT
ENFORCE THE FINANCIAL PENALTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH PRODUCING PRO
FOR MEME IMMUNIZATIONS ALL
FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA'S. SHOULD
FACE THE SAME REQUIREMENTS TO
BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
PENALTIES REGARDING TRUANCY AND
IMMUNIZATIONS CAL WORKS FAMILY
SHOULD NOT BE SINGLED OUT FOR
SEPARATE TREATMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. WHILE I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE OTHER FEATURES
OF THIS BILL I CANNOT OFFER MY
AYE VOTE. DUE TO THE SPECIFIC
ELIMINATION OF THE PERSONAL
BELIEF EXEMPTION FOR
IMMUNIZATIONS. TO ADDRESS THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM THE CAMINO
ALIGNMENT OF THIS BILL WITH SB
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN FROM TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN UNFORTUNATELY
MAKES ME QUESTION THE TRUE
INTENT. OF THIS BILL AND THE
AUTHORS POLITICAL MOTIVATION.
ATTEMPTS TO SUGARCOAT THE FACT
THAT TARGETS A SMALL SUBSET OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE EXEMPT FROM SB
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN. CHILDREN WHO
ARE NOT IN SCHOOL NINE DAY CARE
HOME SCHOOL RE EXEMPT. AS WELL
AS CHILDREN I ET UNDER THE
FEDERAL DISABILITIES ACT. THESE
CHILDREN WILL EXAM FROM SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO BE VACCINATED AND
THE PASSAGE. OF AB TWO EIGHTY
THREE. WILL HOLD GRANTS HOSTAGE
FROM PARENTS ON CAL WORKS THUS
FORCING THEM TO VACCINATE THEIR
CHILDREN AGAINST THEIR WISHES.
IN THE ARMS OF PARENTS TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR CAL WORKS
GRANTS AND WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
IN THE CHILD'S BEST INTERESTS
AS UNETHICAL. THE MORE ON AB
TWO EIGHTY THREE IS A C. I. P.
REQUIREMENTS ARE WILL BE EVEN
MORE REQUIRED VACCINES AND
UNDER SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN.
INCLUDING HEPATITIS A ROTAVIRUS
PNEUMOCOCCAL AN ANNUAL
INFLUENZA IMMUNIZATIONS. BILL
MAY ALSO LIKELY HALT THE CAMP
BLOCK GRANT DUE TO ITS
RELIGIOUS IMPLICATIONS. THE
DIVISION OF HHS OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS HAS CONFIRMED THAT THEY
WILL CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION
OF THIS BILL PASSES WITHOUT A
RELIGIOUS CONSCIOUS BELIEF
EXEMPTION. NOT ONLY ME THIS
TOKEN PIECE OF LEGISLATION COST
CALIFORNIA VITAL TOWNS BLOCK
FROM FUNDING. BILL ALSO
DRAMATICALLY STATE INCREASING
COSTS. THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES OF THE COST
TO TAKE AN ADDITIONAL CAL WORKS
CASE LOAD. WILL BE TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION THEREAFTER PLUS THE ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION ONE TIME
COST OF AUTOMATION TO MAKE THE
PROGRAMMING CHANGES FOR PAYMENT
AND TRACKING PURPOSES FOR THIS
REASON I MUST VOTE NO. ON AB
TWO EIGHTY THREE. THE CENTER
STONE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE CENTER
PORTANTINO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT JUST ONE
RESPONSE IN CLOSE ACCORDING TO
THE AUTHOR THIS BILL MAKES NO
CHANGES TO VACCINE REQUIREMENTS
GIVES THE OPTION TO NOT
FINANCIALLY PENALIZE CAL WORKS
FAMILIES FOR NON COMPLIANT AND
INSTEAD PROVIDES THEM WITH AN
EDUCATIONAL INFORMATION ON
TRANSPORTATION TO HELP WITH
COMPLIANCE AND MET WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES
NOBEL I PORGES. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO BY CHIANG. NO DALLY
NO DODD. I DORADO BY GALGIANI.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO I JACKSON. I JONES
NO LEYVA. TIME ACQUIRE. I
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. HI ATKINS.
YES NO GALGIANI BY RUBIO. HI.
HI IS TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN
MEASURE PASSES MOVIE I DEFY. BY
MOVING MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TO FOURTEEN CENTER MINING IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND ACT REALLY INTO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. CENTER MONEY
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS UNDER EXISTING LAW
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED
TO ALLOW EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES REASONABLE TIME
OFF WITHOUT LOSS OF
COMPENSATION TO PARTICIPATE IN
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS SUCH AS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN
MATTERS BEFORE PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONS THIS IS REFERRED TO
AS RELEASE TIME. ALTHOUGH
CURRENT REGULATIONS PROVIDE
REASONABLE TIME OFF WITHOUT
LOSS OF PAY TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
THE LAW IS INEFFECTIVE IN
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES TO
PARTICIPATE IN EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BECAUSE
CURRENT LAW IS INCONSISTENT
ACROSS DIFFERENT SECTORS. OF
EMPLOYMENT AB THREE FOURTEEN
WOULD UNIFORMLY APPLY A FLOOR
FOR REASONABLE RELEASE TIME
WITHOUT LOSS OF COMPENSATION TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND PROVIDE
CLARITY ON THE SPECIFIC DUTIES
DURING RELEASED TIME TO HELP
BOTH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
MEMBERS I URGE AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
STONE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB THREE
ONE FOUR SUPPORTED BY THE UNION
CAUCUS. THREE ONE FOUR WILL
RESULT IN MAJOR STATE COSTS
LIKELY TO COST MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF
INCLUDING ATTENDANCE AT A NEW
EMPLOYER UNION ORIENTATION AS A
COVERED ACTIVITY ALSO KNOWN AS
RELEASE TIME. RELEASE TIME IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY FOR UNION ACTIVITIES IT
IS QUESTIONABLE WHY TAXPAYERS
SHOULD BE ON THE HOOK FOR
PAYING FOR THESE ACTIVITIES
WHICH IS NOT BENEFIT THE
TAXPAYER AT ALL. WHEN YOU TO
MEMBERS PAY DUES TO THE UNION
TO SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES.
THIS TIME. SHOULD BE EITHER
UNPAID LEAVE DONE OUTSIDE OF
WORK HOURS OR THE UNION SHOULD
REIMBURSE A PUBLIC AGENCY FOR
THE PAY PROVIDED TO THE
EMPLOYEE ON TOP OF ALL THIS AB
THREE ONE FOUR REQUIRES
TAXPAYERS TO PAY THE SALARY OF
A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE. WHILE THEY
ARE PREPARING FOR UNION
MEETINGS BUT DOES NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
PREPARING. THIS IS RIGHT FOR
ABUSE SHOULD THE EMPLOYEE BE
PAID BY THE TAXPAYER WIN HERE
SHE IS SHOWERING AND GETTING
DRESSED FOR A MEETING. BOB
BRUSHING THEIR TEETH OR
SHOPPING FOR NEW CLOTHES TO
WEAR FOR THE MEETING. IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO BE WELL RESTED
PRIOR TO A BIG MEETING PERHAPS
EMPLOYEES SHOULD BE PAID EIGHT
HOURS SLEEP. AND PREPARATION SO
THEIR SHARP FURTHER UNION
RELATED ACTIVITY. AB THREE ONE
FOUR IS JUST ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO
ALLOW UNIONS TO CIRCUMVENT
HAVING TO SPEND THEIR OWN
FUNDS. AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE. I REQUEST A NO VOTE ON
AB THREE ONE FOUR CONTRARY TO
THE UNION CAUCUSES VOTE YES ON
AB THREE ONE FOUR. THANK YOU
CENTER STONE IN ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THING NINE
CENTER MONEY YOU MAY CLOSE.
MEMBERS I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR PREDICTABILITY FAIRNESS IN
THE BEST USE OF TAXPAYER MONEY
TO BUILD STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND
BARGAINING UNITS I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR MINING
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. EIGHT NOBEL HI PORGES
NO BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO.
CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD. I
DORADO AYE AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL.
HUESO HI TACO. JACKSON I HILL
AYE JONES NO LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE
BY MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCKED. NO MORRELL NO NIELSEN.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER I WORK OWSKI. BY
WINNER HI WILK NO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS ALLEN. ATKINS
CABALLERO I GLAZER GROW FOR
TADO GROVE NO TADO. I NIELSEN
NO. HI IS TWENTY SIX KNOWS
ELEVEN MEASURE PASSES CENTER
GROVE FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE I'M CALLING A REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE **** LOUNGE. OKAY
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAVING CALL.
IF ALL OTHER CENTERS COULD STAY
ON THE FLOOR THE ASSISTANT
MAJORITY LEADER WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT
MEMBERS. WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
TAKING UP ITEM TO FIFTEEN WE DO
HAVE A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR SO
WHEN WE DO CALL ROLE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH IT ONCE AND
THEN PLACE IT ON CALL SO IF YOU
MISTER YOU MISSED IT PLEASE NO
SHOUTING OUT. WITH THAT OF FILE
AND TWO FIFTEEN. SENATOR HUESO
ON THE FLOOR BECAUSE HE IS HERE.
THE BOOK WILL GET THIS GOOD
SENATOR SECOND
. THE NEW
AMERICAN LAND SPEED RECORD. ALL
RIGHT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO AND HACK RELATED
TO LAND USE THEIR HUESO THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB ONE ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
THE AGE FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA ACT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT BLANCA RUBIO. AS ALL OF YOU
WEAR THE SHARE OF CALIFORNIA
POPULATION REACHING RETIREMENT
AGE IS GROWING RAPIDLY THIS
RAPID GROWTH WERE RATE
REPRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE TO ACT TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AGING POPULATION
HAS ACCESS TO. LIVABLE AGE
FRIENDLY SERVICES AND CARE AND
RESOURCES. THAT THEY NEED. AND
DESERVE TO LIVE HEALTHY LIVES
THIS BILL WILL CODIFY THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
DEVELOP THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING. AND DIRECT THE SECRETARY
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. TO JOIN A. R.
P.'S NETWORK OF AGE FRIENDLY
STATES AND COMMUNITIES THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEE NOW MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES
BELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD. BY
CABALLERO I CHIANG BY DAILY. NO
DODD. HI DORADO GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG BY HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO. I JACKSON. JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONEY I'M MORE LOCK. RAIL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO I
ROTH BY RUBIO BY SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. NOVEMBER. IOWA
CASKEY I WIENER HI WILK BY.
SENATOR HUESO MOVES THE CALL
NOW MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK
TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN CENTER
SKINNER I SEE THAT SHE IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO A
SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATED TO COLLEGIATE ATHLETICS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SOME VERY PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT BACK FROM
CONCURRENT SB TWO OH SIX. MY
AWARENESS OF THE ISSUE OF
STUDENT ATHLETIC EXPLICATION
REALLY BEGAN BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES WHEN I HEARD A
LECTURE BY PROFESSOR HARRY
EDWARDS WHO REALLY EXPRESSED
THIS AS A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE.
WORDS WAS THE ORGANIZER OF THE
BLACK ATHLETE BOYCOTT OF THE
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT OLYMPICS
HE DESCRIBED COLLEGE SPORTS
RELIANCE ON UNPAID BLACK LABOR
WHICH GENERATED GREAT WELL. FOR
ALL INVOLVED EXCEPT THE
ATHLETES. SINCE THEN THIS VIEW
IS BEEN REINFORCED AGAIN AND
AGAIN BY SOME OF MY FAVORITE
ATHLETES CREMIN ABDUL JABBAR
ANDRE EAGLE DOLLAR DRAYMOND
GREEN AND LEBRON JAMES. BUT
WHAT MAY BE LESS EVIDENCE IS
HOW THE N. C. TWO WAYS RULES
NEGATIVELY IMPACT EACH AND
EVERY STUDENT ATHLETE. THOSE
RULES RIDICULOUS PROHIBIT A
SWIMMER FROM BEING ABLE TO
TEACH SWIMMING LESSONS STOPPED
AT NAPA LEADS HOME GROWN T.
SHIRT BUSINESS AND SANCTION TO
NATALIE TO TRY TO HOLD A
FUNDRAISER FOR THE FAMILY OF A
TEAMMATE WHO HAD DIED IN
PRACTICE. SB REAL COLLEGE
SPORTS MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY AND IT BENEFITS
COLLEGES BROADCAST NETWORKS
CORPORATE SPONSORS THE NC TWO
EIGHT MANY MANY MORE TOP
COLLEGE COACHES MAKE. FORTY
NINE MILLION A YEAR AND IN FACT
IN FORTY OUT OF FIFTY STATES
INCLUDING OUR OWN BE COLLEGE
COACHES ARE AMONG THE HIGHEST
PAID STATE EMPLOYEES THE SAME
HIGHLY PAID COACHES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GET ENDORSEMENT DEALS
AND MAKE EVEN MORE MONEY ON TOP
OF THEIR SALARIES. MEANWHILE
CONTROVERSY TO POP YOUR BILL
POPULAR BELIEF MOST STUDENT
ATHLETES DO NOT GET
SCHOLARSHIPS YES THE ELITE
STUDENT ATHLETES THAT WE- READ
ABOUT WATCH ALL THE TIME. YES
THEY GET A SCHOLARSHIP DOES IT
COVER ALL OF THEIR AND THEIR
FAMILIES COSTS NO BUT MOST
OTHER STUDENT ATHLETES
ESPECIALLY WOMEN IN THOSE IN
LOWER TIER SPORTS THEY DO NOT
GET SCHOLARSHIPS AND IN
COMMITTEE WE HEARD FROM.
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST. HEARING
TO FARO A REPORT AT CAL. OUT
HOW SHE OPTED NOT TO EXERCISE
HER OLYMPIC RIGHTS WHERE SHE
WOULD HAVE CONTROL OF HER OWN
NAME IMAGINE LIKENESS TO GET
SPONSORSHIPS AND ENDORSEMENTS
BECAUSE BY DOING SO SHE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO QUIT GROWING FOR
CAL AND IF SHE QUIT GROWING FOR
CAL. SHE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PRACTICE EVERY DAY AND NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE EQUIPMENT AND
SUCH AND SHE COULDN'T ENSURE
THAT ENDORSEMENT DEAL SHE GOT
WOULD COVER THE TYPE ACOSTA
CHEE WOULD INCUR. TO KEEP UP
WITH HER SUPPORT. STANFORD TOPS
VOLLEYBALL PLAYER HOLLY HE LEE
HODSON EXPRESSED THAT. FOR
WOMEN ATHLETES WHO BASICALLY
HAVE NO ABILITY TO GO PRO
BECAUSE WE DON'T SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN ATHLETES THE
COLLEGE MAY BE THE ONLY TIME
THAT SHE COULD MONETIZE AT ALL.
THE SKILL AND HER ATHLETIC
PROWESS BUT THE NC TO A RULES
PREVENT HER AS WELL AS EVERY
COLLEGE ATHLETE MIND YOU EXCEPT
FOR I BELIEVE TENNIS PLAYERS
CAN TAKE HOME WHAT'S YEAR TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR PURSE BUT LET'S
SET THAT ASIDE EVERY OTHER
COLLEGE ATHLETE. CANNOT USE THE
SKILL THE THING THAT'S THEIR
FAMILY AND THEM HAVE SPORTS SO
MUCH HARD WORK AND TIME INTO TO
EARN ANY INCOME. SB TWO OH SIX
SIX IS THIS SB TWO OH SIX WILL
GIVE OUR- STUDENT ATHLETES TO
GO TO COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA THE
SAME RIGHTS THAT OLYMPIC
ATHLETES HAVE WHICH IS THE
RIGHT TO THEIR NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS. SB TWO OH SIX DOES
NOT REQUIRE OUR COLLEGES TO PAY
THE THINGS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN IN
SOME SOCIAL MEDIA. IS
INACCURATE COLLEGES DO NOT HAVE
TO PAY THE ATHLETES AND IN FACT
SOME ATHLETES MAY NOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS SO EVERY
ATHLETE IS NOT GUARANTEED ANY
MONEY UNDER SB TWO OH SIX ONLY
THOSE THAT CHOOSE TO. USE THEIR
ENTREPRENEURIAL SKILLS TO
MONETIZE THEIR TALENT. AND YES
WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THE RIGHT
TO RESTORE THESE RIGHT STORE
STUDENT ATHLETES BECAUSE UNDER
OUR EXISTING STATE LAW THIS IS
A RIGHT. EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US HALF EVERY OTHER STUDENT HAS
IN EVERY CALIFORNIAN HOUSE AND
THE ONLY REASON THAT OUR
STUDENT ATHLETES DO NOT HAVE
THAT RIGHT IS BECAUSE THEY SIGN
A WAIVER TO THE NC TWO EIGHT
GIVING IT UP. SO BY THE END TWO
ETS PHONE BY LAW AS IT STATES
THAT STUDENT ATHLETES MUST BE
TREATED COMPARABLY TO ALL OTHER
STUDENTS IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN THIS IS A RIGHT THEY
SHOULD HAVE. THEIR HANDS THE NC
TO A BY LAWS INDICATE THAT THE
NC TO A WILL FOLLOW STATE LAW.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE HAD MANY
LEGAL OPINIONS THAT THE NC TWO
EIGHT CANNOT RETALIATE AGAINST
CALIFORNIA THAT TO DO SO. WOULD
BE A VIOLATION OF ANTI TRUST WE
CAN AND SHOULD PASS SB TWO OH
SIX. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'M
HONORED TO JOIN ON MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BERKELEY OBSTACLE AUTHOR
OF SB TOOL SIX AND THAT'S
CLEARLY STATED IS TRULY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF TODAY THE
STUDENT ATHLETES HAVE BEEN
TREATED LIKE CATTLE FOR YEARS
THEIR WORKERS DESPITE BEING
ATHLETES THEY ARE WORKERS AND I
SHOULD SAY TO SUB SPITE MEANS
STUDENTS. THEIR WORKERS EARNING
MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS FOR
UNIVERSITIES ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY'RE NOT BEING
ABLE TO BENEFIT OFFER THEIR
NAME IMAGE OR LIKENESS AND AS
STATED THERE NOW COLLEGE
COACHES MAKING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BEING ABLE TO MONETIZE
THEIR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
AND MANY TIMES A UNIVERSITIES
REPUTATION IS. BASED MORE SO ON
ITS ATHLETIC. PROWESS STAND ON
IT'S ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. IN
MANY CASES SO THIS HELPS BUILD
A LORE AND ATTENTION AND
RECRUITMENT FOR OTHER STUDENTS
WHO WANT TO COME TO THE
UNIVERSITIES AT FIND THEMSELVES.
ACHIEVING GREAT ACADEMIC MEAN
ATHLETIC CHAMPIONSHIPS. ARE IT
WAS NOT UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN THAT THE NCAA DID AWAY
WITH THE LIMITS ON FOOD IT WAS
NOT UNTIL A CONNECTICUT
BASKETBALL STAR SHOULD BOGGS
NAY PEER WHOSE PLANE IN THE IN
SITU ACE FINAL FOR. ANY STATED
MANY NIGHTS I GO TO BED HUNGRY
SO MANY TIMES JUST BECAUSE A
ATHLETE HAS A SCHOLARSHIP DOES
IT MEAN THAT ALL OF THEIR NEEDS
ARE TAKEN CARE OF A JOB THE
SURVIVING COLLEGE TODAY
REQUIRES MORE THAN TUITION AND
BOOKS AND BOARD SO. MANY HAVE
EVEN COMPLAINED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WHEN THEY A KID FROM THE
WEST COAST GO BACK KEYS THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE A OVER COAT TO
WEAR SO THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
IT'S ABOUT FAIRNESS. AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. AS I STATED THIS IS A
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE DESPITE FROM THE
FOLKS WHO WERE IN THIS BUILDING
THIS WEEK. COMPLAIN ABOUT CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUES THIS IS A REAL
ONE THAT WE CAN ALL GET ON
BOARD CONSERVE OUR PLANET PORT
THAT YOU LOVE COULD NOT BE A
SENTENCE THAT REQUIRES YOU TO
RELINQUISH THIS FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT. HERE EARNING INCOME OUR
STANDARD BEARER OF AMATEURISM
IS OUR OLYMPIC ATHLETES AND NAY
TODAY OR ALLOW THE MONETIZE.
THEIR NAME LIKENESS IN IMAGE
AND I THINK THESE ATHLETES
SHOULD BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
AGAIN LESS THAN 3% OF THESE
ATHLETES MAKE UP ARE YOU COULD
SAY. 3% STUDENT POPULAR BUT
THESE AFTER AMERICAN ATHLETES
MAKE UP OVER 50% OF OUR
FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL TEAM.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND IT'S
TIME THAT WE WRITE THIS
HISTORIC WRONG SB TOOLS SIX IS
THAT FIRST STEP PLEASE JOIN
LEBRON JAMES KEVIN DURANT AND
MANY OTHER ALL WELL KNOWN
ATHLETES IN SUPPORTING SB TWO
OH SIX I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY I THINK WE HAD A
BILL ON THE FLOOR THE OTHER DAY
TALKING ABOUT ALLOWING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO VOTE BEING GAVE CIVIC
LEE I WAS SO IMPRESSED WHEN I
GOT A TEXT FROM A SOPHOMORE
FOOTBALL PLAYER AT LONG BEACH
POLY HIGH SCHOOL AUSTIN
GRIFFIN. WHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MY ALAMEDA SAID THE FOLLOWING
THE HE WANTED TO EXPRESS HIS
SUPPORT BECAUSE AS THE ATHLETE
HE KNOWS HOW HARD IT IS TO
PLAYING KEEP YOUR GRADES UP.
AND HE SAID IT WOULD HELP SO
MANY STRUGGLING IN COLLEGE EAT
WHILE THE SCHOOLS MAKE SO MUCH
MONEY AND THAT HE WANTED ME TO
SUPPORT IT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO WEEK KNOWLEDGE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT WE DO THEY
SEE THEMSELVES IN THE LIFE
EXPERIENCE OF THOSE ATHLETES
AND THEY UNDERSTAND THAT EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE ON THE NEWS ON
TV THAT THERE ARE A LEAD
ATHLETES THAT THEY TO
STRUGGLING PLEDGE ANYWAY BUT ME
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND ON. TOP
OF ALL NOW THE CENTER. THANK
YOU SIR MITCHELL CENTER URGES.
THIS I KIND OF WISH THIS ISSUE
EXISTED BACK IN MY COLLEGE DAYS
WHEN I USED TO PLAY TENNIS AND
THIS WOULD BEEN TERRIBLY
CONVENIENT BUT I REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO POSE A QUESTION IF I
CAN'T TO THE FLOOR MANAGER JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION. WELL
ACTUALLY THE AUTHOR BUT YET
WITH THE AUTHOR EXCUSE ARE ARE
YOU RULING DID I'M WILLING TO
YES. OF MY LARGE IS DATED.
THERE USED TO BE A TIME WHEN.
TO GET INTO THE OLYMPICS YOU
HAD TO BE AN AMATEUR AND THE
DEFINITION OF AMATEURS THAT YOU
DID NOT PROFIT FROM THE THAT
THE SPORT ITSELF THAT'S CHANGED
A LITTLE BIT BUT IS THAT STILL
THE RULE. THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF.
NO IT IS NO LONGER OLIMPIC
ATHLETES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
THEIR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
TAKE IT INTO THE OLYMPICS TO
QUALIFY. NO OKAY IS NO LONGER.
WHAT IS STILL A QUALIFICATION
THOUGH HOWEVER. IF YOU'RE IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH IS NOT
A DIVISION ONE OR TWO SPORTS SO
THAT'S NOT UNDER IN C. TO A
RULES. AND LET'S SAY. YOU YOU
WERE THE STAR PLAYER YOUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND YOU
MONETIZE YOUR YOUTUBE VIDEOS
YOU WERE YOU KNOW SO FOLLOWED
IN YUMA YOU WOULD THEN BE
EXCLUDED. FROM PARTICIPATING IN
A DIVISION ONE OR TWO COLLEGE
SPORT ACTIVITY BECAUSE YOU HAD
DONE THAT PRIOR. SO THERE IS
FOR EXAMPLE A YOUNG WOMAN IN
CALIFORNIA SHE'S IN. MIDDLE NOT
MIDDLE SCHOOL BUT BREAKING FOR
HIGH SCHOOL SHE'S A BRILLIANT
SOCCER PLAYER AND SHE IS SO
FOLLOWED WORLDWIDE. AARON'S
OPTED FOR HER NOT TO GO TO
COLLEGE AS A SOCCER PLAYER TO
BEGIN TO TAKE ENDORSEMENTS NOW
BECAUSE THEY KNEW EVEN AS AN
EIGHTH GRADER IF SHE TOOK
INDOORS MEN'S THAT YOU WOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM BEING ABLE TO BE.
ON A COLLEGE TEAM. CRAZY I'M
TOWARD ON THIS BECAUSE ONE I
THINK THIS IS A CONTRACT RIGHT.
THAT IS AT ISSUE HERE FOR
SOMEONE TO BE TOLD THAT THEY
CANNOT HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR
LIKENESS. IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR THERE COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY EXPERIENCE JUST
DOESN'T SEEM FAIR WHEN EVERYONE
ELSE SO IT'S ALMOST LIKE A
CONTRACT RIGHT. IN THAT'S BUT
MY ON THE FLIP SIDE I'M
WONDERING. ARE WE CONCERNED AT
ALL IN DURING THE COURSE OF
DRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION WERE
YOU CONCERNED AT ALL THAT. THE
INDUSTRIES AND ALL THE RELATED
DOLLARS THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY
THIS IS GOING TO UNDERMINE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE SCHOLASTIC
EXPERIENCE THE EMPHASIS ON.
UNIVERSITIES ACTUALLY BEING
SCHOLASTICALLY ORIENTED BECAUSE
IT IT'S GONE SO FAR THE OTHER
DIRECTION THAT. I'VE I FEEL
WE'VE BEEN LOSING THAT WE'VE
BEEN LOSING THAT SCHOLASTIC
EXPERIENCE FOR THE SAKE OF THE
DOLLARS THAT COME ALONG WITH
THE- WITH THAT WITH THE RIGHT
WITH THAT'S LETTER DASH THROUGH
THE CHAIR. CENTER SKINNER YOU
THANK YOU RECENTLY I'M- HEY ONE
COULD ALWAYS DEBATE THAT BUT
CERTAINLY NOW THERE'S NO
PROHIBITION ON ANY OTHER
STUDENTS TO BEING
ENTREPRENEURIAL IF WE LOOK AT
MARK ZUCKERBERG HE STARTED
FACEBOOK AS A COLLEGE STUDENT
NOW HE DIDN'T FULLY MONETIZE
ITALY AFTER YOU LEFT COLLEGE
BUT HAD HE BEEN ABLE TO THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN NO PROHIBITION.
AND I BELIEVE HE WAS A COMPUTER
SCIENCE MAJOR SO HE COULD HAVE
USED HIS A SKILL THAT A SKILL
HE FURTHERED AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT MONETIZED AND OF NO
PROBLEM SO. ARE WE DON'T APPLY
THAT STANDARD TO ANY OTHER
STUDENT ADDITIONALLY WITH IN IF
WE LOOK AT THE COLLEGE SPORTS
INDUSTRY. THERE IS. CORRUPTION
BECAUSE WE DON'T ALLOW THIS
INSTEAD THERE IS UNDER HE
TABLE HEY OUT EITHER BY COLLEGE
COACHES DIRECTLY TO PLAYERS OR
TO OTHERS THEN THE FBI
INVESTIGATES AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS THE PLAYER THEMSELVES
SUFFERS THE PLAYER THEMSELVES
IS THEN EXCLUDED FROM THE
SPORT. IF WE DO THIS IF WE. ALL
THIS ABOVE GROUND AND GIVE THE
STUDENT THE RIGHT WE WILL AVOID
THAT ADDITIONALLY YOU HAVE
SITUATIONS LIKE DIANE
WILLIAMSON WHO. QUIT SCHOOL DID
NOT FINISH SCHOOL BECAUSE IT
WHERE THERE WAS NO LUCRATIVE
REASON TO STAY IN SCHOOL
PERHAPS SOME ATHLETES WOULD
FINISH THEIR COLLEGE DEGREE
BEFORE THEY WENT PRO IF WE
ALLOWED THIS. ARE ALL WELL IN
MY COMMENTS HERE MISTER
PRESIDENT. THIS WAS IT IS A
VERY TOUGH ISSUE. SEE HOW THIS
PLAYS OUT I WILL BE SUPPORTIVE
I'D LIKE TO SEE HOW THIS PLAYS
OUT IN THE NEXT THREE TO FIVE
YEARS. IF IT DOES CHANGE THE
CULTURE. THANK YOU SIR BOARD
JUST SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE I HAVE. OF SOMEONE VERY
DEAR TO ME WHO PLAYED ON THE
USC FOOTBALL TEAM MY OLDEST SON
BOBBY ARCHULETA AND HE PLAYED
WITH BROAD THE PETE AND THEY
SHARED BLOCKER SIDE BY SIDE SO
I'M VERY PROUD OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENT ANY WORSE IS
ROSE BOWL RING VERY PROUDLY AS
A U. S. C. TROJANS. AND HE TOLD
ME STORIES THAT WAY BACK WHEN
HOW SOME OF THE KIDS ON THAT
FOOTBALL TEAM HAD TO ASK OTHER
KIDS WITHIN THE STUDENT BODY
FOR EXTRA DIMES NICKELS A
COUPLE DOLLARS HERE AND THERE
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT AFFORD
THAT LUNCH THAT WAS NEEDED AT
THE OUTSIDE CAFETERIA. THAT THE
FACT THAT IF THEIR AUTOMOBILE
BROKE DOWN THEY COULDN'T TAKE
CARE OF IT BY ASKING SOMEONE
ELSE PICK THAT WOULD BE A
VIOLATION OF THE NCAA RULING.
AND SO THIS IS EXPLOITATION AT
ITS FULLEST AND I THINK THAT
NOW THAT THE CITY CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN RECOGNIZED ACROSS THE
NATION EVERYONE IS SAYING OH MY
GOD WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS CALIFORNIA
DOING WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING MAKING SURE THAT THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN ARE TAKEN
CARE OF AND IT'S A DEADLY
SENATORS. NOT EVERY SINGLE
ATHLETE IS GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS BECAUSE OF THE FACT IT
HAS TO DO WITH THEIR ABILITIES
AND THEIR STATUS TO BE THE
FIRST PART BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE
BUT HOPE WE THEY'LL STE THE
WELL TWO POINT THAT KIDS WILL
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE NOT ONLY THE
EDUCATION BUT THE NOURISHMENT
THAT THEY NEED EVERY SINGLE BIT
COMPETE. SO I'M THINKING THAT
CALIFORNIA BEN IS LEAVE THE WAY
AND LET'S GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
DOORS IT'S KIDS THAT NEED OUR
HELP THANK YOU. TONIGHT URGENT
BY BOAT THANK YOU SAID ARE
SHOULD LET US CENTER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
CAME TO THE- FLOOR TODAY PRETTY
SURE OF MY OPPOSITION THIS BILL
BUT THE DEBATE HAS CAUSE ME TO
READ MY SHIN. I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE AUTHOR QUESTION FOR
CLARIFICATION. ONE PARTICULAR
ISSUE PLEASE. YOU WILL YOU TAKE
A CORTES INTERJECT QUICKLY NC
DOUBLE A AS I UNDERSTAND IT HAS
WRITTEN A LETTER TO THE
LEGISLATURE. I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S A TH IF YOU WOULD
CHARACTERIZE IT AS A THREAT TO
HER. POLICY POSITION ON THERE
OR OF A POSITION ON THEIR END
IT. IF THIS DOES PASS THAT THEY
WILL NOT ALOW CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN
POSTSEASON. NC DOUBLE A
TOURNAMENT'S. WHICH IS REALLY
THE SOURCE OF MY- OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL BUT WHAT CAUSES ME TO
ASK THE QUESTION AND- CAN
BECOME MORE OPEN MINDED TO HIS
FORBES DID A VERY GOOD ARTICLE
ON IT LAST WEEK. AND HAD
PRESENTED SOME PRETTY GOOD
INFORMATION BUT I WOULD SINCE I
WASN'T A PART OF THE HEARINGS.
OR THAT LETTER I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR OF
POSSIBLE ON THAT PLEASE. THANK
YOU SO THIS QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE NC TWO EIGHT CAN MAKE GOOD
ON THE THREATS THAT THEY ARE
MAKING. Z. MANY LAWYERS
INCLUDING ONE A LAWYER WHO
WROTE IN A FORBES ARTICLE. AND
WE HAVE NUMEROUS OTHER LAWYERS
WHO'VE NOW OPINED EITHER IN A
FORBES ARTICLE IN THERE'S AN
ONLINE PUBLICATION CALLED THE
ATHLETE OR THE ATHLETIC THERE'S
A NUMBER OF OTHERS DIFFERENT
LAWYERS ALL HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS BILL AND OF ALL EXPRESSED
THE OPINION THAT. IF THE NC TWO
EIGHT TRIES. ON THEIR THREAT.
THAT WERE FIRST THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BECAUSE-
IT IS AN ANTITRUST VIOLATION
THAT IS THE LEGAL OPINION. AND
IF WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
THE LAWSUITS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN AGAINST THE NC TWO WAY ON
THE THEORY OF VIOLATION OF ANTI
TRUST. THEIR RECORD WELL LET'S
SEE THE RECORD OF WINNING IS
PRETTY LOW THEY HAVE LOST
ALMOST EVERY LAWSUIT BROUGHT
AGAINST THEM IN A QUESTION OF
ANTI TRUST. SO THE LEGAL
OPINIONS THAT BOTH WE HAVE
REQUESTED AND THAT AVE JUST
VOLUNTARILY BEEN EXPRESSING
THEMSELVES WITHIN THE PRESS ARE
ALL THAT THE AND SEE TO IT THAT
THIS IS A HOLLOW THREAT. THAT
THIS IS TO SCARE US NOTICE THAT
THE NCAA DID NOT SAY THEY
WOULD. HIT COLLEGE. CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES FROM PARTICIPATING AT
ALL RIGHT THEY WIN AT THE HEART
OF THE THING IF I'M A STUDENT
pATHLETE WHAT TWENTY MOST WANT.
THE CHAMPIONSHIPS THE PLAYOFFS
SO OF COURSE THAT IS THE MOST
PERMITTED BOTH THREAT. BUT I
THINK IT'S A HOLLOW THREAT
THANK YOU BACK AMOUNT TIMES A
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MISS CAN
APPRECIATE AND A VERY GOOD
EXPLANATION. I WILL IT. THE
VOLTS TO THE BODY HERE THAT I
DID HAVE A VERY POWERFUL
LOBBYISTS CONTACT ME ON THIS
BILL. MY YOUNGEST SON. WHO
PLAYS A COLLEGE VOLLEYBALL AND
SO I HE'S I DON'T I MEAN
HOPEFULLY SOME DAY HE'S IN THE
ARENA OF BEING A- QUALIFIED FOR
THIS I DON'T THINK HE IS RIGHT
NOW BUT HE'S GOT OVER WORK TO
DO. BUT HOPEFULLY IS LISTENING.
I APPRECIATE TO SEND ARSENAL AT
HIS COMMENTS ON THIS AS WELL
THAT. AND BASED ON THOSE YEAH
I'M GONNA VOTE I TODAY AND KIND
OF SEE HOW THOSE AND LET'S SEE
HOW THIS WORKS OUT I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR THIS KIND OF CHANGE I
THINK THAT. A LOT OF THE POINTS
HAVE BEEN POIGNANT TODAY AND SO
WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING SB
TWO OH SIX THANK YOU CENTER
JONES SENATOR DALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS REAL
QUICK I JUST WANNA SAY LOOK
THIS IS BIG BUSINESS. THESE
COLLEGES ARE MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY OFF OF THE STUDENTS AT
THEIR PERIL. SO IF YOU'RE ON
OUR SIDE ALLEN YOU YOU TECH
ABOUT FREE ENTERPRISE WHY NOT
ALLOW THEM TO HOW MANY OF THEM
ARE IT IT'S A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO. SOME OF THEM DON'T EVER
MAKE IT TO THE PROS AND THEY
GET HURT. AND THEY MISSED OUT
ON THAT OPPORTUNITY TO MAYBE
GET SOME RESOURCES ALONG THE
WAY I THINK THIS IS A OF YOU
KNOW FREEDOM OF ENTERPRISES
THIS IS A NO BRAINER FOR ME.
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND HOPE THAT THEY GET TO USE
IT AND THEY YOU KNOW MAKE SOME
RESOURCES AND GROW THEIR
BUSINESS THAT'S THEIR BUSINESS
I LOOK AT THIS A GOODBUSINESS
BUSINESS DECISION. AND NOW I
THINK WE ALL SHOULD SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR DALLY.
BETTER MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT JUST ONE
LAST POINT IT HIT ME AS I
LISTEN TO LAST WEEK YOU KNOW
THIS IS ALSO A GENDER PARITY
ISSUE. I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL
WITH THE MILLERS. IN RIVERSIDE
SHERILYN REGGIE. AND YOU KNOW
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS LOVE
YOU READ YOU SURE I WAS A
BETTER BALL PLAYER IN HIGH
SCHOOL. BUT THE WNBA DIDN'T
EXIST THEN IN THE WOMEN IN THE
WNBA DON'T MAKE. ANY DON'T MAKE
A DIME ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED
TO THAT MAN IN THE NBA. ALSO
CHERYL IN COLLEGE AT USC HAD
BEEN ABLE TO DO THIS. SHE WOULD
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM HER INNATE
AMAZING GOD GIVEN TALENT. HER
BROTHER DID HAD A FULL CAREER
IN THE NBA AND CHERYL WAS NOT
ABLE TO DO THIS SO THIS IS ALSO
A GENDER PARITY ISSUE. FOR
WOMEN ATHLETES AT THE
COLLEGIATE LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO.
ON BENEFIT FINANCIALLY WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS. TO GO ON INTO
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETICS ANOTHER
REASON TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR
MITCHELL STONE WELCOME. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF DEBATES
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE. CORDIAL
FOUGHT FULL WITH GOOD
BACKGROUNDS AND TRY TO. REACH A
CONSENSUS. YOU KNOW I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THEIR PRIMARY
PURPOSE IS TO EDUCATE OUR KIDS
WE NEED TO HAVE A GREAT
EDUCATED WORK FORCE IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR GOING TO COMPETE
GLOBALLY. BUT I AM REMINDED OF
A STORY AS I'M AS I'M SITTING
HERE IN HER TESTIMONY VOTED NO
ON THIS ONE ORIGINALLY CAME
BEFORE US. AND I HEARD OF A
STORY ABOUT A YOUNG MAN THAT.
WAS PLAYING FOOTBALL AND- HE
GOT OFFERED A PRETTY A PRETTY
NICE CHECK. TO GO RIGHT AWAY
BEFORE HE GRADUATED FROM
COLLEGE TO GO TO A PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL TEAM. AND HIS MOTHER
SAID NO YOU'RE GOING TO FINISH
YOUR SCHOOL. BEFORE YOU GO ON
TO THE PROS. AND ENDED UP
GETTING A HORRIFIC INJURY. THAT
COMPLETELY DECIMATED HIS
FOOTBALL CAREER. SO I'M LOOKING
AT THIS FROM A DIFFERENT ANGLE
NOW I'M THINKING THAT MAYBE IF
WE ALLOW SOME OF THESE ATHLETES
ARE REALLY HAVE STRONG PROMISE
TO BECOME PROFESSIONALS. MAYBE
WITH SOME OF THE INCOME THAT
THEY CAN GET DURING THEIR
FORMIDABLE YEARS IN COLLEGE
THAT THEY WILL SEE THE BENEFITS
OF COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME. CAN IN
THE FINANCIAL COMPENSATION AND
THEY NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
MAYBE EVEN DO VERY WELL WITH
THEIR TALENTS. BUT LASTLY I
HAVE TO TELL YOU. I'M VERY
PROUD OF MY DAUGHTER I HAVE A
DAUGHTER ONE DAUGHTER THREE
SONS AND. MY DAUGHTER CAME TO
ME WHEN. SHE WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL AND SHE WAS NEVER
INVOLVED IN SCHOLASTIC SPORTS
AT ALL. AND SHE GOES DOWN I'M
GONNA TRY OUT FOR WATER POLO. I
SAID BERNIE THAT'S A FANTASTIC
IDEA I THINK YOU SHOULD DO THAT
IT'S A GREAT SPORT. BUT SHE
CALLED ME BACK AND SHE GOES. I
REALLY DON'T THINK THIS IS FOR
ME THAT I THINK I'M GOING TO
QUIT I SAID. DON'T DON'T QUIT
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT SHE GOES
WELL I THOUGHT THAT. WATER POLO
WAS VOLLEY BALL IN THE WATER. I
SAID NO IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
PHYSICAL THAN THAT BUT YOU
SIGNED UP FOR IT. AND YOU NEED
TO STAY IN THE SPORT. REASON
WHY I MENTION THIS IS BECAUSE
SHE DID VERY WELL IN WATER POLO
IN THE FOUR YEARS THAT SHE WAS
AT LEAST SO VEHICLE. HIGH
SCHOOL. AND THEN SHE APPLIED TO
GO TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO. AND SHE
WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT
HER VERY HIGH GPA WASN'T FOUR
POINT OH FIVE AND SHE DIDN'T
THINK THAT SHE WAS GOING TO GET
IN. BUT OUR COACH SAID HEY YOU
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT PLAYING
WATER POLO. AND SHE GOES NO
SHOES GO TALK TO THE COACH. SO
SHE WENT TO THE COACH AND THE
COACH DOESN'T WANT TO HER ON
MONDAY MORNING COMING YOUR
BREATHING SUIT. WE WERE TO GO
ON THE WATER SEVEN THIRTY THE
MORNING MY DAUGHTER SHOWS UP.
HE THROWS THE BALL. THE COACHES
THREW THE BALL IN THE NET. MY
DAUGHTER IS A SOUTH PAW A LEFTY
SHE TAKES THE BALL SHE THROWS A
THAN THAT HE THROWS OR ANOTHER
BALL SHE THROWS IT INTO THE NET
HE THROWS ANOTHER VOICE SHOWS
THE NET AGAIN. BECAUSE GET OUT.
HE GOES COULD YOU BE HERE
MONDAY MORNING A STARK HE GOES
WELL I HAVEN'T BEEN ADMITTED TO
THE COLLEGE CHAU SIR HE SAYS
ONE ALLOWED TO ACCEPT ONE
STUDENT PER YEAR. AND I'M
ACCEPTING YOU. SHE PLAYED ALL
FOUR YEARS AT UCSC. AND LET ME
TELL YOU IT WAS A STRUGGLE. I
MEAN SHE'S FORTUNATE SHE HAD A
BAD THE COULD AFFORD TO PUT HER
THROUGH SCHOOL. BUT SHE HAD A
LOT OF COLLEAGUES THAT WERE
PLAYING WATER POLO. THERE
REALLY STRUGGLED TO MAKE IT
THROUGH. AND SO THE TESTIMONY
THAT I'VE HEARD HERE TODAY. HI
IS CHANGING MY MIND ON THIS
VOTE. AND AGAIN CALIFORNIA
SOMETIMES JUST HAS TO LEAD THE
WAY. AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE I THINK WE
NEED TO BLAZE A TRAIL. FOR
THOSE REASONS I'M GONNA SUPPORT
SB TO A SIX. THANK YOU CENTER
STONE CENTER NIELSEN. MISTER
PRESIDENT LEADING DOWN THE
SENATE THIS IS KIND OF A RARE
EXPERIENCE FOR ME BECAUSE I'VE
ALWAYS SAID VERY SELDOM DO THIS
DEBATE ON THE FOREVER CHANGE
ANY MINDS. EVEN MY OWN. I CAME
HERE TODAY QUITE OPPOSED TO
THIS LEGISLATION. AND I THINK
WE HAD IT ONCE BEFORE BEFORE
XIN I DID VOTE NO. THAT ARE
LISTENING TO THE DEBATE I
REALIZED SOMETHING. NOW I WAS A
SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETE BUT I WAS
NEVER ANYBODY GOING TO PAY ME
FOR ANYTHING AT ALL. TO ENDORSE.
BUT WHAT I GAINED FROM
ATHLETICS. TO THE KIND OF HUMAN
BEING THAT I AM. HAS MADE SUCH
A DIFFERENCE IN MY LIFE SUCCESS.
I HAVE IN MY OFFICE COUPLE
FOOTBALLS IN MY COLLEGE SHOT
PUT AND DISCUS AND A SIGN IN
FRONT OF A THAT SAYS HEAVY
LIFTING. AND HEAVY LIFTING THEN
WAS BEING IN SHAPE FOR SPORTS
NIGHT AND COMPETED IN TRACK A
LITTLE BIT AS A MASTER LATER.
AND FOOTBALL AND WORKING ON THE
FARM THAT WAS A HEAVY LIFTING.
BUT NOW THE HEAVY LIFTING IS
ALL THESE THINGS THAT WE DO
HERE. AND THE GREATEST THING I
LEARNED IN ATHLETICS WAS
DISAPPOINTING. WELL WHAT OF
THAT THAT KIND OF PUT IT IN
CONTEXT HERE FOR ME TODAY.
BECAUSE I WAS ENVISIONING THESE
LEGIONS OF AGENTS. SPORTS
AGENTS DESCENDING OUR
UNIVERSITIES. AND THEY'RE NOT
ALL THE MOST ETHICAL PEOPLE.
BUT THE POINT THAT I MAKE. THE
GOOD ATHLETES. OR ANYONE WHO
EVEN COMPETES IN ATHLETICS EVEN.
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL WHATEVER. IT
DOES SOMETHING POSITIVE I
BELIEVE TO THE HUMAN BEING THE
HUMAN CHARACTER IN THE HUMAN
SOUL. AND SO IF SOMEONE IT IS
SO GOOD. THE DAVID DEVELOPED AN
ECONOMIC PRESENCE AND POTENTIAL.
BUT MAYBE IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND NOW RATHER THAN BEING A
VERY STRONG NO VOTE. I TO WILL
BE AND I WILL. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN. CENTER JACKSON YES I
FEEL COMPELLED TO STAND UP BUT
IT IS RESULT OF THE COMMENTS BY
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING A
HISTORY OF MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF RECOGNIZING
RESPECTING STUDENT ATHLETES. AS
A YOUNG WOMAN BELIEVE IT OR NOT
I WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD
TENNIS PLAYER BUT I WAS
INELIGIBLE FOR SCHOLARSHIPS TO
COLLEGE BECAUSE SITTING GIVE
SCHOLARSHIPS TO. GIRLS TO PLAY.
FOURTEEN COLLEGE THAT OF COURSE
IS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY AND AS
A RESULT WE NOW HAVE COLLEGE.
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR WOMEN IN
SPORTS WE HAVE WOMEN WHO ARE
LEADING THE UNITED STATES IN
GOLD MEDALS AT THE OLYMPICS
BECAUSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE AND TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
A LIVING AT IT OR CERTAINLY NOT
HAVING TO GO OUT. AND DRIVE IN
UBER IN THE EVENING AFTER THEY
WORK OUT AND TRY VERY HARD TO
EXCEL AND TO AND TO LIVE UP TO
THEIR- ATHLETIC EXPECTATIONS SO
WE'RE SEEING MOVEMENT IN THAT
DIRECTION. AND I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
TALENT CANNOT DO IT ON THEIR
OWN. I ALSO HAVE A GRANDSON WHO
IS SIX FOOT SEVEN AND IS. FOR
GORE DEPENDING AT A UNIVERSITY
AND WE WENT TO THE NC TO ACE
LAST YEAR IS A STARTING PLAYER
HE HAS A FOUR YEAR SCHOLARSHIP
TO COLLEGE. BUT THAT ISN'T
ENOUGH. WE END UP HAVING TO
SEND THE MONEY EVERY NOW AND
THEN HE WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE FOR
YOUR BIRTHDAY WELL. THERE'S A
LITTLE HAMBURGER STORE AROUND
THE CORNER I COULD SURE USE
SOME MONEY. BECAUSE I REALLY
LIKE THOSE BURGERS AFTER A FOUR
HOUR WORK OUT WHEN I'VE LOST
FIVE TO TEN POUNDS. NOT
COMPLAINING. BUT THIS IS THE
REALITY THIS IS THIS IS THE
KIND OF THING WE NEED TO
REINFORCE AND SUPPORT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE ACHIEVING
EXCELLENCE. WHO ARE JUST TRYING
TO GO THROUGH COLLEGE AND I
WILL TELL YOU BEING AN ATHLETE
AND A STUDENTATHLETE AND DOING
WELL IN SCHOOL AND DOING BOTH
IS NOT AN EASY TASK. THE NOTION
THAT THEY COULD DâN WE
ACTUALLY WOULD GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY Là. WHILE IN
SCHOOL I IS NOT AN
EXTRAORDINARY REACH AND BE FOR
THOSE THREES THE FACT THAT.
WHEN YOU SAW. AFTER THE WINTER.
I'LL BE ABLE TO GET SOME MONEY
AS THEY DO. THEIR WORK AND AS
STATED SHE THOSE EXCELLENT
GOAL. NOW ALL BEING THIS UP I
WOULD SUBMIT. THAT IF THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY DOESN'T FOLLOW
SUIT WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
GREAT ATHLETIC TEAMS HERE
BECAUSE A LOT OF THOSE. BOOKS
ARE GONNA WANT TO COME TO
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA SO FOR
THAT IN A NOT A BUNCH OF OTHER
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON. THERE SKINNER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU. IN MY CLOSE
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS NOT
TO INTERFERE WITH THE RIGHT OF
OUR COLLEGE PROGRAMS TO
GENERATE MONEY FOR THEIR
ATHLETICS PROGRAMS IT IS NOT IN
ANY WAY DESIGNED FOR THATIT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE COLLEGES TO
PAY THE ATHLETES AND IN FACT
THE REASON IT'S COMING BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IS BECAUSE THE BILL
WAS AMENDED THE ASSEMBLY. AND
THE AMENDMENT THAT WILL BE
ADDED WHAT IS THAT ANY CONTRACT
ENDORSEMENTS SPONSORSHIP THAT
IN STUDENTS PURSUED COULD NOT
BE IN CONFLICT WITH A CONTRACT
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAD FOR
THEIR SPORTS PROGRAM OR AT TEAM
SO IT JUST WANTED TO. BE CLEAR
AND LAID BACK TO REST AND THEN
TO FINALLY SAY THAT. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE AN ELITE ATHLETE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS WE HAD I
THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
HEALDSBURG BROUGHT TO US ON THE
FLOOR. FOR MONTHS AGO A YOUNG
WOMAN FROM LAKE COUNTY WHO HAD
WON THE CHAMPIONSHIPS STATEWIDE
FOR HIGH SCHOOL IN WRESTLING
AND WAS THE FIRST TIME ANY
ATHLETE FROM LAKE COUNTY HAD
ACCOMPLISHED SUCH A FEAT NOW
ASSUMING THAT SHE WILL STEP
BACK. THAT YOUNG WOMAN IS JUST
THE PRIDE OF LAKE COUNTY YOU
COULD SEE THERE WERE SO MANY
PEOPLE HERE WHEN SHE CAME TO
GET THAT RECOGNITION THEY'RE SO
PROUD OF HER YOU KNOW THAT
THEY'RE IN OUR CAR DEALERSHIPS
ROTARY CLUBS YOU NAME IT THAT
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
SPONSOR HER IF SHE WANTED TO GO
ON TO WRESTLING AT A COLLEGE AN
NC TO A COLLEGE. SHE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO ACCEPT THAT WHEN I
HIGHLY DOUBT I'M SURE THERE'S A
FEW A FEW WOMEN WRESTLERS THAT
GET A SCHOLARSHIP IN COLLEGE
BUT IT'S PRETTY RARE SO IT IS
FOR ATHLETES LIKE HER AND EVERY
OTHER ATHLETE THAT WE SHOULD DO
THIS AND IF I CAN CLOSE AND
REFERENCE OF MY OWN HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE FAVORITE ATHLETE.
THE FORMER UCLA PLAYER KAREEM
ABDUL JABBAR JUST AS WITH EVERY
INJUSTICE WRONGS DON'T GET
RIGHTED UNLESS WE KEEP RAISING
OUR VOICES AGAIN. AND AGAIN
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL AYE
PORGES AYE BRADFORD AYE KELLY
HERO BY CHIANG. I DALY AYE DODD
AYE DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ HI GROW. HERTZBERG
I HILL HI WITH SO. BY TADO I
JACKSON I JONES HI LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MONNING. HI MORE LUCK MORALE.
HI NIELSEN AYE PAN BY
PORTANTINO HI ROB. HI RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE I
AMBERG. I CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK HI BY. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE. BY
MORE LOCK. NUMBER I'M A GUY.
ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS MOVING
BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
TAKING UP ITEM TO TWENTY CENTER
Y. CASKEY ARE YOU PREPARED HE
IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
A SOME OF THOSE SEVEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
AN ACT RELATING TO TAXATION
THERE RIGHT CASKEY MISTER
PRESIDENT AB TWO OR SEVEN TWO
THREE MAKES CHANGES IS AND HOW
THE TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX.
LAW CAP IS CALCULATED FOR
ALAMEDA AND SANTA CLARA AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING A WIDE RANGE OF
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS
SHELTERS FOR HOMELESS FOLKS
POLICE AND FIRE SERVICES THE
CHANGES IN AB SEVEN TWO THREE
WILL GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY AND THE
OPTION TO OBTAIN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE. TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
A GENERAL PURPOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES SUCH AS
ROAD REPAIRS PARK MAINTENANCE
AND HOMELESS PREVENTION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. EIGHTY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
TRANSACTION. SEEING NONE BEFORE
WE HAD MADAM CLERK CALLED THE
ROLL WE DO HAVE MEMBERS OFF THE
FLOOR SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME AND A
PLACE PLACE THE BILL ON CALL SO
WITH THAT. MADISON SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ME CALL
THE MEMBERS. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS AYE BATES. WELL HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG. VALLEY NO DODD. HI
THERE ARE SO. GALGIANI I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO.
FIVE TADO. HI JACKSON. HI JONES.
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK.
MORALE NO NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. I STONE. NO
I'M BURKE I LIKE HUSKY I WIENER.
I WILK NO. CENTER Y. CASKEY
MOVES THE CALL THE MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY ONE SENATOR WIENER ARE
YOU PREPARED. HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I CALL YOU TO RISE 2%
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRE LOCAL AGENCIES TO POST
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ON THEIR
WEBSITES REGARDING THE TYPE AND
AMOUNT OF THESE FEE IMPOSED ON
A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
THE CURRENT AND BOB FIVE
PREVIOUS ANNUAL FEE REPORTS OF
THAT LOCALLY AND SEE AND ANY
APPLICABLE INFORMATION RELATED
TO THE NEXUS OF THOSE FEES OR
ANY COST OF SERVICE RELATED
STUDIES. BY MAKING THIS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE WILL ADD
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
CERTAINTY. TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION PROCESS
THIS YEAR UC BERKELEY'S TURNER
CENTER DELIVERED A REPORT ON
THE FACT THAT RESIDENTIAL
IMPACT FEES HAVE ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. ONE
OF THE REPORTS KEY FINDINGS WAS
THAT DEVELOPMENT THE SCHEDULES
ARE OFTEN UNCLEAR AND DIFFICULT
TO FOLLOW. THE REPORT NOTED
THAT A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
AROUND FEES AND THE NEXUS
STUDIES USED TO JUSTIFY THEM TO
MAKE DEVELOPMENT RISKIER MORE
COSTLY AND ULTIMATELY SERVE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING
THAT GETS BUILT. ON THIS
LEGISLATORS FOR OUR WE'VE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS. AND THIS BILL WILL HELP
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY. PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WE- ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NINE MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL I FOR JUST. I
BRADFORD. I HAVE A FIVE CHIANG.
DALLY I DON. THERE ARE SO.
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO I
WITH SO. I TADO I JACKSON.
JONES NO LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. MONNING. I MORE
LOCK FIVE MORROW. I NIELSEN AYE
PAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER. I STERN. I STONE I
UMBERG I Y. CASTING. I WIENER.
FIVE WILK. FIVE FIVE JONES NOTA
HI. NO NO WE CANNOT WE CANNOT
DO THAT SOUND ORDER. YOU NINE
CONGER SHED LIKE THAT ALL RIGHT
AND SO THE CENTER MOVES THE
CALL NOW MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
BACK TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO.
ONE FORTY TWO
. SORRY MEMBERS
OKAY NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY TWO SENATOR
WIENER ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS
MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AN ACT RELATING TO OIL SPILLS
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS AND
COMPOSED. SORRY CENTER WIENER
IT'S OKAY MISTER PRESIDENT.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS AND COAST
FROM SPILLS OF NON FLOORING
OILED SO WILL THAT WILL SINK TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE WATER WAY.
AND THIS LEGISLATION WILL DO SO
BY BOTH COLLECTING INFORMATION
ON THE MOVEMENT OF NON FLOATING
OILS AND OUR STATE. AS WELL AS
INCORPORATING THE MOST UP TO
DATE SAFETY STANDARDS AND TO
SPILL RESPONSE PLANS. SHIP
SHIPMENTS OF HEAVY CRUDE OILS
SUCH AS THOSE FROM CANADA'S TAR
SANDS ARE PASSING THROUGH
CALIFORNIA GREATER AND GREATER
RATES. I SHOULD THESE HEAVY
OILS IS NON POLLUTING OIL SPILL
THEY MAY BE VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO CLEAN UP. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T FLOAT ON THE SURFACE
THEY GO TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
WATER WAY. AND THEY ARE
PERMANENTLY LODGED IN THE
UNDERWATER ENVIRONMENT. AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE CONSEQUENCES
FOR WILDLIFE TOURISM FISHING
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. WOULD BE
DEVASTATING A SINGLE NON
POLLUTING OIL SPILL IN THE
KALAMAZOO RIVER IN MICHIGAN FOR
EXAMPLE TOOK HALF A DECADE IN
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN
UP. AND TO THIS DAY THE SITE IS
STILL CONTAMINATED. I WHEN I
AUTHORED THE SAME BILL SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THERE WAS ALREADY AN
URGENT NEED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT ITSELF. AGAINST THIS
TYPE OF SPELL. AND I'M REALLY
THRILLED THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS IS NOW MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION TO THE FINISH LINE.
THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION OTHER THAN THE PART
OF FINANCE WHICH IS OPPOSING
MANY MANY MANY. BILLS THESE
DAYS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL CALL
THE ROLL WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
A ONE TIME THEN THE MEASURE BE
PUT ON CALL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS AYE BATES. WELL I FOR
JUST. NO BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DOLLY NO DON. I THEY'RE
AWESOME I GALGIANI. I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO. I TITLE.
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
I MORE LOCK MORRELL. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN I PORTANTINO. ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE. NO I'M BURKE. I WHITE
HOUSE SKI AYE WIENER AYE WILK
HI. SENATOR WIENER MOVES THE
CALL. NO I MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY THREE
SENATOR HILL AND LOOKS LIKE
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. TWO TWENTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBR HOLDEN AN
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS WITH ONE EXCEPTION A.
B. FIFTEEN THIRTEEN IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD CODE CLEAN UP
BILL ONE SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENT
IS INCLUDED TO SPECIFY WHERE
EXCESS FUNDS FROM THE WILD FIRE
FUND ESTABLISHED UNDER AB FIFTY
AB TEN TEN FIFTY FOUR HOLDEN OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WHERE THOSE
EXCESS FUNDS WOULD BE RETURNED
IF THE FUND WAS TERMINATED THIS
MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SENATOR
HE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS.
BATES. WELL I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. CHIANG
DALLY I DODD. I THERE ARE SO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO. I TADO. I JACKSON. I
JONES. LEYVA I REQUIRE. I
MITCHELL. MONNING FIVE MORE
LOCK. I MORRELL. I NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN. I
STONE I UMBERG. I WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER AYE WILK HI
SENATOR HILL MOVES THE CALL NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO TWO FIVE SENATOR BELL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TEN BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AND ACT REALLY
NEED TO TRANSPORTATION. THEIR
BILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS MISS
PRESENT MEMBERS THIS IS THE
ANNUAL ON THE BUS
TRANSPORTATION BILL CONTAINS. A
TECHNICAL AND NON MINOR CHANGES
TO STATE LAW NO OPPOSITION
ARJUN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SETTING NOT ALL SENATOR
JACKSON THANK YOU MAY MERIT ASK
A QUESTION THE AUTHOR. SKINNER
YOU WILLING TO TAKE OUR
QUESTION GOV IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. MAKES IT ILLEGAL TO
BE HIGH ON A BUS TAXI OR LIMO.
IS THAT CORRECT. TO CHECK. IF I
MAY MY CONCERN MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IS. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT OUR PEOPLE HAVE HAD TOO
MUCH TO DRINK OR IMPLIED WE
WANT HIM TO GET OUT OF CARS AND
DON'T WANT TO BE DRIVING I'D
RATHER THEY TAKE THE BUS OR LE
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT AS A RESULT AB
FIVE. BUT TO FIND OTHER METHODS
OF TRANSPORTATION RATHER THAN
DRIVING THEMSELVES SO. THAT'S
MY CONCERN. AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE KNOWING WHETHER THAT
WAS PUT IN THE BILL BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S OF GRAVE CONCERN
AT LEAST TO ME I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T SUIT YOUR SOUL. WHICH
OKAY. COULD COULD WE PERHAPS.
FOR ALL THE ATTENTION THEY'RE
ALL THAT BUILDING WE HOLD THE
BILL OVER. HE WAS NUMBER IS
THAT A YES. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NOW BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY TWO. SEC A
SENATOR ALLEN. BE PREPARED FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY TWO. BEST MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ZERO ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. THIS PLEASE HOLD IT DOWN
IN THE CHAMBER. AROUND YOU CAN
BEGIN WHATEVER YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE FIGURE OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF THIS BILL WOULD
APPLY A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE
PASSED THE DISCLOSE ACT AND
THIS BILL WOULD APPLY THE
FRAMEWORK OF THAT TO SCHOOLS
ACT TO CAMPAIGN TAX MESSAGES.
INVITING A FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE THAT VOTERS SHOULD
KNOW WHO IS PAYING FOR THEIR
CAMPAIGN LITERATURE THAT THEY
GET BOMBARDED WITH DURING
ELECTION SEASON NO MATTER THE
MEDIA MORE TECHNOLOGY
DELIVERING IT. CALIFORNIA'S
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS ARE
INCREASINGLY REACHING OUT TO
VOTERS USING THEIR SMARTPHONES
PERHAPS SOMETIMES A KNOWINGLY
AND THIS THE WHOLE THE TEXT
MESSAGE DISCLOSE ACT STRIKES A
CAREFUL BALANCE TO PROVIDE THE
ELECTORATE WITH KEY INFORMATION
IN NEEDS TO KNOW ABOUT WHO IS
FINDING CAMPAIGNS. ONE NOT
BEING OVERLY BURDENSOME ON THE
CAMPAIGNS THEMSELVES. ARE THE
BILL CONTAINS SEVERAL
TECHNOLOGICAL OFF FRANCE TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF TAX
CHARACTERS USED TO MAKE
DISCLOSURES KENNEDY COMMITTEES
ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO INCLUDE
THE NAME OF THE CANDIDATE AND
THE OFFICE THE KENNEDY SEEKING.
CERTAIN CAN BE COMMITTEES WOULD
HAVE TO INCLUDE EITHER A
HYPERLINK TO A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE OR THE NAME OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE BODY OF THE
MESSAGE. IF FOR SOME REASON
DISCLOSURE PORTION GOES OVER
THIRTY FIVE CHARACTERS IN
INDEPENDENCE MANAGER WOULD ONLY
NEED TO DISCLOSE A SINGLE TOP
FUNDER. AND IF IN UNPAID
VOLUNTEERS BE USED TO SEND TEXT
MESSAGES. TOP CAMPAIGN FENDERS
IN I NEED TO BE DISCLOSED AT
ALL. PAST DISCLOSE AXE COVER
DISCLOSURE ON TELEVISION. RADIO
MAILERS PHONE CALLS EVEN SOCIAL
MEDIA. AB TWO A ONE SIMPLY
APPLIES THE SAME PRINCIPLE TO
CAMPAIGN TAX MESSAGES. IN
SUPPORT OF TRANSPARENCY AND
FAIR ELECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE TEXT
MESSAGE TO DISCLOSE ACT. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MATTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES BELL. I BORDERS I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I CHIANG
HI DOLLY I DON. I THERE ARE SO.
GALGIANI. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO.
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. MONNING
MORE LOCK. MORRELL NIELSEN. PAN
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I STONE.
NUMBER. I WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI. SENATOR
ALLEN MOVES THE CALL. NOW
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTION. WE AT WHAT
I'M SORRY WE YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT
WE HAD A WE HAD A MEMBER OUT SO
WE'RE GONNA PUT IT WE'RE GONNA
PUT ON CALL I SHOULD HAVE SAID
THAT WELL MEMBER LEFT DURING
THIS SO ANYWAY WE'VE IT'S ON
CALL WEARING GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY FIVES SENATOR
BELL. A CLARIFICATION ON THAT
AMENDMENT THE MEN MEANT TO IS
OF CONCERN CLOSES A LOOPHOLE
CREATED BY A CROSS REFERENCING
AIR THAT PROHIBITED CONSUMING
MARIJUANA IN PASSENGER CARS BUT
INADVERTENTLY PERMITTED THE
CONSUMPTION OF MARIJUANA IN THE
CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS AND THIS
CLARIFIES THE LANGUAGE THAT
ONLY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
CAMPING CONSUME BUT PASSENGERS
OF CHARTER PART PARTY CARRIER.
THAT'S THE AMENDMENT SO IT
WOULD NOT ALLOW IT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE MARIJUANA. IN A
CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS. I
REGION VOTE A YES VOTE ON THIS.
THERE JACKSON DO YOU HAVE ANY
MORE YOU WANTED TO ADD YES
ESSENTIAL I UNDERSTAND THE
AMENDMENT IT SAYS YOU CANNOT
ACTIVELY BE SMOKING MARIJUANA
IN A OF A PUBLIC TRANSIT OR
PARTY BUS WHICH IS VERY
DIFFERENT. THAN NOT. WHAT I HAD
TO BELIEVE THE SITUATION TO BE
IN WITH THAT CLARIFICATION I
ORIGINALLY VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON'S. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE NINE
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
BY THE WAY WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
SO WE'RE GONNA CALL THE ROLL
TWICE. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I BATES. I FELL I
FORGES I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
HI CHIANG. HI DOLLY. I DODD. I
DRAW SO I GALGIANI I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO. I TITLE I
JACKSON. I JONES. FIVE LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY. I
MORE LOCK I MORRELL. I NIELSEN
I PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN. I
STONE I UMBERG I WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WIENER AYE WILK I. PRICE
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS ARE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES SENATOR MITCHELL.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT A MOVE TO
SUSPENDSENATE RULES AS THEY
RELATE TO AB ONE SIXTEEN. OUR
AB ONE SIXTEEN IS A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUSPENDING SENATE
RULES. OKAY THERE'S AN
OBJECTION SO LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. I'D ENTER MITCHELL'S I'M
ASKING FOR A GUY. INSTANCE
CENTER JONES IS ASKING FOR A
NAY AND NOW. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL I BORDERS. NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG. THE ALLEY
NO DODD I ASSUME I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER. I AND SALAS I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL. I HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE NO
I'M BURKE. I WHO I CASTING I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. PRICE
TWENTY NINE DOES NINE SENATE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED CENTER
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT AB ONE THING I THINK
I'M SORRY MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE REACH. I'M HERE TO HELP.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AND
ACTUALLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CENTER MITCHELL MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
WE- SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE MET YESTERDAY AND
THIS IS AN ITEM WE TOOK ACTION
ON ITS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SIXTEEN IT'S OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL IT MAKES A VARIETY OF
CHANGES TO EXPAND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO FINANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. OUR
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING THAT AUTHORIZES
ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING FINANCING DISTRICTS.
THE ISSUE DEBT WITHOUT VOTER
APPROVAL PROVIDED CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET WHICH ARE
IDENTICAL TO THOSE THAT WERE
PASSED OFF THIS FLOOR IN SENATE
BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT. IN MARCH
OF THIS YEAR. SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRES AN E. I. F. D. THE
WHOLE THREE PUBLIC HEARINGS
PRIOR TO ISSUING DEBT. IF
BETWEEN TWENTY AND 50% OF
ELIGIBLE LAND OWNERS AND
RESIDENTS PROTEST THE ISSUANCE
DURING THE HEARINGS THE BILL
REQUIRES THE I. F. D. THE HOLD
AN ELECTION FOR VOTER APPROVAL.
IF THE MAJORITY OF ELIGIBLE
LANDOWNERS WHO RESIDENT
PROTESTS DURING THE HEARING
PROCESS THAT REQUIRES THE I FD
THE COUNCIL THE ISSUANCE THE
BILL ALSO MAKES A VARIETY OF
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES RELATED TO THE CONDUCT
OF THESE ELECTIONS TRIGGERED BY
THESE REQUIREMENTS. I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
MITCHELL. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEE NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HI ARCHIE LETTER AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO WELL I BORDERS. NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. CHIANG
NO DOLLY. DODD I THEY'RE
AWESOME. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL. I HUESO. HI TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORRELL.
NO NIELSEN. PAN. I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN. I STONE NO I'M BURKE. I
Y. CASKEY I WIENER. I WILK NO
NO. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY. THE ROSTER
I JONES NO NIELSEN. NO. BECAUSE
THAT'S THE MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME DALLY NO. HI IS TWENTY
NINE. THOSE ELEVEN. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS ROOM WORD
GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE SENATOR DORADO
ARE YOU PREPARED. KATE
TEMPORARILY PASS NOW FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FOUR SENATOR GONZALEZ.
PASS ON FILE. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY NINE CENTER
MCGUIRE. I KNOW YOU'RE HERE
SOMEWHERE. CARE TEMPORARILY
PASS. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT SENATOR ALLEN.
AND HE'S READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THE
CENTER ALIBIED IN DEFERENCE TO
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM BERKELEY
WHO. IS A GOOD CRAZY AS TO GO
QUICKLY THIS IS OF PORTS
SUPPORT BILL AND SPONSORED BY
THE C. M. T. A. AND THE COMPANY
WERE FOR SUSPICION ESTABLISH
THE BUSINESS WORKFORCE CREATION
UNIT WITHIN GO BAD. TO BETTER
ALIGN OUR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND I RESPECT PRESS
FIVE. THANK YOU SAID AROUND
EIGHTY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
I FELL. I FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO. I CHIANG HI DOLLY
I DODD. I THEY'RE AWESOME I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
I HILL. I HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON. JONES I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK I MORRELL. I
NIELSEN I PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN. STONE I AM BURKE. I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER. I
WILK FIVE CALL THAT THE MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON FIVE
STERN. HI. PRICE FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR ARCHER LETTER YOU
PREPARED FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
FOUR. TEMPORARILY PASS. OKAY
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO. SENATOR PAN ARE
YOU PREPARED. PASS ON FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE
SENATOR HUESO. NOT AT HIS DESK.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
SENATOR HER TADO. PASS ON FILE.
SENATE. ITEM BY ITEM TO FOR. MR
MAJORITY LEADER. CENTER
HERTZBERG PASS ON FILE. MOVING
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN SENATOR REQUIRE.
TEMPORARILY PASS FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY CENTER REQUIRE. GREAT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE SENATOR
CAFIERO. PLEASE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACTUAL LEADING TO
WATER THEIR CAVIAR THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA WHICH WILL
CREATE A NEW PROCESS THAT WILL
ALLOW THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
ISSUE A FIVE YEAR TEMPORARY
URGENCY PERMIT TO ALLOW GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES
OR LOCAL AGENCIES TO DIVERT
WATER TO UNDERGROUND STORAGE
DURING HIGH FLOW EVENTS
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS TO IT TO
ALLOW. A FLOODING OF THE FIELDS
FOR RECHARGE DURING A VERY
RAINY A YEAR THIS BILL WOULD
ADD ANOTHER TOOL FOR
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING THE
CHALLENGES OF IMPLEMENTING THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER MANNING
BEEN ACT THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
THAT I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
THIS MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS. SEEING NINE EYES
FORTY KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS SO BE FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS WE'D
EARLIER WENT BACK TO AND FINISH
BUSINESS AND WE DID THE GREAT
DEBATE ON THE NC DOUBLE A BILL
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
WHEN THE BILL COMES BACK WERE
ONLY SUPPOSED TO BE DISCUSSING
THE AMENDMENTS AND WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE BILL IN CHIEF SO
LET'S TRY TO NARROW THAT. ON A
RETURN BACK SO AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GOOD DOING FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE. AND THAT WOULD BE
SENATORS. WE'VE ALREADY DONE
TWENTY ONE CORRECT NO THAT WAS
TWENTY OKAY TWENTY ONE SENATORS
SKINNER IS UP AND READY SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE. READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY
END OF A KILLER AIR POLLUTION.
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS
REGARDING DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
WITHOUT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YEAH EIGHTY EIGHTY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE. MATTERS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO WELL HI
GORGEOUS. NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG HI DOLLY.
NO DODD. I TERRAZZA AYE
GALGIANI. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO. I TADA I JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK.
MORALE NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN. I STONE NO
I'M BURKE. I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER I WILK. NO. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN NO. PRICE THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SINCE
OUR CONCURRED IN
. OUR MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO SENATOR HERTZBERG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
HOWEVER I'M VERY WHO DID I SAY.
SO SORRY SET HER UP BURKE
SENATOR UMBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR UMBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS
SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS ODD
CONCURRENCE CONCERNS ONLY A
CHAPTER IN ISSUE URGENT AYE
VOTE. WELL DONE SENATOR UMBERG
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING DOES
SENATOR PORTANTINO QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. SENATOR UMBERG WERE
YOU TAKE A QUESTION. IT WOULD
BE THE HIGH POINT OF MY DAY BUT
I'M GOING TO FOREGO IT NOW.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER HERTZBERG
DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THIS
THANK YOU SIR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
SALLY NO DODD. I THEY'RE
AWESOME I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
TADA I JACKSON I JONES. NO
I MONNING I MORE LOCK. NO
MOREAU NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. I STERN I STONE NO
BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG FIVE
HUESO. I WIENER HI EYES THIRTY
KNOWS TEN AT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE SENATOR ALAN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALLEN IN AFTER LEADING
TO ELECTIONS SENATOR ALLEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH ABOUT A
SPEAKER MEMBERS SAID THIS BILL
REQUIRES COUNTIES THAT MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS TO ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION ENSURING A MORE FAIR
NONPARTISAN SYSTEM FOR DRAWING
THE LINES OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICTS BY
MISTAKE IN THE ASSEMBLY
INCREASE THE POPULATION
THRESHOLD FROM TWO FIFTY
THOUSAND TO FORTY THOUSAND
REMOVING FIVE SMALLER COUNTIES
FROM THE BILL. SOME MINUTES
ALSO MADE OF RATED T. DISS
INCREASE COSTS AND REMOVE
BARRIERS FROM COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS START REMOVED BURDENS
FROM COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
INCLUDING REQUIRING SCREEN TO
BE CONDUCTED BY THE CIVIL GRAND
JURY AS WELL AS MULTIPLE
TECHNICAL ANSWER FIND CHANGES.
I INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING OF
COUNTY CIVIL WARS ARE ALL
DISTRICTS WILL ENSURE A MORE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT WE
ARE EXTENDING THE SAME A SYSTEM
THAT. ARE DRAWS THE LINES FOR
US HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECT
FASHIONABLE. THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. EXCELLENT MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO WELL I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM I
CHIANG HI DOLLY. NO DODD. I
THERE ARE SO HI GALGIANI. FIVE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE
HERTZBERG HI HILL I WITH SO.
FIVE TADO I JACKSON. I JONES.
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCH. I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE MORE
LOCK. TOMORROW. MORALE NO OR
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO.
NIELSEN NO PAN. I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE. NO I'M BURKE I
Y. CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO. ICE
THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
PORTANTINO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SIR
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT A MEMBERS SP ONE
SIXTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE STATE SENATE CLARIFIED SOME
OF THE- ISSUES RELATED TO THE-AUTISM TREATMENT BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY MEMORIALIZE THIS
BILL AS LUCAS LAW. THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM SPRINGS SO
PROUD TO BRING BACK LUCAS LAWN
CONCURRENCE THE CENTER
PORTANTINO DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CENTER STONE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT IT. IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART AND A GREAT DEAL OF
APPRECIATION FOR SENATOR UMBERG
FOR MAKING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE SENATOR ORTANTINO TO.
NAME THIS LAW AFTER MY
BEAUTIFUL GRANDDAUGHTER LUKA
WAS ABOUT SIX AND A HALF YEARS
OLD BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO DO
IT'S GOING ALLOW FOR AUTISTIC
CHILDREN. HOW THAT ARE VERY
LIMITED IN THE BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES IF THEY CAN GET THE
INTENSE SERVICES THAT THEY CAN
GET WITHOUT BANKRUPTING THEM A
LOT HAVING TO DRIVE GREAT
DISTANCES TO GET THOSE.
SERVICES. YOU KNOW I THINK
EVERY LIFE ON THIS PLANET.
HUMAN LIFE HAS HAS A PURPOSE IN
MIND MY GRANDDAUGHTER LUKA IS
GOING TO BE A REFER TO AS- AND
SAID DEAL WITH VERY CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND- IN IN
DEALING WITH THEIR AUTISTIC
CHILDREN WITH THE HOPES THAT
THEY- CAN BECOME HEALTHY HUMAN
BEINGS. CANISTER BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT WE'RE GOING TO ADD TO
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THESE
THESE PARENTS AT STRUGGLE EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WITH THE HOPES OF
JUST HAVING A HEALTHY CHILD
PROSPER I IN THEIR LIVES AND SO
WITHOUT MY GRATEFUL
APPRECIATION CENTER PORTANTINO
MY GRATEFUL APPRECIATION
SENATOR UMBERG AND ON BEHALF OF
MY SON JASON STONE. AND HIS
LOVELY WIFE RIANA STONE AND MY
ENTIRE FAMILY WE ARE ENTIRELY
GRATEFUL AND PLEASE I URGE I
LOVE TO SEE UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
SB ONE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SIR
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I FELL I FOR JUST. I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
HI DOLLY I DON. I RAZA AYE
GALGIANI. I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
I GROW. I HERTZBERG. I HILL I
HUESO. I DADA HI JACKSON HI
JONES. LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE MORE
LOCK I MORRELL. I NIELSEN I PAN.
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. AYE STONE AYE
AYE NUMBER. I LIKE OWSKI I
WIENER I WILK. FIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES RUBIO
HI. ONE MORE TIME PLEASE. JONES.
FIVE HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE SENATOR HILL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR HELL AN ACT FOR LEADING
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB ONE
NINETY NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
ESSAY. AND ADJUST THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE PROPOSED
FOR THE OFFICE IN LIGHT OF THE
PASSAGE OF AB OF WHAT ONE ONE
ONE EARLIER THIS YEAR I DRIVE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU CENTER HILL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
HERTZBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO OH
FIVE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS. THANK
HERTZBERG THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CLARIFY MUNICIPALITIES
EXPECTED LIABILITY AYE VOTE
PLEASE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER. FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR HUESO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNICATIONS SO IN A WAY
SO THANK YOU IN A PRESIDENT'S
BE TO AVOID IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMAN MENSA BETTER HAVE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE
CABLE INDUSTRY AND OTHER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
BUT CAL FIRE CLEAR FRIEND THIS
BILL DOES NOT SIGNIFY THE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND. THE CPS
IS A THIRTY IT NEARLY AS LAWS A
CBC TO WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
HE LEGAL WROBEL COLORS IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE CALL BLOCKING WOULD
NOT RESULT IN REAL CALLS BE
BLOCKED AND IT DOES NOT CREATE
SIGNIFICANT LOOSE NEW
LIABILITIES FOR TELECOMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK. YOU CENTER HUESO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I FELL I FOR
JUST. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG AYE DALLY I DODD. I
THERE ARE SO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ. I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG HI HILL I WITH SO.
I TADO. FIVE JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORALE NO
NIELSEN. FIVE PAN. I PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE
STERN. I STONE. NO I'M BURKE HI
MY CASKEY. I WIENER. FIVE WILK
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST FIVE MORE
LOCK. DOLLY I TO KNOW. SIZE
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR DOT
BUT SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO OH NINE BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
WILDFIRES SENATOR DODD THAT A
PRESENT MEMBERS EIGHTY TWO OH
NINE PERTAIN TO WILDFIRE
WEATHER FORECASTING IS BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY FOR
CONCURRENCE. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THE BILL AND AFTER
CONCURRENCE IN IN SOME WAY
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IT'S OUR CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
THIRTY SENATOR BELL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO ELEVEN BY SENATOR BELL
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
HIGHWAYS THE REBEL. THE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE ADDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY ONE US THAT'S A FIGHT
TO THE BILL WHICH WILL
FACILITATE MAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE OF SURPLUS
CALTRANS PROPERTY AVAILABLE FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER FEEDING
PROGRAMS IN ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN SET STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR THESE LEASES
INCLUDING MINIMUM BUILDING CODE
STANDARDS AND CAPS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES THERE IS A
SUNSET ADDED JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY NINE HAS NO
OPPOSITION. VIRGIN I WROTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BILL BELL
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES FIVE WELL.
GORGEOUS. FIVE BRADFORD. BELLI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A- I
CHIANG. HI DOLLY NO DODD. HI
DRAWS SO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG. I HILL. I WAS SO. I
TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES HI
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL
FIVE MONEY. I MORE LOCK. FIVE
MOREAU. NO NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE NO
I'M BURKE. I LIKE HOW SKI I
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBER. FOR JUST.
CALL IF THE NUMBER ONE MORE
TIME. GORGEOUS. VERY GOOD.
THESE ARE. BATES I DON'T KNOW.
I CITY FIVE KNOWS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM. THIRTY ONE
SENATOR ALLEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
TWELVE BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS CENTER
ROAD HI THERE MEN PRESENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
OUR GENERAL LOST CITIES
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO UTILIZE TO MAJORITY WINNER
MAJORITY WINNER VOTING METHODS
FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS WE HAD SOME
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKING THE
ASSEMBLY THAT REMOVED. THE TWO
ROUND RUNOFF AUTHORIZATION FOR
CITIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INSTEAD AUTHORIZE THE TOP TWO
PRIMARY FOR GENERAL US CITIES
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN A TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE RANKED CHOICE
VOTING PROVISIONS AND THIS BILL
SIMPLY GIVES GENERAL US CITIES
THE VERY SAME TOOLS THE CHARTER
CITIES CURRENTLY HAVE TODAY
WITH REGARDS TO ENSURING. THAT
THAT THAT THEY CAN PUT IN PLACE
VOTING SYSTEMS THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT A MAJORITY THE VOTERS
ACTUALLY VOTE FOR THE PERSON IN
THE MORNING AT THE END OF THE
DAY. I DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
CHANGES ON THE CALORIES IT JUST
PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE OPTIONS
SO THEY CAN BETTER SELECT IN
ELECTIONS MATH OF THE MATCHES
THEIR NEEDS AND. CIRCUMSTANCES
AND WITHOUT I RESPECT FOR US
TONIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALAN. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL FIVE FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG
HI DOLLY. NO DODD. THERE ARE SO
I GALGIANI. FIVE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
I HILL I HUESO I DATO. FIVE
JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I MONNING
FIVE MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN. PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
HI STONE. NO I'M BURKE HI MY
COUNTY I WIENER. I WILK. I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES. NO DODD. PAN CALL THAT
JONES. NOW THEY HAVE SET
MEMBERS WILL MORE TIME. DODD. I
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
TO SENATOR DODD. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. THE
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
WILD LAND FIRE PREVENTION
SENATOR DODD THAT A PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS BE TWO FORTY SEVEN
PERTAINING TO AUDITING OF
UTILITY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WORK IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. UNDER DODD
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR
HUESO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE OH FIVE
BY SENATOR HUESO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES SENATE HUESO. YES MY
PRESIDENT. SB THREE OH FIVE IS
BACK UP FOR CONCURRENCE THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
IN EITHER HOUSE AND AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN WITH INPUT FROM BOTH
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. SO ON BEHALF
OF RYAN AND HIS FAMILY FOR
WATCHING THIS VOTE TAKE PLACE
AS FOR NINE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER HUESO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND AFTER
LEADING TO JURIES CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU THIS BILL
GIVES THE ABILITY FOR A PERSON
TO HAVE A JURY OF THEIR PEERS.
REMOVED THE OPPOSITION OF OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
ALSO REMOVED THE OPPOSITION OF
OUR POLICE CHIEFS AND NOW LA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JACKIE LACEY
IS IN SUPPORT. WITHOUT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG.
SUPPORT OF THIS MAJOR THAT MAY
SURPRISE MANY OF YOU SINCE I
WAS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO IT THE
FIRST TIME THIS MAJOR CAME TO
OUR HOUSE. HOWEVER THE AUTHOR
WHO HAS CHANGED MY MIND EARLIER
TODAY. I WORKED HARD TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS I SHARED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU TO THE
CENTER FROM BERKELEY FOR HARD
WORK ON THIS. THIS BILL NOW
ONLY ALLOWS EX FELONS TO SERVE
ON JURIES IF. THEY HAVE
FINISHED ALL OF THEIR PROBATION
OR PAROLE REQUIREMENTS AND THEY
ARE NOT A HE'S A SEX OFFENDER.
HELLO SENATORS I DO BELIEVE IN
SECOND CHANCES FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE MADE A MAN'S AS BEST THEY
CAN AND ARE STRIVING TO GIVE
BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
ALLOWING EX FELONS TO SERVE ON
JURIES MAY HELP THEM BETTER
ACCLIMATE INTO SOCIETY AND IT
MAY EVEN HELP OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB THREE TEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING. BUT TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU. PLEASE CALL. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES. BATES BELL. HI
FOR JUST. NO BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. NO DALLY.
DODD I DURAZO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL I HUESO I
TADO. JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK. MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
STONE. NO BURKE I WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER. I WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES.
NO DALLY. NO TADO. MORE LOCK NO.
I TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN AT THE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE SENATOR HUESO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HUESO AND AFTER LEADING TO
ANIMALS SENATE HUESO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AGAIN
SB THIRTEEN IS BACK UP FOR
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE
EXCEPTION FOR. SAYS APPLIES
ONLY TO DOMESTICATED HORSES.
ALSO IT AUTHORIZES SELECTION
THE EVENT OF A VIOLATION AND
PROVIDES FOR THE DISPOSITION
AND ANY COLLECTIVE PENALTIES
AND MAKES ADDITIONAL TO
TECHNICAL CHANGES I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. FOR US. SB TWO
THREE ONE THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR HUESO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I
BATES I FELL I FORGES. BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CHIANG HI DOLLY.
DODD. HI THE ROSTER HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ. I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HELLO. I HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA
I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I MINING
FIVE MORE LOCK. MORRELL.
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE I AM BURKE. I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER FIVE
WILK. I THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. REGIS DALLY. GROWTH
MORE LOCK. MORALE. BY THIRTY
FIVE NEW ZERO THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX SENATOR MONEY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
MINING AND AFTER LEADING TO
MEDICARE. SENATOR MONNING THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS NEAR THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND MAKE
CLEAR FINE AND TECHNICAL
CHANGES IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE THANK YOU CEREMONY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NO BELL I FORGES. THREE
POINT EIGHT NO BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. VALLEY NO
DODD. I TO RAZA I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. I HELLO I WAS SO. I
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. FIVE
MITCHELL. I MONEY. I MORE LOCK.
MERLE NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE. NO
I'M BURKE. I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER I WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG I
GROWTH. NO MORE LOCK NO NIELSEN.
NO. EYES THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE
ASSEMBLY REMNANTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. OKAY. I MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO ASSEMBLY WE'RE GOING BACK TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE SENATOR
LEYVA LOOKS LIKE SHE'S PREPARED
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AN ACT
RELATED CHARGES SCHOOLS THERE
LEYVA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
STATING THAT RECENT AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE NEGOTIATED AMENDMENTS
THAT MAKE THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL AB FIFTY
NO SEVEN CONTINUES THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S WORK IN
INCREASING CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY. BY ELIMINATING
LOOPHOLES IN CURRENT LAW WHICH
ALLOW CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
OPERATE OUT OPERATE OUTSIDE OF
THEIR AUTHORIZING DISTRICT THIS
BILL RESTORES THE RIGHT OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SCHOOLS
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES AND CLARIFIES THE
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY. OF
THE DULY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS
AND THEIR ROLE IN PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
SIX TO ADDRESS CONSISTENT AN
ONGOING CHALLENGES THAT LEAVE
IMPACTED DISTRICTS WITH NO
RECOURSE OTHER THAN COSTLY
LITIGATION LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES COMMONLY REFERRED TO
AS ELLIE ETS ARE TASKED WITH
ENSURING STUDENT SUCCESS. BUT
THAT SUCCESS IS BUILT OFF OF A
TRUST FROM THE COMMUNITY WITHIN
THE ELEAZAR AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT IS IMPACTED BY THE ELLIE
ETS. TRUST IS BUILT OFF OF
MEASURES OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT WHICH IS NOT PRACTICE
SYBIL IF ANOTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS AUTHORITY OVER THE
SCHOOL IN YOUR BACKYARD AB
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN ULTIMATELY IS
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND MAKE
SURE THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. HAVE TOOLS
AND THE POWER TO BEST USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND CHILDREN AND FOR
THOSE LOCAL ENTITIES TO DO WAT
THEY WERE ELECTED TO DO MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR LEYVA ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AND. I'M
SORRY TO SAY AGAIN THAT WE'RE
KIND OF BACK IN THE SAME PLACE
WHO WERE EARLIER IN THE WEEK
AND NOT TALKING ABOUT. CHARTER
SCHOOLS VERSUS TALKING ABOUT
THE BROADER CHALLENGES FACING
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND ONCE
AGAIN IT CERTAINLY PUTS ME IN
CONFLICT WITH THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT FACE
IN OUR SCHOOLS THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THE TEACHERS ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF THAT CHALLENGE.
OUR SUPERINTENDENTS OUR
PRINCIPLES OUR SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS. AND IT'S NOT AN EASY
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE. AND
YET WE IF IT'S BY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE DO IS A
STATE. I STATURE KATE OUR KIDS.
AND SO I KNOW IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB AND- CERTAINLY
WE'VE HAD FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES. THAT THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT AND I KNOW THAT IF I
WERE A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND
I HAD SCHOOLS THAT WERE FAILING
IN MY DISTRICT. THAT WHEN A
GROUP OF PARENTS WOULD COME TO
ME AND SAY WE'RE NOT HAPPY THE
SCHOOLS NOT WORKING FOR OUR
KIDS WE LOOKING FOR
ALTERNATIVES THAT I WOULD. I
UNDERSTAND THAT SENTIMENT. I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT. THAT
IT'S A STRESSFUL TIME FOR THEM
AND FOR US. BUT I KNOW THAT IT
THAT CHARTER SCHOOL WAS FORMED.
IT'S GONNA DIMINISH THE
RESOURCES THAT I WOULD HAVE IS
A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. TO HELP
THAT THE REST OF THE KIDS. AND
THIS IS THE THIS IS THE- THE
NATURAL CONFLICT THAT CHARTER
SCHOOL EFFORTS. COME INTO PLAY
WITH OUR REGULAR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM IS BECAUSE- BOTH SIDES
ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT'S BEST.
THOSE PARENTS OF FIVE POTENTIAL
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THEN THE
SCHOOL BOARDS SUPERINTENDENTS
THE TEACHERS ALL THE OTHERS
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
REGULAR SCHOOL SYSTEM I KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT HAPPY. BUT
WHEN THAT CONFLICT OCCURS.
THERE IS SELF INTEREST INVOLVED
IN THE CHOICE. MEANING THAT.
SCHOOL BOARDS ARE NOT
INTERESTED. IT FOR A EIGHT AND
IN MOST CASES IN AND SUPPORTING.
NEW PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS OKAY
THAT'S THE CONFLICT AND YET WE
HAVE A LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR
THESE PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
BE FORMED. A PROCESS FOR THEM
TO FILE APPLICATIONS TO CREATE
A SCHOOL. AND SO AND THERE YOU
HAVE THE CONFLICT SO. IF THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL GETS APPROVED
MAYBE NOT BY THAT SCHOOL BOARD
MAYBE ITS APPEAL TO THE COUNTY
BOARD OF THE STATE BOARD. NOW
YOU GET TO THE ISSUE OF WHERE
IS THAT CHARTER SCHOOL GOING TO
BE LOCATED. AND YOU GET BACK TO
THAT CONFLICT AGAIN IF THERE
ARE AT THE SCHOOL FACILITIES IN
A SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND THAT THE
COMMUNITY OF PARENTS IN THAT
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL WANT TO
USE THAT FACILITY. THERE'S
CONFLICT AGAIN BECAUSE THERE'S
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST AGAIN.
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE I
DISCUSSED EARLIER. SO WHAT IS
THAT NEWLY FORMED CHARTER
SCHOOL TO DO WELL THERE. THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE BRINGING IN A
PARENT COMMUNITY IN THE FROM
THE NEIGHBORHOODS. FOR THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S AROUND THAT
SCHOOL BUT YET THEY CAN'T USE
THAT FACILITY THAT'S NEARBY.
BUT YET THEY WANT ONE SO THEY
LOOK AROUND THEY TRY TO FIND
EMPTY OFFICES OR OTHER
FACILITIES TO BEGIN THEIR
SCHOOL. AND SOMETIMES THAT
MEANS THAT THE LOCATION OF THAT
SCHOOL GOES OUTSIDE A LINE. A
LINE ON A MAP. AND THEIR THEIR
VIEW IS I KNOW THAT THEY WANT
TO MAKE IT A COMFORTABLE PLACE
THEY WANT TO MAKE A CONVENIENT
PLACE TO LOOK FOR TRANSIT
ROUTES THAT TO LOCATE THAT
SCHOOL THEY WANT TO MAKE IT AS
CLOSE AS THEY CAN'T FROM THAT
COMMUNITY OF PARENTS THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THAT SCHOOL AREA. AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS. AND SO YOU
HAVE A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT IS OUTSIDE OF A LINE A
LINE ON A MAP. AND A BILL LIKE
THIS CREATES A SERIOUS
IMPEDIMENT TO THE ABILITY. TO
HAVE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
FUNCTION BECAUSE THEY NEED A
LOCATION WITHIN SIGHT OF A LIE
NOT OUTSIDE OF A LINE I THINK
ABOUT IT IN YOUR DISTRICT
MEMBERS THE LINES THAT ARE ON
THE MAP FOR YOU I KNOW IN MY
AREA THIS IS GOING TO SURPRISE
YOU. BUT THE SENATOR FROM NAPA
COUNTY. REPRESENTS AN AREA.
THAT THE IN MY DISTRICT. THIRTY
FORTY MILES AWAY FROM HIS
OFFICE IT'S ONLY ABOUT FIVE
MILES FROM MINE BUT IT'S A LINE
ON A MAP. HAPPENS TO BE
PLEASANT HILL. AND THAT'S
THAT'S THE CIRCUMSTANCE WE FIND
OURSELVES IN. IS IT REASONABLE
WELL IT'S WHERE THE LINES ARE
DRAWN. AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS WITH OUR CITY
LINES TO. BUT THOSE PARENTS ARE
NOT TRYING TO CREATE A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN A PLACES THAT FAR
AWAY THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT
AS CLOSE AS THEY CAN TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN WHICH THAT
CHARTER COMMUNITY WAS BORN.
WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR LIFEBLOOD
WITH THEIR FRIENDS. AND AT AND
THEIR NEIGHBORS ARE LIVING.
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE THAT AWAY.
YOU KNOW WHEN A. WHEN A PARENT
MAKES THE CHOICE TO BE A PART
OF IT A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL
NETWORK IT IS PROBABLY MAYBE
THE MOST DIFFICULT CHOICES.
THAT THEY MAKE IN THEIR LIVES
WHY IS THAT. BECAUSE IT'S A
COMPLETE DESTRUCTION OF THEIR
LIFE. THEIR FRIENDS THERE'S
THEIR CHILDREN'S FRIENDS ARE
NEARBY AND THEY WANT TO PLAY
TOGETHER THEY WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL TOGETHER THEY BREAK THAT
UP. AND WHEN THEY HAVE TO GET
UP EARLY IN THE MORNING AND
COME HOME AT NIGHT. THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SCHOOL THEY HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO GET TO THAT PLACE WHERE THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS BEEN FORMULATED
BECAUSE THEY- THEY KNOW IT'S
THE LIFE BLOOD FROM THEIR POINT
OF VIEW FOR THEIR- THEIR
CHILD'S FUTURE. AND THEY HAVE
TO INCONVENIENCE THEIR WHOLE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE OR WORK LIFE
WHATEVER IT IS. TO MAKE THAT.
ATTENDANCE AT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL WORK. AND THEN WE HAVE A
BILL LIKE THIS IT SAYS. NO NOW.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT EVEN ALLOW THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL BECAUSE IT'S
OUTSIDE THAT LINE THAT LITTLE
LIGHT ON THE MAP. UNDER
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS. AND SO
MY FRIENDS. IT IS NOT. WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING. IT IS NOT
FOCUSING ON THE PROBLEMS OF
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE. AS I
DISCUSSED A FEW DAYS AGO OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FAILING SCHOOLS.
TWENTY FIVE OF THEM. CHARTER
PUBLIC CHARTERSCHOOLS DO I
LIKE THAT NO I DON'T LIKE FEEL
THE SCHOOLS ANYWHERE WHAT IT
WHATEVER THEY ARE WE OUGHT TO
WORK TOGETHER TO RESOLVE BOATS.
BUT THIS THIS THIS LEGISLATION
THAT SAYS A LINE ON THE MAP IS
GOING TO MAKE IT EVEN HARDER
FOR PUBLIC CHARTERS ISN'T THE
SOLUTION IS NOT GOING TO HELP
THEIR PET THAT THESE PARENTS
YES. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF THEM
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF THE
BUT NOW UTILIZED THE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOL NETWORK. AND
WHEN THEY TOOK THEIR CHILDREN.
TO BED TONIGHT. WHAT ARE THEY
THINKING ABOUT. HELLO MY GET A
GET MY KID READY IN THE MORNING
HOW MY GONNA GET THEM TO THAT
SCHOOL THE SAME THINGS THAT ALL
PARENTS THINK ABOUT IT YET IF
YOU'RE IN A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL BELIEVE ME YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT IT TWICE AS HARD
BECAUSE IT'S MORE INCONVENIENT.
AND THAT'S THE CHOICE THAT
THEY'RE MAKING SHOULD WE
SUPPORT THAT CHOICE TODAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO THAT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER. SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I DON'T KNOW IF I
COULD BE AS ELOQUENT. AS THE
SENATOR FROM ARANDA BUT. AB
FIFTY NO SEVEN FOCUSES ON
BOUNDARIES. AND WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON STUDENTS AND WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON PARENTS
WHO WANT THEIR KIDS TO SUCCEED.
THE CURRENT SCHOOL. DISTRICT
PARADIGM IS SINKING IN
SACRAMENTO IS MOVING DECK
FURNITURE. I URGE A NO VOTE ON
A. B. FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. BIGGEST
ARE MORE LIKE CENTER BARGES. TO
PRESENT. MY TENURE IN THE
SENATE BEGAN AN INTEREST IN
JANUARY SO FORGIVE ME IF I'M A
LITTLE LATE TO THE PARTY IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW ALL OF
SACRAMENTO IN THE SENATE WORKS.
BUT I THINK WHAT REALLY COME OF
WHAT. REALLY IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION IS DO YOU BELIEVE DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS PROVIDE A WORTHWHILE
SERVICE. OR DO YOU NOT. IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION COMES THROUGH IT
FALLS INTO TWO CAMPS. MOST OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE SEE HAPPENS
TO BEING IN THE LATTER. AND
IT'S JUST A SYSTEMATIC
DELIBERATE DISMANTLING OF THE
CHARTER SYSTEM. LEGISLATION BY
LEGISLATION ISSUE BY ISSUE
CHIPPING AWAY WHEN ULTIMATELY
THE ISSUE IS WE JUST DON'T LIKE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THAT I
THINK. IS UNFORTUNATE I'M NOT
GONNA GET INTO THE MERITS ON
THIS I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
DISCUSSED BY EARLIER. COMMENTS
I JUST THINK IT'S SAD WHEN YOU
HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CHILDREN TO LEARN. AND YOUR
TAKING AWAY THAT OPPORTUNITY IN
FORCING THEM. ONTO A DIFFERENT
PATH WHEN TO CAN SIMULTANEOUSLY
EXIST. AND PERFORM WELL THIS IS
NOT A WIN LOSE SITUATION OR AN
EITHER OR WAR. THEY CAN COEXIST
CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN THRIVE CO
EXIST WITH THRIVING TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. I THINK WE NEED
TO RE EVALUATE OUR THESE
CHARTER ISSUES NOT JUST ONCE IN
THE SESSION BUT THE ONES THAT
WILL PROBABLY COME UP IN THE
NEXT SESSION. WE CAN FIND PASS
FORWARD FOR THEM TO CO EXIST.
AND BE MEANINGFUL INSTITUTIONS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES I JUST DON'T
THINK WERE. BEING HONEST WITH
OURSELVES IF WE ARE LOOKING AT
THIS LEGISLATION BY
LEGISLATION. NOT FIXING A
PROBLEM ITS DISMANTLING CHARTER
SYSTEMS. THANK YOU CENTER BOARD
JUST SENATOR FELL. WELL AFTER
THIRTEEN YEARS HERE AND TWENTY
SIX YEARS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE. LEGISLATION THAT
REALLY CLARIFIES RELATIONSHIP
IF. I'M GONNA TRY TO TAKE YOUR
CHEESE AWAY OR IF YOU'RE GOING
TO TRY TO TAKE MY CHEESE AWAY
SO THIS RELATIONSHIP INTER
GOVERNMENTAL RELIGION SHOULD BE
ISSUE IS REALLY UNIMPORTANT
IMPORTANT THING AND I AND I
STAND FOR THIS BILL. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ESTABLISH
THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO HAVE THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE ONE
THAT HAS THE SITE. HOUSE TO
HAVE THE VOTERS IN THAT
DISTRICT. BE THE PREDOMINANT
DECISION MAKING BODY. THE
PREDOMINANT DECISION MAKING
BODY. WITH COOPERATION WITH THE
OTHER. SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WORKING WITH THOSE SCHOOL THIS
IS THE AND THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
BUT I THINK THAT'S A FAIR A
FAIR THING BECAUSE WE DID PASS.
THE LAW. THAT'S A COMPANION
BILL SAYING THAT. WE WENT TO
SCHOOL BOARD FROM THAT AREA. TO
HAVE THE FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THEY THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DETERMINING THE IMPACT. ON ALL
THE STUDENTS IN THAT DISTRICT
WHAT IS THE ACADEMIC IMPACT
WHAT IS THE FISCAL IMPACT NOT
JUST FOR THE CHURCH START
CHARTER SCHOOL KIDS BUT FOR ALL
THE KIDS. IN THE DISTRICT. HOW
DOES IT IMPACT YOUR THOSE KIDS
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION. HOW DOES
IT HELP THE KIDS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION OF THOSE ARE ISSUES
THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
SO I THINK THIS BILL HELPS
FACILITATE THOSE KINDS OF
RELATIONSHIPS. THAT THOSE KIND
OF RELATIONSHIPS ARE GOING TO
HELP THE STUDENTS NOT HURT. SO.
SOMETIMES ANOTHER ANALOGY MIGHT
BE IMPORTANT. AND WHAT IF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. WHAT UP TO
ANOTHER COUNTY DECIDE WE'RE
GOING TO PUT A PRISON UP IN
ARANDA. OKAY SAY WE WANTED TO
PUT A PRISON ONE OF WE HAVE OUR
PRISON INMATES. BEEN FACILITY
UP IN THAT ARE AND WE DON'T
TALK HAVE TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT
IT. WE CAN GO UP THERE AND DO
IT WITHOUT. ANY KIND OF RULES.
WE COULD SEE THAT'S A VERY
ILLOGICAL SAYING THAT'S WHY YOU
NEED. RELATIONSHIPS
INTERGOVERNMENTAL RELATIONSHIPS.
TO DEVISE WHAT THE RULES OF THE
RULES ARE THIS BILL DOES THAT.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. WE
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BELL CENTER NIELSEN. MR
PRESIDENT LADIES DOWN THE
SENATE I. WAS NOT IN A HASTE TO
PUT MY MICROPHONE UP I'VE
SPOKEN SO OFTEN ON THIS ISSUE
OVER THE YEARS. BUT I MUST
CONCLUDE THIS WITH THE- THEN
OBSERVATION HOW THE ATTACK. BUT
I HATE TO USE THAT WORD I WISH
YOU COULD BE CONCILIATORY BUT
THERE ISN'T OUT OVER AND LONG
STANDING ATTACK ON PRIVATE
SCHOOL THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
EXCUSE ME THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
BY SOME ONLY SOME BUT SOME IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL ESTABLISHMENT.
AT ALL LEVELS. SUPERINTENDENTS
WHO HAVE AN ALL OF LEVEL OF
AUTHORITY IN THIS. SCHOOL
BOARDS. YES BE A FOR EXAMPLE.
CERTAINLY CTA. I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
AT THE FOR. TO DESTROY. CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND THEN THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE MATURED A BIT.
REALIZE THAT THEY HAD TO GET
MORE ACTIVE HERE. AND THE
POLITICAL PROCESS. THEY LEARNED
THAT PROCESS. THEY BECAME
SOMEWHAT SUCCESSFUL. FILL THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL NOW ESTABLISHMENT
HAS GOT TO DOUBLE DOWN IN FACE
OF THIS THREAT. TO THEIR
DICTATORSHIP. OF THE EDUCATION.
OF OUR YOUTH. I DON'T LIKE TO.
SPEAK SO HARSHLY. BUT IT REALLY
IS A PAIN TO THE HEART. WHEN
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THE RESULT
IS AND IT IS NOT THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR YOUTH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. ARE
NOT ABOUT THE KIDS. NOT ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION THEY RECEIVE OF THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE AVAIL THEM AND THEIR
PARENTS. IT IS ABOUT HAM
STRINGING. THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE.
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION. MAYBE A
TRUCE COULD BE CALLED NOT BE
LOVING TO BE A PART OF THAT.
TRUCE AND A PEACE DELEGATION.
TO PROFESSIONS SOME KIND OF A
COMPROMISE HERE. IT WOULD BE
TOLERABLE. BUT I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY EVIDENCE YET. OF THAT AND I
CHARTER SCHOOL ESTABLISHMENT.
WANTING TO DO ANYTHING BUT
DESTROY. I ORIGINAL WILL. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN. SEEING NO
OTHER MIKE'S UP THERE LEYVA YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT WELL WE GOT A LITTLE
FAR AFIELD ON WHAT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT AND WHAT IT
ACTUALLY DOES THIS BILL IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL
WHICH I THINK MOST OF US ON
THIS FLOOR SUPPORT. AND THE
LINES THAT ARE DRAWN ARE NOT
ARBITRARY LINES THEY'RE NOT
LIKE THE LINE THAT OUR
PRESIDENT USER SHARPIE AND DREW
ON A MAP THESE ARE LINES THAT
WERE ACTUALLY DRAWN TO CREATE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR THE CITIES
THAT WE LIVE IN THEY CEATE THE
CITY THAT WE LIVE IN. I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF CHINO SO IF MY
SCHOOLBOARD VOTES ON THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND THEN LOCATED
IN THE CITY OF ONTARIO WHICH IS
A CITY THAT ABUTS THE CITY OF
CHINO. HOW DOES THE CITY OF
ONTARIO SCHOOL BOARD FEEL ABOUT
US A SCHOOL THAT THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER BEING IN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT THIS IS ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL THIS IS NOT ABOUT
CLOSING DOWN CHARTER SCHOOLS
THIS IS NOT ABOUT NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO OPEN THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE IN THE
DISTRICT THAT ACTUALLY VOTED
FOR THEM. MEMBERS I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. WALT DEBATE HAING
SEES MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I
PORGES. NO. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. CAFIERO CHIANG NO.
DOLLY NO DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HILL AYE
HUESO. I TADO. JACKSON. HI
JONES KNOWS LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO. SKINNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER. OUR
CASKEY BY WINNER HI WILK NO.
THERE LEYVA MOVES THE CALL. NOW
MEMBERS WE ARE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. I'M SORRY I'VE BEEN
JUST THE STRUCTURE WE'RE GONNA
LIFT THE CALL ON ITEM ONE FORTY
TWO. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
AYE BATES. DORADO BY. GROWTH
HERTZBERG. WITH SO. JONES BY.
THAT'S LEYVA. MITCHELL LEYVA
AYE MITCHELL MONNING. MORE LOCK
I AM A RAIL. NIELSEN BY MORRELL
HI PAN. STONE STONE AYE
ARCHULETA I TO KNOW. YEAH CAN
WEEK WE ARE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BATES HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HUESO.
MITCHELL. MONNING HI PAN. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE. MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
BACK AND LET THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE. MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN HI. CABALLERO
GALGIANI. HERTZBERG HI TADO.
RUBIO I. HI IS TWENTY FIVE
KNOWS TWELVE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN. AND THAT WOULD BE
SENATOR STERN ARE YOU PREPARED.
OKAY BEFORE CENTER STERN PURRS
PRESENTS ONE REMIND EVERYBODY.
PLEASE LIMIT YEAR. YOUR
COMMENTS TO BE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN CAN BROAD PUT IN FROM
THE ASSEMBLY MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BEFORE
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
ACKLINGTON NATURAL GAS STORAGE
WELLS. CENTER STERN I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND WITH YOUR-
IN RESPECT TO YOUR. ADMONITION
I'LL JUST CLARIFY HERE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT CHEMICAL
DISCLOSURE BILL. DRESSING
NEARLY SO CANYON GHASTLY CAN
OTHER NATURAL GAS STORAGE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE. WOULD
REQUIRE DOGGER TO RESPOND TO A
RECENTLY RECORD RELEASE ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS. THAT SHOW. AS A
HISTORY OF MISMANAGEMENT OF
THIS OF THIS FIELD AS WELL AS
MANY REMAINING QUESTIONS ABOUT.
WHAT CHEMICALS WERE ACTUALLY.
BLOWN OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
PEOPLE ARE STILL SICK AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHY THERE'S BEEN A
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN THE
CHEMICALS WE USE IN THESE GAS
STORAGE FACILITY SO THE LAST
AMENDMENTS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS WELL
SO WE THINK THIS IS A POSITIVE
STEP FORWARD FOR THE INDUSTRY
TO BUILD TRUST WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AGAIN. AND REST
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL. ANY OTHER. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL I BRIDGES. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO HI CHANGE I DALY. DOT
I DORADO. GALGIANI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. HI TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY MONNING
BY MORE LOCK I'M A REAL NO.
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. RUBIO. BROTHER I
RUBIO SKINNER. HI STERN HI.
STONE NO RUBIO BY. NUMBER I
HAVE BY RIGHT BECAUSE HE- BY
WIENER BY WILK BY. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD BY DALLY. DORADO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. THIRTY
EIGHT CENTER PORTANTINO ARE YOU
PREPARED YOU ARE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
THERE PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M GLAD THIRTY EIGHT
FOLLOWED THIRTY SEVEN. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR I'D CONCURRENCE WHICH DOES
THE NOVEL THING OF ACTUALLY
AWARDING DEGREES TO STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE THE COURSE WORK. THE
MEMONS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION ONE
YEAR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. EIGHTY THIS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THING NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS I BRADFORD. CABALLERO
APHRODITE CAVIAR I. CHIANG I.
DALY AYE DODD. HI DORADO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER HI. GONZALEZ I
GROW AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I TACO I JACKSON AYE
JONES. LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. I'M A REAL. BY NELSON. BY
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN BY
STONE. I AM BURKE OUR COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
GALGIANI. JONES BY RUBIO I.
PRICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE CENTER Y.
KOWSKI IS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FIVE EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
AYE CALCIUM ACT RULING CIVIL
ACTIONS THERE Y. CASKEY FLOOR
SHORES THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
SWORE TECHNICAL IN NATURE THIS
IS A SUPPORT OPPOSE BILL I
REGION. HI FOLKS. AB DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THING NOW MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NOBEL. BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD HI KELLY AERO HI
CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD. HI
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
pHERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO. JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NUMBER
RAIL NOTE NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK NO. MISTER. SECRETARY CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS TACO. LEYVA
I RUBIO HI. HI TWENTY EIGHT NOS
ELEVEN THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY SENATOR
BRADFORD HE'S READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FIVE SEVENTY FIVE A
SENATOR BRADFORD ENACT REALLY
AND CAL GRANTS CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SB
FIVE SOME FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE NATURE AND
DEALS WITH CHAPTER IN ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR. HE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE MR SACK
YEAH MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. BY ATKINS AYE BATES.
BATES HI BELL HI PORGES.
BRADFORD. I CAN BE HERO HI
CHIANG I DALY. HI DODD HI
DORADO HI GALGIANI BY. GLAZER
BY GONZALEZ I. GROWTH. BURGESS
BY GROWTH HERTZBERG BY HILL HI
GROW BY WITH SO. BY OUR TITLE I
JACKSON. HI. JONES HI LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. BY PAN BY. TO DO YOU
KNOW BY ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER
BY STERN BY STONE. BY NUMBER
OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MORE LOCK
RUBIO. HI. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR
CONCURRED IN MOVING NOW RIGHT
AFTER ITEM FORTY FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE CENTER PORTANTINO IS
READY TO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
HUNDRED BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WISH I
WERE FORTY ONE AGAIN BUT I'M
BACK TO PRESENT SB SIX HUNDRED
ON CONCURRENCE ON FERTILITY
PRESERVATION THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY WORK
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL. GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALY DODD.
HI DORADO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
OUR TITLE HI JACKSON. HI JONES
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK MERRELL. HI NIELSEN. HI
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN HI.
STONE I AMBERG OUR CASSIE AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI THIS IS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA. HI
BATES. BELL HI JANE. BY DAILY
HI GROWTH. MORE LOCK. THAT'S
GROW MORE TIME BATES GROW GROW
BY MORE LOCK. SIZE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO SENATOR ALLEN IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR ALLEN
AN ACTOR LINDA TENDENCY.
SENATOR ALLEN. MISTER PRESIDENT
THIS BILL SB THREE AT SIX
THIRTY EIGHT HELPS RENTERS
ACCESS ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS BY REFORMING
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS ARE
THEIR INSTALLATION I MEMBERS
TAKING THE ASSEMBLY SAFEGUARD
RENTERS AGAINST EXCESSIVE
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS THE BILL
HAS NO. OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECT PRESS RUBBER. THANK YOU
SIR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL I PORGES. BRADFORD CAFIERO.
HI CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD. I
DORADO HI GALGIANI. GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO. I
JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL BY MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK MERRELL. HI
NIELSEN. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN HI STONE. I AMBERG OUR
COUNTY HI WINNER HI WILK HI
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES HI. OR
JUST. BRADFORD HI GALGIANI BY
JONES. BY MORE LOCK. SKINNER
SKINNER RIAA. I THIRTY EIGHT OF
THE VICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE SENATOR
CAFIERO IS PREPARED SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AND ACT REALLY
THE HEALING ARTS SENATOR MISTER
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS SB SIX
NINETY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY EAST
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS BOARD
AND REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE AT THIS
IS ACTUALLY A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS SEEING NONE. ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR ONCE AGAIN SENATOR
CAFIERO SHE'S PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING THE FLOORS YOUR
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES AMONG OTHER
THINGS TOOK OUT THE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY DAY JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROCESS WHICH REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
ADDED A SUNSET THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES HI BILL I BURGESS. HI
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO.
BY. GALGIANI BY GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO I.
JACKSON JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL. MONNING. MORE LOCK
I AM A RAIL. I NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE I AMBERG OUR COUNTY. NO
WIENER. WILK. HI HI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD. BY
JACKSON LEYVA. BY MITCHELL.
MONNING STERN WIENER WIENER AYE.
HI THIRTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX SENATOR GLAZER
IS READY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO PARKS GLACIER FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE BAN ON
SMOKING IN PARKS AND BEACHES
YOU HEARD THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
EARLIER TODAY AND FOR THOSE WHO
AND LET ME JUST MENTION THAT TO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS DEALT
WITH SIGNAGE AND ALLOWING
SMOKING ON PAVED ROADS AND FIND
PARKING FACILITIES ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THAT WE ACCEPTED. BUT
FOR THOSE WHO'VE BEEN AROUND
AWHILE WILL KNOW THAT THIS IS
MY THIRD TIME. THREE THIS
LEGISLATION ROOM HOPING THIRD
TIME IS THE CHARM BUT MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THAT MY WORK IN
THIS AREA IS ACTUALLY NOT AN
ORIGINAL PIECE OF WORK THAT THE
ORIGINAL WORK. TO BAN SMOKING
IN PARKS AND BEACHES WAS LED BY
SENATOR MARTY BLOCK FROM SAN
DIEGO. WHO WAS TURNED OUT A FEW
YEARS AGO AND SO LIKE CARRIED
THE BANNER THAT HE HAS LED ON
FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND SO I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT IN
THIS LEGISLATION TODAY BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THE GREAT
LEADERSHIP. OF CENTER MARTY
BLOCK AND THAT HIS WORK IN THIS
AREA. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI BATES.
NOBEL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD.
CAFIERO HI JANE. DALLY. NO DODD.
DORADO I GALGIANI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROW NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO HI
JACKSON. JONES NO. LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LARK NUMBER RAIL NO
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER
OUR CASSIE. BY WIENERAYE WILK
HI MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
HI BRADFORD. JANE NO DODD.
GALGIANI HI JACKSON HI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE FINAL TIME
BRADFORD. HI DODD. HI TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMONS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MEMBERS MOVING TO A FILE ITEM.
FIFTY TWO CENTER MCGUIRE ARE
YOU PREPARED IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
FIVE A CENTER REQUIRE AN ACT
REALLY CANNABIS. SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESIDENT YOU HAVE BEEN
GOING ALL DAY AND VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE WORK SIR A NAME IS
TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY ADDRESS
CHAPTER NOW ISSUES. IN REMOVE
LANGUAGE CLARIFYING THE ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
CANNABIS AFTER WAS ADDRESSED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU SIR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THIS BILL
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION SEEING
ONE OVER TO MY RIGHT AND MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES. HI BILL I BURGESS.
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY HI DODD. HI I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILLAYE HUESO BY TADO. I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING.
MORE LACKEY I'M RAIL NIELSEN.
HI PAN BY PORTANTINO I ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG.
IOWA CASKEY I WINNER HI WILK BY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BOARD YES.
JANE BY MORNING BY MERRELL.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN BOB NEXT FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR SENATOR TADO IS PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT TWO SIXTY BY SENATOR
HER TADO AN ACTOR L<c.cyan>G</c>
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE CENTER TADO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT US
SB TWO SIXTY BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. I'M AND
ARE LARGELY TECHNICAL IN NATURE
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
NO NO VOTES AND IT WAS A CLASS
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL I BOARD YES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI CHIANG
I DALY DODD AYE DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. HI TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES KNOWS LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCKED RAIL NO NIELSEN.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER. HI STERN AYE
STONE. BY AMBERG OUR CASKEY. I
WINNER. BY WILK BY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. GORGEOUS
DALY GROVE. MORE LOCK. NIELSEN.
RUBIO HI. SIZE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR
CONCURRED IN NEXT UP MEMBERS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE CENTER
HUESO BE PREPARED YOU ARE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HUESO ENACT RULING
COSTA RESOURCES THERE HUESO YES
MISS PERSON THREE SIXTY SEVEN
IS BACK ON CENTER FOR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE VERY TECHNICAL BUT THEY
REQUIRE THE SEC EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. TO SUPPORT RATHER
THAN MEET STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ADOPTED CONTENT
STANDARDS TO COUNT FOR
SITUATIONS IN WHICH MEETING
CONTEXT AN URGE OR NOT
APPLICABLE. SO THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECT FOR IT.
A ROOM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL BY BOARD YES. BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO HI CHANGE AYE DALY
AYE DODD I DORADO. HI GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TADO. I JACKSON BY JONES. I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK.
MORALE. NIELSEN AYE PAN I
PORTANTINO BY ROB. HI RUBIO AYE
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. I AM
BURKE. IOWA CASKEY BY WINNER HI
WILK HI MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS.
GROVE MORE LOCK. MORRELL. PRICE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE I SEE
THIS CENTER PORTANTINO'S
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE HOLD IT
DOWN RESPECT THE SENATOR CENTER
PORTANTINO PLEASE PROCEED
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
GOING TO FARMS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I MEMBERS I AM
BRINGING BACK THREE SEVEN SIX
ON CONCURRENCE WITH CHAPTER OUT
AMENDMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL I PORGES NO BRADFORD HI
KELLY GUERO BY CHIANG. DALY
DODD. I DORADO BY GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY TADO. JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. BY MITCHELL.
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE NOPE NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI BY STONE.
NO NUMBER BY A COUNTY BY WINNER
BY WILK NOPE. ROTH. ROTH I
DON'T AGREE TERRY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG. NO
DALLY NO. FOR TITLE. MARLA NO.
PRICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
CENTER HUESO. BE READY. PASS ON
FILE. MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX SENATOR Y. KASKI. SIXTY TWO
YOU JUST PASSED ON FILE. THE
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTEEN BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HE ENACT RULING THE
CIVIL ACTIONS. BY CASKEY MISTER
PRESIDENT. SB SIX ONE SIX GOT A
LITTLE SKINNY ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE BUT IT'S BACK HERE FOR
CONCURRENCE IT WILL PROTECT THE
LAST ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT DOLLARS IN THE
WORKERS BANK ACCOUNT AFTER
BEING SEIZED BY. THAT FROM
BEING SEIZE FROM THAT
COLLECTORS AMENDMENTS HAVE ALSO
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION FROM THE
BANKING INSTITUTIONS IN THE
CREDIT UNION'S AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE ASSEMBLY ALSO RESULTED IN
THE BILL RECEIVING FORTY EIGHT
VOTES. IT'S NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE IN POVERTY NOT GOING
DEBT I WOULD ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS AND ALLOW THIS BILL
TO REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
FAMILIES LIVES THANK YOU SIR Y.
CASKEY. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NOBEL HI GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD AYE CAPPIELLO BY CHAIN
NO DALY NO DODD. HI THERE ALSO
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. HI HI TOTO.
I JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA.
MCGUIRE MITCHELL. MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. HI PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER. BY STERN BY
STONE. NO AMBERG IOWA CASKEY HI
WIENER. BY WILK NO PORTANTINO I
DON'T KNOW. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JACKSON. LEYVA HI RUBIO. RUBIO
JACKSON I. RUBIO HI. HIGHS
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO CENTER
HUESO IS READY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO AN
ACRYLATE ENERGY THERE HUESO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SB
FOUR FIVE SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THIS BILL EXTENDS THE SENATE
SUNSET DATE BY FIVE ADDITIONAL
YEARS OF EXISTENCE EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR BY MY
THING PROJECTS ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
WERE CLARIFYING THE NATURE AND
TECH VERY MINOR AND TECHNICAL.
HI I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR HUESO.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE. HEY HI MISTER AS
SAYING NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL I PURCHASED I BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHAIN AYE
DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. GROWTH I HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO. HI
JACKSON. JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONEY I'M
MORE LUCK BY AMARILLO. I
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN STONE. I AM BURKE OUR
CASKEY. WIENER. BY WILK HI HI
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. BY
GONZALEZ JACKSON MITCHELL.
SKINNER STERN WHY CASKEY. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S OUR
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATOR GLAZER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY
THE CAMINO BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ECHOING HEALING ARTS CENTER
GLAZER THIS IS A BE AND HE
COMMITTEE BILL WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. HE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE THERE
ANY OBJECTIONS. SEEING NINE
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
NOW TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SENATOR BELL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE BY
SENATOR BELL AND ACTOR LANE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCE.
CENTRE BELL THIS PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS. BILL IS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INVESTMENT
PROGRAM OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE CAST CONCURRENCE ON ONE
CLEAR FOR THE PRIORITY PRIORITY
SHOULD BE GIVEN TO PLANTS BATES
BASED ON THE DEPTH OF THEIR
AFFORDABILITY. AND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT IS TO ADDRESS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE COMMENTS AND
CREATE MORE CERTAINTY FOR
LOCALS TO ISSUE BONDS WITH SB
FIVE PHONES. AND PROVIDE AND
NUMBER THREE IS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR CPAS SPECIFIED SMALL
SELF HELP HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
RELY ON VOLUNTEER WORKERS.
NUMBER FOUR IS OTHER NON
SUBSTANTIVE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ARJUN CHAU
CONCURRENCE ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NOBEL AYE PORGES.
BRADFORD. HI CAPPIELLO BY
CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD. I
DORADO. GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. HI
JACKSON. JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL BY MONNING
BY MORE LARK. A REAL NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE. NO I'M BURKE OUR
CASSIE I WINNER BY WILK NOW
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BOARD YES.
DORADO HI GROWTH JACKSON. I
MORE LOCK. PRICE TWENTY NINE NO
STATE THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE SENATOR WINNERS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR WINNER AN
ACRYLATE CANNABIS CENTER WIENER
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SB THIRTY FOUR
RETURNS TO US FROM THE ASSEMBLY
OF THE DENNIS BROWN AND BROWN
IN MERRY OCT TO ENSURE THAT
COMPASSION CANNABIS PROGRAMS
CAN CONTINUE TO EXIST.
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
REPLACE THE URGENCY BECAUSE
WITH THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
DATE SUNSET ALL OF THE TAX
EXEMPTIONS AFTER FIVE YEARS
REQUIRE ANNUAL REPORTS ON THESE
KIND OF THE STATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AND
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. AND
ENJOY STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER WINNER ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. THING AND THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTIONS. THING
NINE. SAYS I DON'T SEE WHAT.
THERE OKAY THERE'S AN OBJECTION
IN THE FAR RIGHT CORNER OF THE
CHAMBER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL I PORGES. BRADFORD BY.
CABALLERO BY CHANGE. HI DOLLY I
DONT. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. I GROVE.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO. JACKSON BY. JONES.
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. I AM A REAL NIELSEN. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE
STONE. I AMBERG BY A CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS. ROVE
THE TITLE. MERRELL. PRICE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIR CONCURRED IN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO CENTER
SKINNER IS READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ECHOING THE JAILS
THANK YOU SB FORTY TWO IS BACK
TO GETTING HOME SAFE ACT
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY NERO
THE REQUIREMENTS ON OUR COUNTY
JAILS AND ADDED THE DATA
COLLECTION PROVISION WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. HI
BATES HI BILL I BURGESS I
BRADFORD AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD. DOURADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROW NO. OF COURSE. ALL RIGHT
WAY TO GREENLAND IN THE MACHINE
SO WE'RE GONNA START OVER THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO BITES
BY SENATOR SKINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BY BILL BY BURGESS.
BY BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG BY DELHI. DODD DORADO.
BY GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE.
I JACKSON. I JONES. I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
AMARILLO. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO BURKE OUR CASKEY. I WINNER
HI WILK BY. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY DODD. HI BY GLAZER HI.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR OF THAT BY
SENATOR WIENER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WINNER
AND ACCOLADES TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB ONE TWENTY SEVEN
RETURNS TO US. I'M SORRY MR
SORRY SENATOR NO PROBLEMS
RESIDENT SP ONE TWENTY SEVEN
RETURN SOURCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
IT REQUIRES CALTRANS TO
IMPLEMENT COMPLETE STREETS
ELEMENTS WHEN IS ALREADY DOING
ROAD WORK IN AREAS THAT RUN
THROUGH OUR CITIES OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. REQUIRED COMPLETE
STREETS ELEMENTS SUCH AS
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
FACILITIES TO BE INCLUDING
CALTRANS ASSET MANAGEMENT PLAN
REQUIRES CALTRANS BEGINNING
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY TO SHOP
BUT WHEN CONSIDERING A PROJECT
IN AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
AREA. TO GIVE PRIORITY TO
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE TO THE INEQUITIES IN
THE STATE'S TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM AND MAKE OTHER ARE
CLARIFICATIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE OO. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUR I AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BILL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG NO
DALY NO DODD. HI DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA TIME
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MORNING
BY MORE LARK NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN. STONE. NO I'M BURKE.
IRAQ OWSKI HI WINNER BY WILK NO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THAT'S A MEMBER STERN. NO.
PRICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE
ASSEMBLY MINUTES ARE CONCURRED
IN NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR
SENATOR WIENER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT ONE
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR WINNER AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
CENTER WIENER. I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SB
ONE FORTY TWO RETURNS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY THIS WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO LIKE TATIAN
FACILITIES FOR NEW MOTHERS
RETURNING TO WORK ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS I DO THE FOLLOWING
THE LEAD THE BUILDING CODE A
STANDARD SECTION. ARE BUILDING
STANDARDS AS SECTION OF THE
BILL TO LEASE THE THREE YEAR
RECORDKEEPING PROVISIONS
DELETES THE OPTIONAL MODEL
LACTATION ROOM POLICY THAT
EMPLOYERS. ARE COULD
POTENTIALLY EMPLOYMENT AND ADDS
A REASONABLE STANDARD TO THE
UNDUE HARDSHIP PROVISION TO
MAKE IT CONSISTENT WITH BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI BATES.
NOBEL AYE PORGES. NO BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG. DALY
NO DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO AYE
HURTADO. JACKSON JONES. JACKSON
HI JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN. BY
STONE NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY I
WINNER BY WILK NO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MISSING MEMBER AT THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA HI. CHIANG
CHIANG NO. GALGIANI BY TITLE.
HI TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S OUR
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY SEVENTY SIX
AND THAT SENATOR WIENER ONCE
AGAIN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SAID ABOUT ONE FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR WIENER AND ACT
RELATING TO HIV PREVENTION.
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT WHEN IT RAINS
IT POURS COLLEAGUES AS THE
FIFTY SB ONE FIFTY NINE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
THIS MEASURE WILL EXPAND ACCESS
TO PREP AND PAP CRITICS CLOSER
PROPHYLAXIS IMPOSED EXPOSURE
PROP PROPHYLAXIS. TO PREVENT
HIV AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFIED DEFINITIONS
AND GUIDELINES NARROWED THE
SCOPE OF TESTING REQUIREMENTS
AND EXPANDED ACCESS TO THE
MEDICATIONS AS PROMISED WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN THAT
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION I WANT
TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL THERE IS AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
EIGHT DEBATER DISCUSSION. CENA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL BY
BURGESS HI BRADFORD. CABALLERO
HI BRADFORD HI CHANGE. HI DALY
AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROW. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. BY TADO BY JACKSON BY
JONES. LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK BY MERRELL. I NIELSEN. PAN
I PORTANTINO. BY ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE. FIVE A CASKEY BY
WIENER AYE WILK HI. YOUR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER. BY JONES.
NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT WE SHOULD BE
SENATOR JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SORT OF
A ONE SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR
JACKSON IN ACCRA INTO ATTORNEYS
THAT ARE JACKSON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE ALWAYS
EXCITING STATE BAR DUES BILL.
WE'RE BACK ON CONCURRENT
SISTERS THE ANNUAL BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES THE DUES THAT THE
STATE PARK IN CHARGE TO
ATTORNEYS LAST YEAR WE
INSTRUCTED THE STATE AUDITOR IN
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE TO AUDIT AND STUDY THE
BAR TO DETERMINE. IF THERE
SHOULD BE AN INCREASE IN FEES
AND IF SO WHAT AMOUNT IT WOULD
BE THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY SET THE FEE INCREASE
AT THE AMOUNT THE REFLECTS THE
AMOUNT SUGGESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE BILL ALSO
EXPRESSES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE STATE BAR
USED TO LICENSE FEES CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT AND THE
ALEJO'S REPORT AS WELL. THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES A PROVISION
TO INCREASE YOUR MIND OF INCOME
AN ATTORNEY CAN MAKE IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY FOR THE FEE DISCOUNT
FOR ATTORNEYS WHO MAKE A LESSER
AMOUNT OF MONEY WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ON CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU CENTER JACKSON ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SENATE GORGEOUS.
OUR PRESENCE PRESIDENT JUST A
CLARIFICATION THE THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS WHAT ARE THE CHARGES
NOW. SENATE JACKSON WOULD YOU
CARE TO ANSWER THAT WITH THE
CHARGES UNDER THE BILL WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE OUGHT
TO BE. FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT DOLLARS. AND WHAT WERE
THE- THROUGH THE CHAIR WHAT
WERE THEY BEFORE THE MEMONS
TODAY CHANGE AT ALL. THEY DO
CHANGE BUT I DON'T RECALL WHAT
IT WAS IF THERE HAD BEEN A FEE
INCREASE IN TWENTY YEARS SO
THERE WAS AN ADJUSTMENT. BASED
UPON THE LA AND THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT SWITCHERS WHAT
WE DESIGNATED DIRECTED THE BAR.
EXCUSE ME WHAT WE DIRECTED IN
LAST YEAR'S BAR DO BILLS. SO
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
AN ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE MARK AMOUNT
SHOULD BE AFTER A NO INCREASE
IN TWENTY YEARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR OR JUST ANY OTHER
DEBATERS QUESTION. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL AYE
PORGES. BRADFORD HI. CABALLERO
I CHAIN NO DALLY. DODD I DORADO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA TIME
ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL. I MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK BY MERRELL NO
NIELSEN. PAN. BY PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER HI
STERN HI. STONE NO NUMBER. OUR
CASKEY HI WINNER HI WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS.
DALLY GROVE NO. NIELSEN RUBIO
BY. I THIRTY ONE OF ICE THIRTY
ONE NO SIX THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE SENATOR RUBIO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. OKAY
RUBIO MISTER PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
TWO SEVENTY THREE THE PHOENIX
ACT WHICH IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO REPORT
REPORT ABUSE. ON BEHALF OF THE
MANY SURVIVORS OUT THERE WHO
FOLLOW THIS LEGISLATION CLOSELY
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY THE I'M NOT OKAY
COALITION LED BY EVAN RACHEL
WOOD. AND ASKED ME BE UNCLE AND
OTHER VICTIMS LIKE KATE RANTA
WHO SURVIVED THE GUN SHOTS OF
HER ABUSER AND SHEA FANKEL
CLAWSON WHO RECEIVED HER FIRST
PUNCH AT THIRTEEN. AND DIDN'T
REALIZE WHAT IT WAS UNTIL
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS LATER I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
DISAPPOINTMENT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS LORENA STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AFTER YOU SHOWED
COURAGE. SHARE YOUR HORRIFIC
EXPERIENCES AND PUT YOUR SAFETY
AT RISK BY SPEAKING OUT MY
COMMITTEES I LIKE TO THINK THIS
BODY FOR STUDY WITH ME. AND
SUPPORTING LANGUAGE THAT
REFLECTED A GREAT DEBATE
DISCUSSION IN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL THE
ADVOCATES. AND MY ALLIES HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE I THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR OUT FOR THINKING.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO. IT
DISCUSSION DEBATE SENATOR ALLEN
I JUST WANT TO SAY I KNOW ARE
TURNING TO THE REST THINGS
ALONG BUT I DO WANT TO MARK
THIS MOMENT AND JUST COMMEND
THE AUTHOR WHO IS WORK SO HARD
ON THIS VITALLY IMPORTANT
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT ISSUE HI
SHE HAS OPEN HER OWN HEART AND
SOUL AND CHANGE MANY LIVES
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND I KNOW
THAT THIS THIS THIS WILL IT
WILL HELP MANY MANY PEOPLE
GOING FORWARD AND I JUST WANNA.
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE HER
COURAGE AND HER LEADERSHIP ON
WHAT CONTINUES TO BE A HIT IN
AND UNDER REPORTED SCOURGE ALL
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY AND I
COMMEND HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU FOR SHARING THOSE COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THING AND THIS IS ACTUALLY A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTIONS. SEEING
NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR BELL WHO IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR BELL
AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION CENTER BELL. IS
THE PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
THESE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
ASSEMBLY PROVIDE MORE
CLARIFICATION ON HOW THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP FUNDS ARE TO BE
PROVIDED TO LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION IT AGENCIES.
THAT SPECIFICALLY THE
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE DETAILS ON
HOW TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
WILL RECEIVE THEIR FORMULA
DISTRIBUTIONS CRATES UP
ADDITIONAL COMPETITOR PROGRAM
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING ONLY
JUST SMALL COUNTIES. INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL PROVISIONS
FOR IMPLEMENTATION PURPOSES BOB
MEMBERS THE MEMBERS AKEN HIS
SIMPLY REMOVE THE LABOR
OPPOSITION TO THIS TO THIS
BILL. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY LARGE AND SMALL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO. FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE THEN I BIRDS
OF SUPPORT FOR THE CONCURRENCE
OF THESE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER BELL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL. BY
BURGESS NO BRADFORD. I COVER
GYRO BY CHAIN. DOLLY DOT I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO I JACKSON. JONES. HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING BY MORE LOCK I'M
REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER. STERN. HI STONE I AM
BURKE I WOULD COUNTY HI I
WINNER. HI WILK HI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHIANG. I DOUBT
DALY. JACKSON SKINNER BY. PRICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND UP NEXT FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR MITCHELL
AND SHE'S PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ IN ABOUT
THREE TWENTY NINE TO SENATOR
MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION CENTER MITCHELL
COLLEAGUES TO THE BILL THREE
TWENTY NINE IS BACK WORKING
CURRENTS AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT LANDLORDS THE GOAL
OF THE BILL IS TO MAKE IS TO BE
CLEAR THAT LANDLORDS CANNOT
REJECT ATTENDANT. SOLELY BASED
ON THEIR USE OF HOUSING
VOUCHERS TO PAY THE RENT THIS
IS NOT A MANDATE THE BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE LANDLORDS TO
PRIORITIZE A DOCTOR HOLDERS
OVER NOW BUDGET NON DOCTOR
USERS AGAIN LANDLORDS STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SCREEN
VOUCHER HOLDING THE APPLICANTS
USING THE SAME CRITERIA THEY
USE FOR ANY OTHER POTENTIAL
TENANT THEY WOULD SIMPLY BE
BARRED FROM REFUSING SOMEONE
APPLICATION BASED SOLELY ON
THEIR SOURCE OF INCOME THE BILL
WILL ENABLE FAMILIES WITH
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
SUCCESSFULLY APPLY FOR. AND
OBTAIN IF THEY QUALIFY HOUSING
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD IN
NEIGHBORHOODS OF OPPORTUNITY
AMENDMENTS MADE IN THE ASSEMBLY
SOME RESOLVE CHAPTER IN
CONFLICTS GIVEN THE STATE'S A
CHALLENGE WITH REGARD TO
HOUSING PEOPLE AND MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY FOR
SECTION EIGHT CAN ACTUALLY
FOUND HOUSING FIND HOUSING THAT
MEETS THEIR NEEDS I ASK FOR
YOUR I'D VOTE. ON CONCURRENCE
ON SENATE BILL THREE TWO NINE.
HE SAID OR MITCHELL. EIGHTY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL. BURGESS NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO HI CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TITLE HI JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING BY MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
BURKE OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK NO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BELL BY. GALGIANI GLAZER ROTH.
PRICE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR
CONCURRED IN. MOVING NOW
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE. SENATOR HUESO. PASS ON
FILE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY
SENATOR HILLS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOR TWENTY FIVE A SENATOR
HILL AND ACT RULING THE HEALING
ARTS CENTER HILL THANK YOU TO
RESIDENT ASSEMBLY MEANT
AMENDMENTS WERE MINOR AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY MEMONS
THANK YOU SIR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. THING NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BY BILL. BY BURGESS
I BRADFORD. BY CALOGERO I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
DORADO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ. I GROW BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES. I
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. I'M REAL
HI NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH BY RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE I
AMBERG OUR COUNTY I WIENER HI
WILK I YOUR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MITCHELL. HI STERN. BY. THEIR
PRICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR CONCURRED
IN OBJECTS FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR CENTER JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FOUR SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT GOING TO
TAXATION THAT ARE JACKSON THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THIS IS A
AN ITEM FOR CONCURRENCE IT'S A
BILL THAT WILL FINALLY BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF EXAMINING OUR
STATE COMPENDIUM OF TAX CREDITS
TAX DEDUCTIONS SALES TAX
EXEMPTIONS IN INCOME EXCLUSIONS
TO DETERMINE IF THOSE TAX
EXPENDITURES ARE ACHIEVING THE
GOALS FOR WHICH THEY WERE
CREATED. SINCE THE BILL LEFT
THIS HOUSE THERE ARE BEEN
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS NONE OF
WHICH CHANGE THE SUBSTANCE BUT
INSTEAD OF THE LA PERFORMING
THE ANALYSIS WE KNOW THE LA
DOESN'T HAVE MASSIVE RESOURCES
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WILL
BE DOING THE ANALYSIS AND THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO HAD A
PROVISIONS SUN SETTING THE
REVIEW BOARD AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE HOLD HEARINGS ON
THEIR REPORT WHICH WILL BE ON
THE EFFICACY OF THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES ARE WE ALSO
REMOVED TO PARTICULAR TAX
EXPENDITURES ONE FOR THE
CHARTABLE CONTRIBUTIONS. ARE
IN THE EXCLUSION OF LIFE
INSURANCE PROCEEDS FROM THE
CATEGORY OF INCOME WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE THANK.
YOU CENTER JACKSON ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NOBEL AYE FORGES.
BRADFORD I COVER EURO. CHANGE
NO DALY NO DOT I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE HURTADO I
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA. I'M
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. MON BY
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK MORALE.
NOPE NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER. I HAVE A COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK NO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PORGES.
CABALLERO NO MORE LOCK. SIZE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN
SENATE HIRSCHBERG I BELIEVE IS
PREPARED SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT FIVE
TWENTY BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT. AS YOU'VE
HEARD ME TALK ON THIS FLOOR AS
WE TRANSITION FROM THE OLD
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES MODELS
TO A ROBUST MODEL WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT RESOURCE ADEQUACY
CENTER PROCUREMENT AND THE-
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. FURTHER DEFINE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PROVIDERS
OF LAST RESORT ADD TRY TO REACH
THE JOINT APPLICATION PROCESS
REQUIRE THE CPC TO CONSIDER THE
EFFECTS OF MASS ON PLANNED
CUSTOMER MIGRATION AND MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGE LAST
YEAR I VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS. OKAY WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION ON THE FAR FAR FAR
RIGHT WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. BY BILL BY BURGESS HI
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO HI JANE I
DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. NO
GONZALEZ HIGHGROVE. HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES BY LABOR I AM
ACQUIRE MITCHELL. HI MONNING.
HI MORE LARK MORALE. I NIELSEN.
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN STONE.
I AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WIENER.
WILK HI HI MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. GROVE HI. MCGUIRE MORE
LOCK. NIELSEN HI SKINNER STERN
WIENER WIENER NOW. POPEYES
THIRTY THREE KNOWS TO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND NOW MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE CENTER STERN HE'S
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ IN ABOUT FIVE FORTY
TWO BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION. CENTER STERN. I
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AS
WE AS WE CONCLUDE THE- OR GET
CLOSE TO CONCLUDING THIS
EVENING. I WANT TO BRING BACK
SB FIVE FORTY TWO ONE
CONCURRENCE. THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
INJURIES AMONG OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. WHERE SUICIDE IS
TAKING MORE MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE FRONTLINES THEN FIRES. OR
ACCIDENTS. WE NEED TO GET PAST
THE NOTION OF P. T. S. I. AS A
DISORDER. BUT RATHER IS AN
INJURY THAT WE CAN HEAL FROM
THE AMENDMENTS. ADD SOME
STREAMLINING SOME COST
PROTECTIONS AND OTHER CRITICAL
PROVISIONS THAT MAKE THE BILL.
TIGHTER AND MORE WORKABLE WE
THINK IN THE FUTURE BUT. THE
POINT I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH
ALL MEMBERS IS THAT. OUR MEN
AND WOMEN WHO GO TO BATTLE FOR
US EVERY DAY TO KEEP US SAFE
WHETHER IT'S IN A WILDFIRE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY. OR MASS
SHOOTING LIKE WE HAD IN
THOUSAND OAKS. JUST LAST YEAR.
OR THE EVERY DAY. TRAFFIC
TRAGEDY. WORK PEOPLE ARE BEING
PULLED OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
THINGS ARE SEEING THAT CAN'T BE
ON SCENE. WHEN WE LOSE THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN TO SUICIDE
BECAUSE THE STIGMA THAT WE
ATTACHED OPPOSE DRAMATIC STRESS
INJURY. WE'RE NOT JUST LOSING
PUBLIC SERVANTS BUT WE'RE
LOSING A PIECE OF OURSELVES.
THIS TIME WE MOVE FORWARD AS A
STATE HERE AND SAID TO SEND A
SIGNAL TO THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
STAND UP FOR US EVERY DAY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO STAND UP FOR
THEM. SO WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATE
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I AM IN AND SUPPORT
THE BILL AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT JUST A COUPLE QUICK
STORIES I SEE THE FIREFIGHTER
BACK HERE BUT I WANT TO SHARE
STORY OF A BUDDY OF MINE WHO IS
A- HI WILL PATROLMAN. THEY USE
ABOUT. THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD.
ACTION ON THE FREEWAY. BIG
FIRE. HE JUMPED OUT OF THE CAR
RUNS OVER TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
HE TOOK A DIG. DEEP BREATH THE
CHEMICALS FROM THAT FIRE JUST
ATE UP HIS LUNGS JUST LIKE THAT
DOWN TO THE GROUND HE WENT. HIS
CAREER WAS OVER HIS FAMILY. WAS
IN SHOCK IN THIS WITH JUST ONE
INDIVIDUAL HE HAD TO LIVE WITH
THAT. GOD WILLING HE'S GETTING
STRONGER AS AS WE'RE TALKING
TODAY. BUT THAT JUST ONE STORY
BIG ABOUT THAT FIREFIGHTER THE
PICKED UP THAT SMALL BABY AND
THE LEGS FELL OFF BECAUSE OF
THE FIRE. THINGS OF THAT NATURE
THAT HAPPENED THAT I'VE HEARD
BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA THAT
THESE FIREFIGHTERS GO THROUGH
POLICE OFFICERS. ESPECIALLY THE
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN RIGHT NOW
MORE HIGH WILL PATROLMAN BEEN
KILLED ON THESE HIGHWAYS. BY
GUNFIRE THAN EVER BEFORE. AND
THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW SO HERE WE
ARE. NINE ELEVEN. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO RAN INTO THE
FIRE. RATHER THAN RUN FROM IT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT ARE
GIVING THEIR LIVES TO US AND
SEE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT THROUGHOUT THE
NATION. SO I'M SO PROUD THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS AND ALL OF US
STAND BEHIND OUR FIREFIGHTERS
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS. AND TODAY
IS THE DAY WE ACKNOWLEDGE NINE
ELEVEN WE WATER EACH AND
EVERYONE. OF YOU AND FOR THIS
BY OUR REGION I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BY BILL I BURGESS. HI BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG. AYE
DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
BY GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO I TADO I JACKSON BY
JONES I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL BY MORNING. BY MORE
LOCK MORALE. NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER I STERN. STERN AYE
STONE. I AMBERG I WILL CASKEY
BY WINNER BY WILK. HI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE. OR LOCK
GROW BY WARLOCK MORALE BY.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE OH ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
VERY CLOSE TO APPROACHING MY
FAVORITE TIME OF THE NIGHT
WHICH IS A SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR BUT PRIOR TO THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE LIFTING THE CALL
ON A LOT OF BILLS SO IF YOU
COULD STAY ON THE FLOOR
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THROUGH
THESE QUICKLY. FIRST UP WILL BE
FILE ITEM TWENTY. SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI. EYES
FORTINOS OR. PRICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED BUT
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. HI
ARCHULETA HI CABALLERO NO. DALY
NO GALGIANI NO GLAZER. BY MORE
LOCK NO NIELSEN NO NUMBER.
NUMBER NO. I TWENTY FIVE TO
FIFTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
FIFTEEN MEASURE PASSES. BUT
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO.
ALLEN HI BATES NO PORGES. NO
STONE. FIVE THREE THE MYSTERY
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO THREE THEY
MET AT THE MEASURE PASSES UP
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE.
ALLEN. I BATES. NO MORRELL. I
THREE SEVEN US TO ICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES BUT NECKS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI
BATES. BURGESS HI. ZERO I DOLLY
BY GROWTH I HILL TADO. JONES HI
MITCHELL. I AM A REAL. NIELSEN
I AM REAL AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER.
I STERN BY WORK OWSKI I WIENER.
HI BATES SORRY. HILL AYE TOTAL
WHY. I SUPPORTING THOSE ARE.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SIX. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. BY BATES.
OUR AYE BURGESS. HI DOLLY OUR
GROWTH I HILL BY HER TADO HI
JONES. HI MORALE. SKINNER. LIKE
OWSKI CALCIUM. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
BATES. NO BURGESS NO DALY.
GROWTH NO HILL. HI HER TADO. HI
MORE LOCK. SKINNER. I STERN BY
WHAT CASKEY BY. I FORTY PRICE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. UP NEXT FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI BATES.
BURGESS NO DALLY. GLAZER HI
GROWTH. I HILL AYE HER TADO I
JONES NO MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI.
GROVE I DON'T KNOW. BATES NO.
PRICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. I BATES
AYE DALLY HIGHER GROWTH. I HILL
HI TADO. BY SKINNER. I STERN BY
WHAT CASKEY. PRICE THIRTY NINE
DOES ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. HI BATES HI BURGESS.
DALY WE'RE JUST AYE DALY AYE.
GROVE I HILL HI TADO. I SKINNER.
I STERN BY Y. CASKEY HI. BY THE
FOR YOU KNOW THEIR EYES FORTY
NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN I BY.
BATES NO GORGEOUS YEAH NO
BRADFORD. DALY. NO YEAH THE DOG.
I BY OKAY. GROVE. NO HILL BY
TADO. SKINNER. BY STERN BY WHAT
CAL SKI. BY TITLE II BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
RADFORD. PRICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN MEASURE PASSES. AT AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE EVERYBODY IN
THE CHAMBER TECHNOLOGIES FORMER
SENATOR. MARTY BLOCK THIS
YEAR'S. SENATOR ARCHER ARCHER
LET HIM. I'D LIKE TO JUST TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT TO SAY WE GOT A
SPECIAL GUEST IN THE HOUSE AND
I THINK THEY'RE BACK THERE OF
MY WIFE ROSE AND MY DAUGHTER IN
LAW TIFFANY WELL LADIES AND
JONES. WELL I GOT TO SHARE
SOMETHING WITH YOU TIFFANY R.
JILLETTE AS A WEST POINT
GRADUATE FORMER CAPTAIN UNITED
STATES ARMY A TOUR IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ AND SHE'S
HERE FOR FLEW IN FROM GEN HER
HUSBAND MY SON THE STATION AT
THE PENTAGON SHE WANTED COME
AND SPEND SOME TIME WITH MY
WIFE AND I AND OF COURSE IS MY
WIFE ROSE. WELCOME TO
SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
NOW MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. HI
BATES. GORGEOUS DELHI GROVE.
HILL. HI HER TADO I MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN SKINNER. I STERN BY
WACHOWSKI HI. HIGHS THIRTY
NIELSEN HI. PRICE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS THREE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI BATES I BRADFORD. I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE GROWTH. HI
HILL I HER TADO I AM A REAL. I
SKINNER I STERN. HI WHAT CASKEY
HI. I SUPPORTING ALLIES FORTY
NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. HI BATES.
NO CHANGE. HI DALY. GONZALEZ
GROVE NO HILL BY HER DATO.
JACKSON MITCHELL. I'M MORE LOCK.
MERRELL NO NIELSEN. SKINNER I
STERN. BY COUNTY I WILK. HI
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS FOR MEASURE
PASSES. BOB X. FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. CHIANG HI DOLLY. BY
GROVE. BY HER TADO. I SKINNER.
WHY CASKEY HI BATES AYE SKINNER
BY. AS FOR YOU KNOW THEIR EYES
FORTY NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES
I'M NEXT FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SIX MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS.
GROVE TADO. NIELSEN. FOR JUST
BY HER TITLE II. GROVE AYE
NIELSEN AYE. MORALE I DON'T
KNOW. HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ONE MEASURE PASSES. BUT NEXT
FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY FOUR
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. HI
DOLLY I WINNER. HI. I FORTY NO
SURPRISE FORTY NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES BUT NEXT FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS. CABALLERO BY DAILY.
NIELSEN WIENER. WIENER AYE.
NIELSEN NO. PRICE THIRTY KNOWS
A MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS. DALY. NO
GROWTH. NO PORTANTINO. HI RUBIO.
I WIENER. BY. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
BUT NEXT FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. BATES
DOLLY I GROWTH. NIELSEN. PRICE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT FILE
ITEM TWO OH ONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. BATES
BATES NO. CHANGE. CHIANG AHRI
GROWTH. GROVE NO. OKAY ATKINS.
PRICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS A
MEASURE PASSES MOVING RIGHT
ALONG TO FILE ITEM TWO OH TWO.
YOUR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BATES.
WE'RE JUST. ZERO I DALY I
GROWTH. MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE STONE.
PRICE THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT ITEM IS
TWO OH THREE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS CABALLERO. I DORADO.
MORE LOCK. PRICE THIRTY SIX
KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES BUT
NEXT FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BATES.
BELL BY BURGESS. DORADO I
GROWTH. JACKSON. BY MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE NO. GROW BY. HI STE
HI IS THIRTY ONE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM. TWO
TWO ZERO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA BATES. NO. BURGESS NO
CHANGE NO DORADO. GROWTH DRAWS
A HIGH. GROVE MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN NO ROTH. GROVE NO.
PRICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES BUT NEXT
FILE ITEM TWO TWENTY ONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BATES. HI JANE HIGH.
DODD. I DORADO HI JACKSON.
MITCHELL. SURE YEAH RIGHT.
JONES DOES NOT AYE JACKSON AYE.
MITCHELL AYE. ICE FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. BUT NEXT ITEM
TO TWENTY TWO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. I BATES I. BRADFORD.
BY CHAIN BY BURKE DATO. MORE
LUCK. PORTANTINO HI. THIRTY ONE
SIZE THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO TO THREE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES BY BURGESS.
CABALLERO. GORGEOUS I CAREER I
CHIANG BY GROVE. HI JONES BY
MITCHELL. MID JULY. PRICE
THIRTY A NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
CENTER HER TADO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE A TO REQUEST FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT AB SIX BE REMOVED
FROM TO BE MOVED TO BE AN ACTOR
FILE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. THE DESK WILL NOTE. SAM
REQUIRED NIGHT SEE YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS THE PRESIDENT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. GRATEFUL FOR HARPER TODAY
SIR REALLY NOTED. SENATOR ALLEN.
UNDER MOTIONS SO I'D LIKE TO
MOVE. FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THIS
IS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
SO NUMBER QUIRK TO THE INACTIVE
FILE AT THE OTHERS REQUEST THE
DESK WILL NOTE. CENTER HUESO.
OTHER RELIGIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU WANT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
CLEAR FIND THE INTENT OF SB
THREE ONE THREE WHICH WAS VOTED
ON EARLIER THIS EVENING. AND I
HAVE THE LETTER HERE TO SUBMIT
TO THE JOURNAL. PLEASE BRING TO
THE DEATH. LIKE. WHICH OF THE
THOUGH DOES IT
. MR MR MAJORITY
LEADER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR MISTER PRESIDENT PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
ASSEMBLY MEASURE TWELVE ALL
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK WILL NOTE. KANTOR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WILL BE PLACE ON TODAY
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS
SIDE OF THE CHAMBERS BEEN VERY
NINETY TODAY VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN YOU. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE PLACED
ON TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS FORTY FIVE.
FORTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT.
495-051-5350 FIVE. FIFTY SIX
FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. SIXTY.
SIXTY FOUR. SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT. 778-081-8680
. EIGHT
NINETY ONE NINETY TWO NINETY
THREE NINETY FIVE NINETY SIX
ONE OH TO ONE OH FI
ONE OH NINE. MISTER SECRETARY.
YEAH WE TAKE THE WAY TAKE THE
SPECIAL CONSENT COUNTER NOW
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ALL THE BILLS SENATE BILL
636-715-3150 SIX ONE SIXTY FIVE
TO A 228-289-3409 THREE SIXTY
FIVE. THREE SEVENTY FIVE THREE
FIFTY TWO. SIX FIFTY SIX SIX
NINETY ONE SIXTY ONE NINETY ONE
NINETY SIX. 403-994-4054 FIFTY
ONE. FOR FIFTY FIVE FOUR
SEVENTY ONE FOR NINETY. FIVE
FORTY ONE FIVE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHTY SIX FIVE EIGHTY NINE
FIVE NINETY EIGHT
610-640-7670. SIX SEVENTY SIX
SEVEN SIXTEEN THEM FORTY TO.
SEVENTY FIVE INSTEAD OF THE
FIVE NINETY ONE. ARE THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS TO USING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF THIRTY
NINE TWO ZERO. SEEING NONE THIS
SENATE COULD AT THE SPECIAL
THIS IS THE SENATE SPECIAL
CASSETTE CALENDAR PASSES THIRTY
NINE TWO ZERO. WITH THAT LET'S
GO TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
SENATOR HILL. IT WAS THE CHAIR
OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE WILL
MEET TOMORROW MORNING IN HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AT EIGHT THIRTY OR ACTUALLY
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ARE WHICH
IS SCHEDULED FOR. PRIOR TO THAT
COMMITTEE SO. FIRST WILL BE
EDUCATION SECOND WILL BE LABOR
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU SIR CENTER
LEYVA. WELL I APPRECIATE CENTER
HILL KIND OF MAKING MY NAILS
BUT FOR ME BUT THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT EIGHT
THIRTY IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
TO HEAR ONE BILL AB FORTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA. ALL THE
SENATOR ON BURKE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
CONGRADULATIONS OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE YOU ALL GET TO COM AND
MEET ONE FINAL TIME TOMORROW IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY AT NINE AM
GREAT THANK YOU SIR. THERE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE MEETING
TOMORROW A ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE IN THE AFTERNOON
TIME TO BE DETERMINED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE. ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER
WIENER I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
I WAS SCHEDULED TO MEET AT NINE
THIRTY TOMORROW WE WILL BE
MEETING TOMORROW BUT THERE WILL
BE NINE THIRTY WILL BE UPON THE
CALL OF THE CHAIR AND WE WILL
ANNOUNCES DURING SESSION IN
TERMS OF EXACTLY WHEN OR WHERE
IT WILL BE. BUT NOT AT NINE
THIRTY. THANK YOU SIR CENTER
PORANTINO. THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL MEET TOMORROW AT
NINE AM AND FORTY TWO OH TWO.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. THREE
NINE MR MAJORITY LEADER. MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS ALL OF
THE OUR IS YOUNG. OUR WORK HAS
BEEN STRONG WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FIFTY CENT AND ASSEMBLY
MEASURES EIGHTY SEVEN SENATE
MEASURES HAVE BEEN COMPLETED
FOR TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR MEASURES DISPENSED
WITH TODAY. THAT'S GOOD NEWS
BUT DON'T FORGET THERE'S ALWAYS
WORK TO COME AND SO WITH THAT
AND TO THE LOVED ONES AT HOME
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED
AND WE RECONVENE TOMORROW
MORNING THURSDAY AT TEN O'CLOCK%
THANK YOU CAN CERTAINLY GET
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE
CHURCH AND WE WILL RECONVENE.
HERE TOMORROW AT TEN AM HAVE A
GREAT EVENING